AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT -- WE WILL
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE ARE
WAITING FOR A MEMBER OF THE
OPPOSITE PARTY AND THEN WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE WE
COMMITTEE.
DESPITE THE ABSENCE [inaudible]
SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE NOTE THE
FOLLOWING [inaudible]
AND MANY.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE NOTE THE
FOLLOWING THE FOLLOWING EASURES
BEEN PULLED FILE ITEM.
NINE AB EIGHT NINE SIX EIGHT HAS
BEEN FULL.
THAT LEAVES -- TODAY'S AGENDA
WITH. TWENTY FOUR MEASURES ON ON
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NO. SIX MEN. FOR MEASURES WITH
THE FOLLOWING SIX MEASURES ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE SIX MEASURES ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARE FILE ITEM.
THREE FILE ITEM TWELVE FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
AND FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE ADDITIONALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL QUIRK HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
ALSO ONE OF PUBLICLY THANK.
TECHNICAL PLEASE JOIN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- STEAM AS A
RETIRED A NEW IT EARLIER THIS
YEAR THIS WILL BE HIS LAST
HEARING AND SO NEXT YEAR.
WHEN HOPEFULLY DECIDES COME BACK
TO WORK WITH US AGAIN?
LASTLY PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR
GENERAL GUIDELINE FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE.
IS TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FOR TWO
WITNESSES WERE SUPPORT. TO
WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION AND TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK.
EACH FOR TWO MINUTES.
HOLDERS AND ENTITIES THAT ARE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION
WILL BE ALLOWED TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES WHEN I CALLED FOR
TWEETERS.
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
MISTER SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT -- BEFORE YOU ON THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND WE
TAKE THE COMMITTEE -- AMENDMENTS
AS REPORTED IN THE OUT NOW SO SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AB SIXTEEN TWENTY WOULD
PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH AN INCREASED
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
BY REDUCING THE ATTENDANCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR IN STATE
TUITION I TO TWO YEARS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
MISTER -- CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITH THIS IS IN
SUPPORT.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR A. B..
SIXTEEN TWENTY MY NAME IS ALICE
I AM AN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ORGANIZER A CREE RESOURCE CENTER
AND ON TALKING TO COST YOU KNOW
WITHOUT DHAKA IN AB FIVE FORTY
ELIGIBILITY.
MY FAMILY AND I HAVE BEEN
RESIDING IN CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE
YEARS NOW AND I'VE ATTENDED UCLA
FOR THREE YEARS STUDYING APPLIED
MATHEMATICS.
MY LIFE IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND AS EVIDENCE HERE I BROUGHT
MY TAX RETURN.
OF MY DRIVER'S LICENSE WITH MY
CALIFORNIA ADDRESS MY TRANSCRIPT
FROM UCLA AND MY COMMUNITY HERE
TODAY TO THIS HEARING. TO SHOW
YOU THAT I AM INDEED A MEMBER OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NEVER THE LESS I STILL DO NOT
QUALIFY UNDER AB FIVE FORTY AM
REQUIRED TO PAY NON RESIDENT
TUITION.
IN FACT MANY ON TALKING TO
STUDENTS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
STILL DO NOT QUALIFY.
BECAUSE THE MOST RECENT
EXPANSION OF AB FIVE FORTY SB
SIXTY EIGHT WAS WRITTEN WITH
SPECIFIC CASES OF STUDENTS IN
MIND.
THOSE WHO HAVE A YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND WENT TO COMMITTEE
COLLEGE.
AS A RESULT IT HAS ACCIDENTALLY
LEFT OUT A POPULATION OF
STUDENTS THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED BY.
NOT ACKNOWLEDGING ANY ATTENDANCE
AT ANY CALIFORNIA HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS OTHER THAN A
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AND LOCAL SCHOOL.
AND BY PUTTING A LIMIT ON NUMBER
OF YEARS OF COMMITTEE COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE TOWARDS -- COUNTED
COUNTED TOWARD ELIGIBILITY.
SCHOOLS ALSO DO NOT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO GO BACK TO COMMITTEE
CALLED IT AN OPEL SCHOOLS IF THE
STUDENT IS ALREADY INVOLVED IN
THE FOUR YEAR HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS.
EVEN IF THEY'RE WILLING TO GO
BACK AND FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SB.
SIXTY EIGHT THAT IS WHY WE MUST
PASS A BE SEEN TWENTY NOW TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO RESOURCES FOR
THESE STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE INVESTED THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES HERE IN CALIFORNIA JUST
NOT THAT THREE YEARS A K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION?
SO TODAY I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A BI.
SIXTEEN TWENTY AND FORTY
ACADEMIC JOURNEYS OF ON TALKING
TO STUDENTS THAT ARE QUALIFYING
MEMBERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS WITHOUT THE OTHER.
NIGHT I HAVE BEEN LIVING IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR NINETEEN GARETH AND
I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND THING.
OF THE THINKING FOR HIGHER THE
CULTURAL SEEING SIDE BUT THEN I
HAD THIS PRIVILEGE.
IN THE IN OTHER STATES.
I COULDN'T ROLE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
BUT IT TOOK ME SO LONG BECAUSE I
DO IT ALL THE WAY BECAUSE I'D I
DIDN'T HAVE ANY FINANCIALLY.
AND I HAD TO WORK IN A STUDY OF
THE THINK TANK.
BUT I A I LOVE THE WAY TO A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH
EXCELLENT GRADES.
IN A EYE WITH A FAKE THAT
THROUGH A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
BUT THE I WAS I THINK THE
THOUGHT OUT OF THE STATUS TO
THEM.
AND I COULDN'T AFFORD IS TO
SHOWN SOUL I HAD TO STOP THAT
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE MANY
MANY MEMBERS AND IN.
MANY CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY THAT
DON'T KNOW QUALIFIED I THINK THE
THING OF ME.
IN THEY HAVE TO STOP IS STARTING
THEY HAD TO PULL MAYBE THEY'LL
HAVE TO TAKE A FEW CLASSES IN IT.
WORK AT THE SAME TIME
[inaudible]
SOME.
I KNOW ALL THEY HAD LIVED FOR
MANY YEARS LET ME IN THIS IN
THIS.
AND IS A STATE AND THEY HAD A
STUDY FOR SEVERAL YEARS BECAUSE
HER SON TO THE TRUE THOUGH THE
CALL THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS.
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ARE SEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT.
AND IF ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WOULD GIVE THEIR NAME IN THE
GROUP THAT THERE WITH.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RYAN
WHO STILL A PART OF JAPAN AND
FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
TODAY I SEE OUR YOUTH ORGANIZER
WHICH YOU LINE STRONG SUPPORT.
GLORIA AROUND WHICH THE LINE I
STRONG SUPPORT.
HON SO CHOI UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
AND A CONSTITUENT OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ALISON HOW AND I'M
FROM MONTEREY PARK AND I SUPPORT
AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY HELLO MY NAME IS
DIANA -- COMING FROM WITH GRAND
RESOURCE CENTER AS WELL AS FROM
COST THE FULLER TEN ALSO SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE RICARDO
AND COMING FROM ANAHEIM IN WITH
THE KOREAN RESOURCE CENTER IN
FULL SUPPORT.
I AM JOEY FORCE I FOUNDER OF
AMANDA VOTERS I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL CALLING FROM
CAL STATE FULLERTON OF FLOW
STATE AT CYPRESS CAUGHT CYPRESS
ORANGE COUNTY.
ARE YOU ALSO SUPPORTS.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA MOVIE RECENT
GRABBER USE YOUR MIND ALSO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND I WAS
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HELLO CONSISTS TRANSFERABLE
VALLEY I'M HERE REPRESENTING
INLAND EMPIRE OF WORK FOR A
SERMON OF MANY COLLEGE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ALSO.
BUS CONVENE -- FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY OF STANISLAUS AND I'M
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S MONEY END UP ONCE
THEY'RE FROM SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS GOING TO LOOK
ABOUT THAT FROM SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE AND ALSO STRONG SUPPORT
THIS.
HI MY NAME IS LUCY OF THE CREAM
RESOURCE CENTER AS WELL AS A
STUDENT AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH
I STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SKY WAGNER I'M A
STUDENT CAL STATE LONG BEACH AND
ALSO WITH MARCH FOR OUR LIVES
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA CAM I
WORKING IT DOWN CARRY OUT OF
KOREA RESOURCE CENTER IS --
PARENTS SELL WHEN I FEAR AND I'M
STRONG ENOUGH SEPARATE.
HI MALINA ABDOULAYE A PROFESSOR --
CAL STATE LA AND ALSO WITH BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS ACCURATELY
HELLUVA I'M AT RECENT GRADUATE
AT SAC STATE -- I'M ALSO WITH
SECOND LINE -- BROWN BRACE AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S JESSIE BEECHAM I'M
GOING TO BE A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND I'M GOING TO
HUMBOLDT STATE I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME THE ENSURE FROM WITH
BEND THE ARC OF JEWISH
PARTNERSHIP FOR JUSTICE AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SAY NONE OF I THANK THE OTHER
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD --
THANK THE STUDENTS FOR COMING --
TO GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY -- AS AS
A WAS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I
SAW MANY STUDENTS WHO WERE.
OF NOT HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TEACH BECAUSE THEIR THEIR
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS.
AND I THINK THIS IS A A GOOD
BILL AND WE WILL KEEP THE VOTE
AND WHEN WE HAVE A A QUORUM.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR MAKING
SURE THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE -- WE HAVE A ITEM.
SIXTEEN AB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible] SIX
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
AND MEMBERS -- ME HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU A. B..
FOURTEEN SIXTY THE ETHNIC
STUDIES REQUIREMENTS -- SEE
ISSUE EDUCATES THE MOST
ETHNICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY AN
ACADEMICALLY DIVERSE STUDENT
BODY IN THE NATION.
AND THAT DIVERSITY SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED BY THE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF A
CURRICULUM THAT IS INCLUSIVE AND
REFLECTIVE OF THE STUDENT
CULTURES AND BACKGROUNDS A
SERVER.
ETHNIC STUDIES SCHOLARSHIP
FOCUSES ON THE CENTRAL ROLE THAT
RACE AND ETHNICITY PLAY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AMERICAN HISTORY
CULTURE AND SOCIETY.
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE
STRUCTURAL CONTENTS OF POWER.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCES OFFICE LAUNCHED A TASK
FORCE ON THE ADVANCEMENT OF
ETHNIC STUDIES COMPRISED OF
FACULTY DEPARTMENT CHAIRS
PROGRAM DIRECTORS COORDINATORS
DEAN'S ACADEMIC SENATE CHEERS.
AND PRESIDENT FROM THE C. ISSUE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
TASK FORCE FINAL REPORT WAS TO
MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES A GENERAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT THROUGHOUT
THE CSU SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION THE REPORT
EMPHASIZED THE CRITICAL ROLE
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES PLAY AND
THE REALIZATION OF THIS ISSUE
MISSION WHICH INCLUDES A GOAL TO
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE
INTERNATIONALLY MULTICULTURAL
SOCIETY.
STUDIES AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY HAVE FOUND THAT BOTH
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND WHITE
STUDENTS BENEFIT ACADEMICALLY
AND SOCIALLY FROM TAKING ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES.
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
CONTRIBUTE TO IMPROVE GRADUATION
RATES POSITIVE CAMPUS CLIMATE
OUTCOMES AND ARE VITAL TO
STUDENT SUCCESS BEYOND COLLEGE
IN AN INCREASINGLY DIVERSE WORK
FORCE IN SOCIETY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY WAS TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY AMERICAN HISTORY THAT
I'M THAT EVERY AMERICAN HISTORY
IS TAUGHT.
IN VALUE BY HAVING TO SEE ISSUE
SYSTEM INCLUDE THE COMPLETION OF
AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE AS A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
ACADEMIC SENATE TO WORK WITH
THIS ISSUE COUNSEL ON ETHNIC
STUDIES TO DEVELOP CORE
COMPETENCIES TO BE CHEEKY ****.
BY STUDENTS TAKE IN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE.
AB FOURTEEN SAYS SIXTY SPECIFIES
THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD NOT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
REQUIRED TO GRADUATION.
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
INCREASE TIME TO DEGREE.
THE BILL A STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT THE ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
COULD DOUBLE COUNT FOR MULTIPLE
REQUIREMENTS AND IF A STUDENT
TOOK AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE FULFILL.
THE COMMITTEE ANNA ANNA A NOT AN
ANALYSIS NOTED THAT CURRENT
ARTICULATED PATHWAYS TO THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE TO BE RE
EXAMINED IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE
AND ETHNIC STUDIES REQUIREMENTS.
WE BELIEVE THE BENEFITS STUDENTS
WOULD GAIN OUTWEIGHS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF IT
EXAMINING PREVIOUS PRACTICES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRESCRIBED
CURRICULUM COURSE CONTENT OR
STUDENT LEARNING OUTCOMES WHAT
IS THIS BILL LIMIT FACULTY
MEMBERS OUR STUDENTS ENGAGE.
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN
INTELLECTUAL DEBATE WHATSOEVER
AND THEREFORE DOES NOT INFRINGE
ON ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE AT LAW
SANDERS DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SACRAMENTO STATE BE ISSUE THE S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA.
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR BLACKS
CITIES THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
LATIN AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR NIGGLE
WOMEN.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY IS
DOCTOR MILLION OF DO LOVE
PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF PAN
AFRICAN STUDIES AT CAL STATE LA.
ANTOINETTE SADLER'S STUDENT CAL
STATE LA.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US -- AND
GREETINGS -- CHAIR MEDINA -- SO
I JUST WANT TO CORRECT THAT ASIA
CLOWNEY IS ACTUALLY THE STUDENT
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING -- SO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MORE
THAN TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FACULTY LIBRARIANS COACHES AND
COUNSELLORS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WHICH SERVES
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IS PROFESSOR
AND CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PAN AFRICAN STUDIES AT CAL STATE
LA.
IS A DELEGATE TO THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL FOR BLACK STUDIES A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION.
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES AND IS ONE
WHOSE LIFE LIFE WAS TRANSFORMED
BY BLACK STUDIES AS A STUDENT AT
BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL AND LATER
HOWARD UNIVERSITY -- ALSO IS AN
ORGANIZER WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN A MEMBER OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES TASK FORCE THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER MENTIONED
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FOURTEEN SIXTY THE TIMES IN
WHICH WE LIVE MAKE THE CALL FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES WITH AN ETHNIC
STUDIES REQUIREMENTS URGENT.
WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING AND
EXPERIENCING IS WHITE SUPREMACY
IN TERMS OF POLICY AND VIOLENCE
HATE CRIMES ARE SOARING AND AS
EDUCATORS AND ONE'S INVESTED IN
TEACHING?
OUR STATE AND THE STUDENTS IN
OUR STATE TO THINK CRITICALLY
AND BE AGENTS OF CHANGE WE HAVE
A ROLE IN TURNING THAT TIED.
WE KNOW ETHNIC STUDIES TO BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION. FIFTY
YEARS AGO AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS FACULTY AND
COMMUNITY BAND TOGETHER TO
DEMAND AN EDUCATION THAT SPOKE
TO WHEN EMPOWERED STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
ETHNIC STUDIES IS MEANT TO FILL
GAPS IN TERMS OF SUBJECT AREA
AND KNOWLEDGE AND CORRECT
INTENTIONAL MISREPRESENTATIONS
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR THEIR
HISTORIES CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXPERIENCES.
BUT ETHNIC STUDIES IS ALSO MEANT
TO DO MORE.
WE ADOPTED DIFFERENT PEDAGOGICAL
APPROACH THAT ELICITS A COAL
LEARNING MODEL THAT VALUES
STUDENT KNOWLEDGE AND LIVED
EXPERIENCES IT ALLOWS STUDENTS
OF COLOR TO ATTACH TO THE
LEARNING PROCESS.
A PISTOL LOGICALLY THE WAY IN
WHICH WE STUDY IN WHAT WE STUDY
FOR THE SCHOLARSHIP IT'S
GENERATED IS MEANT TO BE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITIES
RATHER THAN TO STUDY UPON
COMMUNITIES.
I KNOW THAT THERE IS OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
AND THEY CITE ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT
AND WHAT.
ACADEMIC FREEDOM ACTUALLY IS.
THE CONCEPT OF ACT ACADEMIC
FREEDOM IS ADVOCATED MOST
FIERCELY BY THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS WHICH I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF MEANS PRIMARILY THAT.
BOTH FACULTY MEMBERS AND
STUDENTS CAN ENGAGE IN
INTELLECTUAL DEBATE WITHOUT FEAR
OF CENSORSHIP OR RETALIATION.
THAT MEANS THAT ACADEMIC FREEDOM
CALLS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
A BILL LIKE THIS RIGHT -- WE
HAVE TWO ARTICLES FOR YOUR
REVIEW THAT SPEAK TO OUR
DEFINITION OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM
FROM INSTITUTIONS THAT SAFEGUARD
ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT OUTLINE
COURSE CONTENT.
ON THE QUESTION OF DOES THIS
BILL TRAMPLE ON ACADEMIC FREEDOM
BY DIRECTING QUART COURSE
MATERIALS THE ANSWER IS A
RESOUNDING NO.
FINALLY ANY CONCERN ABOUT TIME
TO GRADUATION CAN BE QUICKLY
ALLAYED AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
THE AUTHOR OUTLINED THIS IS A
OVERLAY REQUIREMENTS IT WOULD
MEAN.
THAT CLASSES THAT STUDENTS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO TAKE WOULD
BE TAKEN IN ETHNIC STUDIES AT
LEAST ONE WOULD BE TAKEN IN
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR EXAMPLE
RATHER THAN TAKING ORAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
OKAY A STUDENT COULD TAKE BLACK
ORAL TRADITIONS RATHER THAN
TAKING THE CONSTITUTION A
STUDENT COULD TAKE RACE
GOVERNMENTS IN THE CONSTITUTION.
WE'VE NOT REALLY ADDRESSED
RACIALAND SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES
IN THIS COUNTRY THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR THAT
HISTORY OF ETHNIC STUDIES TO
UNDER THE HISTORY OF THE
COMMUNITY WORK THAT FOUNDED IT.
TO UNDER THE HISTORY OF THE
FACULTY AND STUDENTS WHO FOUGHT
FOR IT AND FIFTY YEARS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION I THINK THAT THIS BILL
DOES A WONDERFUL JOB AND
ADVANCING ETHNIC STUDIES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DINA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY MY
NAME IS ASIA CLOWNEY I AM A
JUNIOR AT CALIFORNIA STATE.
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES DOUBLE
MAJORING IN COMMUNICATION AND
PAN AFRICAN STUDIES I'M ALSO A
PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK SITTING
UNION.
I SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY AND
THE CREATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES --
ADD REQUIREMENT IN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM AS YOU MAY KNOW ETHNIC
STUDIES WAS FOUGHT FOR AND WON
BY STUDENTS FACULTY AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FIFTY YEARS
AGO AS A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
LONGEST STUDENT LED STRIKE IN
THE NATION.
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
BLACK POWER MOVEMENT ONE OF THE
KEY DEMANDS WITH THE CREATION OF
DISCIPLINES THAT SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO THE EXPERIENCES OF BLACK
PEOPLE.
CHECKING NEGLECT THE NEXT PEOPLE
NOT NATIVE PEOPLE IN ASIAN FOLKS
MY CAMPUS CAST THE DELAYED WITH
THE SECOND UNIVERSITY IN THE
COUNTRY SO WHEN A BLACK CITY'S
DEPARTMENT.
WHICH IS PAN AFRICAN STUDIES ON
OUR CAMPUS AND THE FIRST HAVE TO
KIND OF STUDIES.
I'M HERE TO CONTINUE IN THAT
TRADITION.
AND I'M AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
WHY ETHNIC STUDIES NEED TO BE A
REQUIREMENT.
ETHNIC STUDIES IS NOT ONLY
NECESSARY BUT ESSENTIAL FOR A
SOLID EDUCATIONAL FOUNDATION AND
THE WORLD WE LIVE IN IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
MAY BETTER COMMUNICATE WITH ONE
ANOTHER FROM DIFFERENT ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS.
IT WAS WHEN I WROTE IT PAN
AFRICAN STUDIES THAT I GAVE THE
CONSCIOUSNESS ABOUT MY BLACK
HISTORY NOT THE HISTORY THAT HAS
BEEN ALTERED TO SUPPORT THE
MASTER NARRATIVE.
BUT THE HISTORY THAT HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM ME UNTIL I GOT
TO COLLEGE.
RECENTLY I WAS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN PRESENT MY
RESEARCH AT THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
FOR BLACK STUDIES CONFERENCE IN
NEW ORLEANS.
DURING SPRING BREAK I IN ABOUT
FIFTEEN OTHER SCHOLARS
PARTICIPATED IN A SERVICE
LEARNING TRIP IN MONTGOMERY
ALABAMA.
BOTH EXPERIENCES WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN POSSIBLE HAD I NOT BEEN A
PAN AFRICAN STATES COURSES.
I WAS NOT INTERESTED IN COMING
TO COLLEGE I WENT TO THREE
DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS ONE OF
WHICH WAS A MILITARY SCHOOL
SCHOOL DID NOT INTEREST ME
BECAUSE I DID NOT SEE MYSELF OR
MY STORE IN THE THINGS WE WERE
LEARNING.
MY FRESHMAN YEAR OF COLLEGE I
TOOK A CRITICAL RACE THEORY
COURSE ANY CHANGE MY LIFE.
I UNDERSTOOD THAT MY EXPERIENCE
WAS AN EXPERIENCE THAT WHAT THAT
WAS HAD BY MANY BLACK WOMEN.
I WAS ABLE TO ARTICULATE MYSELF
USING SCHOLARLY VERBIAGE I
LEARNED THAT AS A BLACK WOMAN MY
EXPERIENCE IS DIFFERENT THAN A
WHITE WOMAN'S EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
OF INTERSECTION KNOWLEDGE HE
LEARNING THAT RACE IS A SOCIAL
CONSTRUCT.
RACISM AND THE FACT OF IT IS
REAL HAS GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEFEND MYSELF
USING FACT AND LOGIC RATHER THAN
SOLELY A MOTION.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO HOLD
CONTROVERSIAL CONVERSATIONS IN
ACADEMIC SETTINGS BECAUSE THE
CONFIDENCE I HAVE RECEIVED
THROUGH THESE COURSES.
THESE COURSES HAVE ALLOWED ME TO
EXPAND MY KNOWLEDGE IT HAS
OPENED MY EYES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE WAR THAT WE LIVE
IN.
TRUTHFULLY I WOULD LIKE FOR
PROFESSORS TO BE REQUIRED TO
TAKE A CLASS AND ETHNIC STUDIES
SO THAT THEY MAY BE EDUCATED AS
WELL ON THE STUDENTS THEY ARE
TEACHING.
STUDENTS NEED ETHNIC STUDIES
JUST AS THEY CAN JUST AS THEY ME
MAD ENGLISH AND SCIENCE ETHNIC
STUDIES SHOULD BE A REQUIREMENT
FROSTED IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THEY'D COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
ABSOLUTELY HAVE A RECENT
GRADUATE FROM SACRAMENTO STATE I
MAJORED IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
MINORED IN CHICANO LATINO
STUDIES -- THE CHICANO LATINO
STUDIES COURSES ON IT AND JUST
YOUR NAME.
WELL IN SUPPORT THEY'RE AMAZING
CLASSES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON HOWEVER
MONTEREY PARK ANIMUS UNIT CAL
STATE FULLERTON AND ACTUALLY
HAVE A MINOR ETHNIC STUDIES AND
I SHOWING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DIANA I'M DOING --
I WILL BE DOING NEXT SEMESTER
MASTERS IN COUNSELING WITH
EMPHASIS ON THE ANNEX
COMMUNITIES AND I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JESSE BEECHAM FUTURE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE PLANNING ON
TAKING AND MINOR IN.
CHICANO LATINO STUDIES
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
HI SKY WAGONER IN SUPPORT CAL
STATE LONG BEACH STUDENT
STUDYING INTERNATIONAL STUDIES
AS WELL AS WITH MARCH FOR OUR
LIVES BETTER EDUCATED STUDENTS
MAKE A SAFER COMMUNITY.
HI MY NAME IS DOWN TO THE
JACKSON I'M A THIRD YEAR AT
FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY I'M ALSO
THE SECRETARY MEMBERSHIP CHAIR
FOR THE FRESNO STATE CHAPTER OF
CHAPTER THE NWC P..
I SUPPORT THIS.
HI MY NAME IS SERENITY WHY DELAY
I AM THE TREASURER OF FRESNO
STATES -- AND DOUBLE ACP --
FIRST YEAR STUDENT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY PAIN I'M A
DOUBLE MAJOR IN AFRIKANER
STUDIES AND PHILOSOPHY PRE LAW
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE IN
THE LACI P. AT FRESNO STATE NOT
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS JOY FOR SAID OF
THE FOUNDER OF BAND OF VOTERS
AND THE DAUGHTER OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS I MEAN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI AM AND IS IN A FRESHMAN IN
COLLEGE MAJORING IN ANTHROPOLOGY
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
THIRTIES BELAY -- WITH THE BLACK
ALLIANCE FOR JUST IMMIGRATION BY
G. I FULLY SUPPORT SB
[inaudible]
SIXTEEN FORTY THANK.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
PROUD COSPONSORED ALSO --
FACULTY THE POLITICAL SCIENCE
DEPARTMENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI LOSING -- WITH THE GREEN
RESOURCE CENTER AND ALSO STUDENT
I KELSEY LONG WHICH I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S IAN SCHIFFER I'M
WITHIN THE ARE COULD YOU IS
PARTNERSHIP FOR JUSTICE IN A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM NOTHING CAN BE CHANGED
UNTIL ITS FACE STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL KHôNG AT THE
NEXT THIRTY MAJOR US CAL STATE
FULLERTON I SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S JATIN RICARDO WITH THE
KOREAN RESOURCE CENTER AND A
STUDENT AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH
I SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS TO REALLY IN
OTHERS AND I AM FROM CAL STATE
LOS ANGELES AND MY MAJORS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I WILL BE GRADUATING
IN MAY AND I STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS EMMA BECAUSE SOME
AS PUBLIC HEALTH SENIOR CASTELLI
IN A STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS COUNSEL CHOI --
FROM GREEN RESOURCE CENTER AND A
RECENT GRADUATE OF CAL STATE
FULLERTON IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANTE OUR ROUTE.
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER IS
BUILDING A BLACK LIVES MATTER
MEMBER.
IN THE SOUTHWEST COMMITTEE
COLLEGE GRADUATES.
KRISTIN MCGUIRE WESTERN REGION
DIRECTOR OF YOUNG INVINCIBLES
THE NATIONAL POLICY AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW CARTER I
MAY GRADUATING SENIOR CAL STATE
LA MY MAJOR'S PUBLIC HEALTH AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS JUST COME OPPOSITE
I'M A THIRTY AT CASTING LONG
BEACH AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY CAM MONO
I'M A FOURTH YEAR AT CAL STATE
LONG BEACH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SOMEBODY'S AND I'M
OF THE GRADUATES I'M GRADUATING
FROM CAL SILLY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DENISE COMBOS FROM
CAST LA SETTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI INTO THE BILL BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND A COLLEGE STUDENT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M AUDREY GEORGE WITH WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES AND I
DROVE.
UP HERE FROM MOM SANTA MONICA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT DOCTOR
WEBER SPELL.
HI MY NAME'S AMANDA GARDNER FROM
LOS ANGELES AND AS A FORMER CAL
DALY SOON I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI AM THE KEYBOARD FROM THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF NEGRO WOMEN
AND BAY PACK SACRAMENTO AND OUT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI SIMEON GANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'M DAVE MCCOMB I LIVE IN LA AND
I'M A GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO RENEE BAYARDO S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME HI MY NAME IS MATEO
WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER LOS
ANGELES AND DIGNITY AND POWER
NOW CONSTITUENTS OF DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH ARE THE
COLORS REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE JUST WONDER
POSITION LAST WEEK.
OBVIOUSLY FROM CURRY RESOURCE
CENTER IS STRONG SUPPORT.
UNTIL JACKSON'S BELUM LA --
GRADUATE CLINICAL CHICAGO STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SEARCH MARCEL BLACK LIVES MATTER
AL I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M SHEILA I'M ACTUALLY A CSU
GRADUATE AND I STRONGLY SO OF
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
A MIKE MCCURRY FROM WEST LA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ZACH SHERWIN FROM
WHITE PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES IN
LOS ANGELES I ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ADAM SMITH FOR MY PEOPLE FOR
BLACK LIVES IN LOS ANGELES
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND BRADFORD SAN BENITO COUNTY --
PROP UP AROUND SCHOOL OF LAW
GRADUATE I WROTE A VERY SIMILAR
CURRICULUM FOR LAW SCHOOLS AS
WELL -- I STRONGLY OPPOSE OF
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ARE YOU DON'T.
JOSHUA CAMACHO DOCTOR REVEREND
MINISTER CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTS HIS
BILL THANK YOU HAVE A DAY
[inaudible]
EUGENE DSA.
POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN A CENTURY
BILLION AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
LUCKILY.
MEDI AND I LOVE AS WITH CATHOLIC
RELIEF SERVICES THAN SIGMA
LAMBDA GAMMA SORORITY MEMBER ICE
CREAM TO SUPPORT THIS.
JEREMY WHITE WITH THE MANY FIRST
COALITION AND THE NEED TO
SURVIVORS MARCH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
[inaudible]
CATHY WALKER.
BLACK LIVE MATTER AS GONE WITH
HIS BILL.
JOSH ROADBLOCK MARCH REALIZE
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL -- MAHMOUD
SAMMER ALL FAR -- DIRECTOR OF
MARCH FOR LIFE CALIFORNIA AND A
FRESHMAN AT CELEBRATE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
EDU WHICH IS IS IN OPPOSITION.
HAVE THE PLEASE COME TO THE
TABLE.
AND IT IF WE WOULD MAKE.
ROOM [inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRY MORE OIL
WITH THE CSU AND WE HAVE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON
THIS WOULD LIKE TO THANK HER FOR
IT FOR HER TIME.
RESPECTFULLY WE DO NEED TO
OPPOSE THE THE BILL AND I'D LIKE --
TO INTERVIEWS ALISON RAN FROM
OUR ACADEMIC AFFAIRS DIVISION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PART OF THE C. ISSUES MISSION IS
TO PREPARE OUR DIVERSE STUDENTS
TO LIVE AND WORK IN A CULTURALLY
DIVERSE SOCIETY AND WE TAKE THIS
MISSION VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE HAVE THREE MAIN OBJECTIONS TO
THIS BILL WHICH I WILL TOUCH ON
BRIEFLY AND THEN I'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
FIRST WE BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD NOT IMPOSE CURRICULUM
CURRICULAR DECISIONS OR THE ROLE
OF THE FACULTY IN CONSULTATION
WITH CAMPUS ADMINISTRATION.
THE CSU FACULTY ARE HIRED FOR
THE DISCIPLINARY EXPERTISE THEY
SHOULD BE RELIED UPON TO PROPOSE
AND DEVELOP CURRICULUM.
THIS BILL UNDERMINES THE PROCESS
OF SHARED GOVERNANCE IT RELIES
ON CAMPUSES AND FACULTY TO
DETERMINE COURSE CONTENT.
DEGREE IN GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS.
A LEGISLATIVE MANDATE SUCH AS
THIS WILL SET THE DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT OF ALLOWING GOVERNMENT
TO DETERMINE CURRICULA AND THIS
DOESN'T FACT THREATEN THE
ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
OVER CAMPUSES.
SECOND THE PROPOSED BILLS NOT
NECESSARY WE ALREADY HAVE
CULTURAL DIVERSITY REQUIREMENTS
ON ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES.
OUR CAMPUSES AND FACULTY SAW A
NEED FOR CULTURAL STUDIES
COURSES AND DEVELOP THESE
REQUIREMENTS EITHER AS PART OF
GENERAL EDUCATION OR AS A
STANDALONE CAMPUS REQUIREMENT.
MANY OF THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE
MET BY EXISTING COURSES IN
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR COURSES IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS
ANTHROPOLOGY HISTORY.
GENDER WOMEN'S STUDIES AMONG
MANY OTHERS.
FINALLY SUCH A REQUIREMENT COULD
ADVERSELY IMPACT OUR ASSOCIATE
DEGREES FOR TRANSFERS OR EDT
PROGRAMS AND THE PROGRESS
TOWARDS GI. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TEASER DELICATE BALANCE
OF SIXTY UNITS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN SIXTY UNITS IN THE
CSU.
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE CSU
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
DEVELOP THESE TRANSFER PATHWAYS.
SINCE THEN OUR TWO SYSTEMS OF
WORK FOR YEARS TO DEVELOP OVER A
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND DEGREE
PATHWAYS TO IMPROVE OUR STUDENTS
CHANCE OF GRADUATING IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
ANY CHANGE TO GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE CSU WOULD
REQUIRE US TO REVIEW ALL OF OUR
EIGHTY TEAS AS THERE ARE NO
UNITS ON THE CSU SIDE OF MANY OF
THESE DEGREES.
THIS COULD RESULT IN AN ADVERSE
IMPACT ON TRANSFER.
THE BILL COULD POTENTIALLY ALSO
ADVERSELY IMPACTS USE USE
GRADUATION MISSION OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AN AMBITIOUS EFFORTS
SUPPORTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE ISSUES GRADUATION RATES
ELIMINATE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
STUDENTS WOULD BE FORCED TO FIT
IN A MORE SPECIFIC COURSE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND CAMPUSES WOULD BE FORCED TO
DEVELOP ADDITIONAL COURSES TO
MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DATA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KATHERINE NELSON I'M CHAIR OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE CSU.
WE ARE THE INSTITUTIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AND THROUGH THE
HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER RELATIONS ACT.
THE LEGALLY RECOGNIZED VOICES
CSU FACULTY IN MATTERS OF SYSTEM
WIDE ACADEMIC POLICY INCLUDING
THE CURRICULUM.
AND THAT IN TURN INCLUDES
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS.
WE OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY YOU HAVE HEARD
VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONY IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALSO
CONSIDER THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
FACULTY CONTROL OVER THE
CURRICULUM.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE FOR THIS OR
ANY OTHER GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
IS AN APPROPRIATE MEANS FOR
ACCOMPLISHING.
THE GOAL OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE LEGISLATION.
FACULTY CONTROL OVER THE C<c.cyan></c>
CURRICULUM IS A FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLE IN A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY.
A PRINCIPLE IS IMPORTANT TO US
AS THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS TO THE
ACLU.
AND A PRINCIPLE THAT IN THIS
INSTANCE MUST BE WEIGHED AGAINST
THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
LEGISLATIVE INTRUSION INTO THE
CURRICULUM.
CLICK HERE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CURRICULUM PRECISELY BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE DISCIPLINARY AND
CURRICULAR EXPERTISE. TO BEST
JUDGE THE KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS
NEEDED IN UNIVERSITY DEGREE.
LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT IN
SETTING DEGREE REQUIREMENTS
COULD ULTIMATELY MEAN THAT THE
GOVERNMENT'S AGENDA.
SUPERSEDES FACULTY EXPERTISE AS
THE BASIS FOR CURRICULAR
DECISIONS.
YOU CAN ALSO HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE OPEN EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF KNOWLEDGE.
AND STUDENTS ACQUISITION OF
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ETHNIC STUDIES.
BUT WE SIMPLY DO NOT THINK THE
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH GOVERNMENT
MANDATED CURRICULUM SHOULD BE
TAKEN IN THIS CASE.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
I RIGHT QUESTION.
YEAH BACK TO WEBER.
I KNOW YOU HI YOU ARE A FORM OF
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE HIGHER
EDUCATION -- I WAS ALSO.
COMMITTED TO FACULTY AT THE
SEVERAL HOURS HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTES.
INSTITUTIONS SO AND THEN ALSO
SERVED AS OF FACULTY SENATE
MEMBER -- HIGH -- ORDER HARDLY
HOW DID THE AGREE HE DON'T NEED
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES -- AS A
MEMBER OF FIVE ETHNIC GROUP
MYSELF I WOULD LIKE.
TO SEE THAT THAT HAPPENS -- TO
INCREASE THE SENSITIVITY AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STUDENTS --
ABOUT THE OUT DIFFERENT ETHNIC
GROUPS SO AND THAT THEIR CULTURE
AND HISTORY.
AND HI THE HERE THAT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF BLACK STUDIES
SO -- ON CAMPUSES SO.
I AGREE HE IT DOES SET IMPORTANT
BUT IN PRINCIPLE.
IF WE START.
NO STATE.
MANDATE SET CURRICULUM WHAT IS A
REQUIRE THE FULL GRADUATION
ETCETERA ETCETERA.
AT THIS WILL OPEN UP THE DOOR.
OF FOR QUESTIONING MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS SO.
VERY POSSIBLY -- AND IN ORDER SO --
INFRINGING UPON THE ACADEMIC
FREEDOM.
THAT THE ES SARAH I SEE.
THE LIST OF OF COURSE IS SELL US
OUT FOR MANDATED -- ON DIFFERENT
NOT CSU CAMPUSES SO.
MY HOPE TO SAIL ALMOST TO A
TWENTY INDIA TWENTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES SAID THEY ARE
CURRENTLY OLD OFFERING DIFFERENT
KINDS HEALTH.
NICK STUDIES SO -- AND AS YOU
KNOW.
THE TIME IS STILL QUITE LIMITED --
DURING FOR OUR OF FOUR YEAR OF
CURRICULUM -- AND HOW WE GONNA
DEFINE.
ETHNIC STUDIES SO -- WOULD IT BE
A CERTAIN.
SELECT DID.
ETHNIC STUDIES SAYS SUCH AS A
BLACK STUDIES.
LOVE TO INCLUDE THE YOU KNOW
KOREAN ETHNIC STUDIES OF KOREAN
AMERICANS.
IN THE U. S. -- WHATEVER HISTORY
THAT THE WE MAY HAVE LESS OF
ISSUES.
IN A HUGE ISSUE IS THE LACK OF
IN ALL FOR OUR APRIL.
YOU KNOW TWENTY NINE EVENT THAT
THE ENTIRE A KOREAN BUSINESSES A
PUT DOWN -- WAS IT UP -- ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS AGO IN THE LA AREA
AND THAT KIND OF EXPERIENCE AND
RAISING THE SENSITIVITY -- ABOUT
THE KOREAN AMERICAN EXPERIENCE
IT IS IMPORTANT -- WHEN WE'VE?
DON'T TALK ABOUT IT THE IT IT
MAY BE SOON FORGOTTEN SEOUL IS A
SAY IMPORTANT -- TO END UP ANY
OF THE AND NICK.
YEAH POOP SO SUCH AS JAPANESE OR
CHINESE.
SO AND THE HISPANIC.
ARABIC YOU CAN GO ON AND ON HOW.
WE GONNA -- CUT OUT.
THAT THE INTEREST GROUPS SO.
AMANDA WHEN IT'S DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES.
I WONDER IF -- THERE'S A SOME
COMPROMISE -- BECAUSE OVER THE
IMPORTANT TOPIC AT THE SAME TIME --
TO HONOR THE ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND THE CONCERN SO AND THEN ALSO --
THE KINDS OF ETHNIC STUDIES --
BEING DEMANDED BY THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS -- SINCE I SEE THAT AS
OF REQUIRING TERRACE THE SO TO
PROVIDE A CAMPUS IN ETHNIC
STUDIES.
INSTEAD WERE REQUIRING.
WHETHER WE CAN COME UP WITH THE
SOME OF THE EXPRESSIONS SUCH AS
ENCOURAGING -- VAN.
I'M SURE THE CAMPUSES WILL TAKE
IT VERY SERIOUSLY AND THE TRIED
ACCOMMODATE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
SO WE ARE SUGGESTING WE WE WE
HAVE INTEREST IN THIS AREA.
AND THE LIVING UP TO THEM.
AND A WHAT KIND OF ALL ETHNIC
STUDIES THAT THAT WOULD PROVIDE.
A DEPEND UPON REGION AREA --
WHEN LARA BOOK IN A BLACK
INTEREST A BANDEAU BLACK STUDIES
IF TO SELL A LOT OF ASIAN MAYBE
ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES ITS
BAREST INCLUSIVE REALLY MAYBE?
SO -- THAT MIGHT BE -- SOMEONE
AT THE ALTERNATIVE I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER YOU CAN.
MODIFY ON THIS -- YOU KNOW -- AT
THIS PARTICULAR OUR BUT THAT
DOES SO -- MY KIND OF SUGGESTION
TO YOU THANK YOU.
HE WOULD ANSWER THERE OKAY --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT I WANT TO
THANK THOSE WHO'VE COME -- TO
FROM C. ISSUES -- CAMPUS AND
IT'S ALMOST LIKE DEJA VU ALL
OVER AGAIN.
ETHICS REYES IS FIFTY YEARS OLD
AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE OLDEST -- ETHNIC STUDIES OF
CAMPUSES OF IN THE NATION
BEGINNING IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE SO WE WILL
BE FIFTY YEARS OLD THIS YEAR --
AND FOR FIFTY YEARS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE SAME THING OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ENCOURAGEMENT
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON SO I
THINK AFTER FIFTY YEARS A HALF
OF A CENTURY.
OF WE SHOULD BE AT A DIFFERENT
PLACE WHICH AS I CONSISTENTLY
SAY TO THOSE ON THE FLOOR WE
NEED TO BE A POINT WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE TO STUDY.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH LATINO
HISTORY MONTH API MONTH WE
SHOULD BE A POINT IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE HAVE A CURRICULUM THAT
IS DIVERSE THAT IS IN NOT ONLY
K. TWELVE BUT POST SECONDARY.
IT WON'T HAPPEN IN K. TWELVE
MILITIA APPLE SECOND HERE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO CAN ACTUALLY TEACH THE
SUBJECT MATTER NOT SIMPLY PASS
OUT FLIERS ON MARTIN LUTHER KING
DAY.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED HOWEVER AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THERE IS
STILL IS ACADEMIC FREEDOM OF THE
FACT THAT THE FACULTY WILL
CHOOSE THE CURRICULUM.
IT WOULD CHOOSE WHAT TO BE WHAT
IS TO BE TAUGHT THEY CHOOSE THE
TEXTBOOK AND THEY'RE NOT
RESTRICTED.
IN THE FOCUS OF THE COURSE
THAT'S WHAT ACADEMIC FREEDOM IS
ALL ABOUT NOT NECESSARILY BEING
ABLE DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO
WHEN YOU WANT TO DO IT -- WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE QUESTION OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE NOW YOU KNOW THE
REALITY IS I SPENT FORTY YEARS
IT'S AN EAGLE STATE UNIVERSITY?
OF NOT ONLY THE FOUNDER OF THE
VARIOUS ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT OF WOMEN'S STUDIES
BUT I ALSO SERVED AS CHAIR OF A
DEPARTMENT FOR CLOSE TO THIRTY
YEARS.
A CERTAIN EVERY MAJOR GRAFFITI
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAD WHAT WAS
THE UNIVERSITY CURRICULUM --
WHETHER IT WAS SERVING AS SIX
YEARS ON THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
OF THERE'S NOT A COMMITTEE AT
ANY UNIVERSITY THAT THAT I CAN
THINK OF THAT I DID NOT SERVE ON
AND FOR YEARS I SERVED ON THE
CURRICULUM COMMITTEE AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
AND RETIRED AS A FULL PROFESSOR
OF WITH EMERITUS STATUS SO I'VE
DONE THE ACADEMIC I KNOW HOW THE
UNIVERSITIES WORK I KNOW THAT
THE IVORY TOWER SELDOM OPENS ITS
DOOR UNLESS THE DOORS KICKED
DOWN.
AND THAT'S THE REALITY OF THE
IVORY TOWER THE FACULTY THAT ARE
AN ACADEMIC SENATE ARE BASICALLY
THE FACULTY THAT IS REFLECTIVE
OF THE INSTITUTIONS.
AND SO THEREFORE THERE ALWAYS
GOTTEN THAT DIDN'T NEVER GOING
TO REALLY FULLY OPEN.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CURRICULAR OF
CULTURAL STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY STEP TAKEN AND I'VE
BEEN A PART OF THAT WHOLE
DISCUSSION OF CULTURAL STUDIES
AND WE KNOW THAT IT IS POSSIBLE
TO GET YOUR DEGREE AT ANY
UNIVERSITY AND NEVER TAKE AN
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE?
YOU CAN TAKE A CULTURAL STORE
COURSE OF SOUTHERN ITALY OR
SUDDEN EUROPEAN AND THAT IS A
CUT CULTURAL COURSE BUT IT STILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
ISSUE OF THIS NATION IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS NATION WITH
REGARDS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HERE.
WHO ARE EITHER AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO API AND THE ISSUES OF
RACE AND INTERSECTION BETWEEN
RACE AND CULTURE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IS QUESTION THAT HAS
TO BE HAD?
AT THIS AT THIS TIME AT THIS
YEAR AT THE END AND AT THE
UNIVERSITIES SO WE START TALKING
ABOUT ACADEMIC FREEDOM IT IS
STILL THERE.
WE DO IMPOSE A NUMBER OF THINGS
ON A UNIVERSITY WE IMPOSE AT
LANGUAGE REQUIREMENTS WE IMPOSE
OF THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE TO
TAKE AMERICAN HISTORY
INSTITUTION REQUIREMENTS WE GIVE
THE UNIVERSE IS THE FLEXIBILITY
TO CHOOSE HOW IT IS TAUGHT.
BUT WE BASICALLY REQUIRED THOSE
ISSUES OUT OF THERE SO WHEN YOU
BEGAN TO ACTS BUT ACADEMIC
FREEDOM WE HAVE A BROAD BASE OF
OF OF THINGS THAT WE JUDGE THAT
WE HAVE THAT ARE PART OF IT.
ETHNIC SO YOU SHOULD BE A PART
OF IT IT CAN EASILY BE
INCORPORATED IN THE CURRENT
COURSES THAT ARE REQUIRED WE'RE
NOT SAYING THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A A STRICTLY STANDALONE ETHNIC
STUDIES DEPARTMENT.
IF YOU TEACHING HISTORY COULD BE
TEACHING AMERICAN HISTORY TO
VARIOUS LANDS IS AND WE SEE THAT
NOW MANY CAMPUSES WILL DO THAT
SOMEONE NOT.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE IS A HODGE
PODGE OF REQUIREMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BUT NOT NECESSARILY A
FOCUS AND A REQUIREMENT THAT
STUDENTS HAVE TO TAKE LEAST
THREE UNITS OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT K. TWELVE AND
WE PASS IN K. TWELVE ISSUES WE
DON'T HAVE THE FACULTY TO TEACH
IT SAN DIEGO STATE OF OF SENEGAL
CITY OF CITY SCHOOLS HAS A HAS
ETHNIC STUDIES ON ITS BOOK YOU
CAN TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES.
BUT THERE ARE VERY FEW FACULTY
WHO COULD ACTUALLY TEACH IT AND
I REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS OFFERED
IT'S AN EAGLE STATE WHEN I WAS
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT AND WHEN
I WAS A PROFESSOR THERE WE
ACTUALLY WENT OUT AND HIRED
SOMEONE FROM THE COMMUTER
COLLEGE COME IN ONE DAY.
A WEEK WHICH IS DIFFICULT TO DO
THE TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES A ONE
OF A HIGH SCHOOL THAT REQUIRE
THAT REQUESTED IT.
MAINLY BECAUSE THERE THERE WERE
NO FACULTY ALL THAT COULD
ACTUALLY TEACH THE COURSE WITH
THE LEVEL OF COMPETENCY THAT IS
REALLY CENTRAL.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES FOR EVER AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT AND IT
WILL COULD WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BRING UP ARGUMENT OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON THE QUESTION IS IS IS GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA.
IS A GOOD FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE CONFRONTED
WITH AN EXTREMELY DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION.
WOULD BE GOOD FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOW INVOLVED IN THIS CHALLENGES
WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OF HEADS
OF ETHNIC STUDIES CLASSES.
AND SOME UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DIVERSITY OF INDIVIDUALS BUT
ALSO UNDERSTANDING OF THEMSELVES
IN THE BIASES THAT THEY BRING TO
THE EDUCATIONAL PROCESS.
YES OUR TIME TO UNIVERSITY IS
IT'S IT'S TIME TO DEGREE IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT WHAT I FOUND OVER
THE YEARS AS THOSE STUDENTS WHO
ACTUALLY TAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
PARTICULARLY STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ACTUALLY GET TIME TO DEGREE BUT
A WHOLE LOT FASTER THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE BECAUSE THEY
ACTUALLY SEE THEMSELVES IN THE
CURRICULUM THEY BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO CHANGE THEIR HISTORY AS WELL
AS A CHANGE THE COMMUNITIES THEY
COME FROM.
SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE TRIED YOU COULD
SAY IS THERE A COMPROMISE IS A
COMPROMISE THE COMPROMISE IS WE
REQUIRE ETHNIC STUDIES BUT THE
INSTITUTION STILL GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE HOW THAT
IF.
THAT IS GOING TO BE TAUGHT WHAT
THE CURRICULUM IS GOING TO BE
LIKE AND ACTUALLY HOW IT FITS
INTO THE PATTERN OF THE
UNIVERSITIES THAT THAT OF THE
YEAR.
WE HAVE THAT'S POINTED OUT EARLY
WE HAVE THE MOST DIVERSE
POPULATION OF STUDENTS IN THE
WORLD RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR UNIVERSITIES AND YET WE
FAIL TO ADEQUATELY REQUIRE AND
SUPPORT THE MANY THINGS THAT WE
THINK THAT ARE CENTRAL AND IT'S
NOT JUST FOR ETHNIC STUDENTS IT
IS FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE SEEN MY
STUDENT POPULATION GROW FROM.
A MAJORITY OF OF STUDENTS OF
COLOR WHEN I WAS TEACHING
UNIVERSITY OF WALKING AND IN IN.
SEVENTY TWO OF THE MOST AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN MY CLASS BY THE
TIME I GOT READY TO RETIRE I CAN
TELL WHO WAS IN MY CLASS WHEN I
WALKED IN WHAT WAS MY CLASS OF
THE CLASS NEXT DOOR.
BECAUSE STUDENTS BEGAN TO TAKE
ETHNIC STUDIES AND I AM PROUD TO
SAY THAT MANY OF MY GRADUATES
ARE VERY DIFFERENT GRADUATES
WITH THE LAWYERS A DOT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
LEVEL CURRICULUM WHEN THEY TOOK
A MINOR OR JOINT MAJOR IN AFRICA
IN ETHNIC STUDIES.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR
CREDIT THEIR SUCCESS. TO HAVING
TAKEN AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
AT UNIVERSITY WHEN WE DID THE
ETHNIC STUDY RESOLUTION THAT WAS
HERE.
THE REPORT THAT CAME BACK FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WITH ALL
THE VARIOUS ONES WAS A
RECOMMENDATION FOR AN ETHNIC
STUDIES REQUIREMENTS.
OF WILL IT OPEN THE FLOODGATES
FOR ALL KINDS OF OTHER THINGS I
HAVE NO IDEA.
I DON'T WE ARE HAVING BEEN AT
THE MAYBE BECAUSE I'VE BEEN THE
UNIVERSITY SO LONG I DON'T
REALIZE IS THAT I DON'T SEE IT
AS A SACRED INSTITUTION.
THEY CAN'T CHANGE I KNOW IT NOT
ONLY CAN'T CHANGE BUT IT HAS TO
CHANGE IN ORDER TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF THE STUDENTS WHO
COME TO THE UNIVERSITY.
SO WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A WHILE.
AND IT'S TIME FOR US TO
BASICALLY PUT OUR THOUGHTS AND
OUR HEART WHERE WE BELIEVE.
AND BASICALLY BITE THE BULLET
AND REQUIRE INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ETHNIC STUDIES IS A REQUIREMENT
FOR GRADUATION.
MANY OF OUR CAMPUS WILL ONLY
HAVE TO MAKE MODEST ADJUSTMENTS
BECAUSE IT MANY OF THEM HAVE
ETHNIC STUDIES DEPARTMENTS THEY
COULD SIMPLY INCORPORATING THE
G. REQUIREMENTS.
THOSE WHO DON'T CAN FEET WILL
FIGURE IT OUT BECAUSE THEY CAN
HIRE HISTORIANS OR LITERATURE
FOLKS WHO COULD OFFER COURSES
WITHIN THE TRADITIONAL
DEPARTMENT.
IN THOSE ETHNIC STUDIES AREA BUT
I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE MOVE --
IT'S BEEN FIFTY YEARS SINCE THE
STUDENTS KICK DOWN DOORS SINCE
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE FIFTY
EIGHT LONG YEARS AND IT'S ABOUT
TIME AT THE AT THE ANNIVERSARY
OF THE FIFTY YEARS.
THAT WE BASICALLY INSTITUTE A
REQUIREMENT THE UNIVERSITY FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE WHEN WE GET A
CHANCE WE GET A QUORUM.
DOCTOR WEBER I JUST WANNA TRY TO
CLARIFY SOMETHING.
I WE HAVE HERE A HAND OUT FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR --
THE CSU AND ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
OFFERINGS.
THAT THEY HAVE -- COURSES I I
ASSUME THAT THEY ARE -- YOU
WOULD LEAVE IT UP TO THE CSU. TO
TO DETERMINE HOW THEY WOULD --
HOW THEY WOULD -- OFFER THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES CLASS EXACTLY
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
TO OFFER.
A PARTICULAR COURSE WE WOULD
LEAVE IT UP TO THEM TO DO THAT
BUT IT SHOULD BE AN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURTS IN OTHER WORDS
YOU SHOULD BE FOCUSED.
ON THE MAJOR ETHNIC STUDIES
GROUPS AND THAT WE THAT WE KNOW
OF IN TERMS OF LATINO AFRICAN
AMERICAN API.
AND NATIVE AMERICAN INDIE OKAY
THOSE OF THE GROUPS OF THAT ARE
THAT ARE THERE AND IT'S ALWAYS
INTERESTING I HAVE TO SAY THIS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE FOUGHT SO
MANY BATTLES.
THE UNIVERSITY WHEN I WENT THERE
IS A A NAIVE TWENTY THREE YEAR
OLD AND AND AND AND EVERYONE
KNEW WHAT THE WORD ETHNIC
STUDIES MET.
UNTIL WE START HAVING MONEY AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT EVERYBODY GOT
CONFUSED THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
ETHNIC STUDIES WAS WILL MAYBE
ASSISTANCE GOT A STUDY OF
EUROPEAN SOUTHERN EUROPEANS ARE
MADE WITH THIS GROUP WITH THAT
GROUP.
MY RESPONSE IS ALWAYS IF I TELL
YOU THAT ETHNIC STUDENTS ARE
FAILING IN PUBLIC SCHOOL WHO
WOULD YOU THINK THEY WERE.
WE ALL HAVE CLEAR UNDERSTAND OF
WHAT ETHNIC FOLKS ARE AT THAT
POINT.
IF I SAY TO YOU WE GOT SOME
MONEY TO GIVE TO FOLKS WHO
WANTED TO BE INVOLVED IN ETHNIC
STUDIES ETHNIC ACTIVITIES NOBODY
KNOWS WHO THE HECK I'M TALKING
BACK AS EVERYBODY THAT MOMENT
ONE OF THE ETHNIC.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW RIGHT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE STUDENTS WHO
CAME UP THE STUDENTS WHO SPOKE.
AND I AM I I WOULD SAY AS A
EDUCATOR.
AS A LONG TIME TEACHER THAT THAT
THE STUDENTS WHO CAME UP
DEMONSTRATE.
THE POWER OF ETHNIC STUDIES THE
THE POWER THE CONFIDENCE THAT A
CURRICULUM THAT REFLECTS ALL
STUDENTS A GIVES -- STUDENTS AND
I THINK THE STUDENTS WHO SPOKE
TODAY REFLECT THAT -- OUT.
I HAVE A QUESTIONS ALSO FOR C.
ISSUE -- THIS WAS NOTSOMETHING
THAT THAT HAPPENED -- THIS BILL
DID NOT COME ABOUT -- IN A
VACUUM.
IT CAME ABOUT THROUGH DISCUSSION.
WITH FACULTY -- ESPECIALLY -- I
I I I KNOW I HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH.
OF FACULTY FROM CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE -- HAD MORE THAN ONCE
A CONVERSATION WITH THE FACULTY
AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE THE CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE IS THE CAMPUS
THE CSU CAMPUS WITH THE MOST
OFFERINGS.
IN ETHNIC STUDIES THE LARGEST A
CHICANO STUDIES DEPARTMENT
PROBABLY IN THE NATION -- HAS A
CENTRAL AMERICAN -- LATINO
STUDIES PROGRAM BUT THERE WERE
CONCERNS WITH FACULTY AT CSU
NORTHRIDGE ABOUT WATERING DOWN
OF THEIR PROGRAM I THINK THERE
WERE ARTICLES IN THE NEWSPAPER --
OF STUDENTS DEMONSTRATING OF
STUDENT OF STUDENTS -- YOU KNOW
OF OF BEING ON CAMPUS OF
CONVERSATIONS INCLUDING WITH THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE CSU STUDENTS
SO THIS BILL DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IN A VACUUM THE RIVER FACULTY
INVOLVED ESPECIALLY I KNOW
FACULTY FROM NORTHRIDGE WHO'D
BEEN.
INVOLVED IN CONVERSATION.
WITH THEIR CHANCELLOR AT CSU
WITH THE PRESIDENT CSU.
NORTHRIDGE AND ALSO WITH THE
CHANCELLOR TIM WHITE -- AND
THERE WERE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
FACULTY OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND
THE ACADEMIC SENATE I KNOW THAT
THEIR THERE WAS A STUDY DONE AT
AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE -- OF
THE ETHNIC STUDIES AT AFTER
THEIR CAMPUS AND WHAT I GOT FROM
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FACULTY OF CSU NORTHRIDGE THAT I
pTHAT IT WAS THEIR FEELING AND
THE FEELING OF THIS OF AT LEAST
SOME OF THE STUDENTS AT
NORTHRIDGE THAT IT WAS AN
ATTEMPT BY.
CSU TO ACTUALLY WATERED DOWN --
THE ETHNIC STUDIES -- WATER DOWN.
OP RANGE THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
THAT THAT WAS YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT THOSE WERE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE CONVEYED TO ME --
THEIR FEAR.
THAT AT NORTHRIDGE THE BIGGEST
DEPARTMENT.
OF ETHNIC STUDIES LATINO STUDIES --
THEY WERE GONNA LOSE.
ACTUALLY LOSE SECTIONS.
IN IN THEIR COURSE OFFERINGS.
SO WHILE.
WE SEE THE VALUE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SEE THE VALUE
WEALTH WE SEE THE STUDENTS LINED
UP TO SAY HOW VALUABLE IT IS IN
THEIR LIVES.
AS WE HEARD TESTIMONY AT THE
SAME TIME.
AYE AYE AYE AYES SEE.
THE OPPOSITE HAPPENING -- ON ON
AT LEAST THAT ONE CAMPUS SO I'LL
LET YOU RESPOND.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
ON THE CAMPUS OF THERE WAS NO
CHANGE IN THE REQUIREMENTS AND
IN FACT -- SEE SUN CONTINUES TO
HAVE ITS A REQUIREMENT IN
SECTION F. -- AND I I CAN SAY
UNEQUIVOCALLY THERE WAS NO
ATTEMPT TO WATER DOWN OFFERINGS
AND REQUIREMENTS AND ETHNIC
STUDIES.
AT ANY TIME.
IN THE CITY HAS YOU ARE AND I
DON'T KNOW SAN FRANCISCO STATE
MIGHT ARGUE THAT THEY HAVE MORE
ETHNIC STUDIES IN THE COLLEGE
ABOUT THE STUDIES I DON'T KNOW
THE NUMBERS OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD.
SEE SON AND MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES
ARE EXTREMELY DIVERSE -- WE KNOW
ABOUT THESE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WE AGREE WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY IN ETHNIC STUDIES AND
AGAIN -- ETHNIC STUDIES ARE
OFFERED ON VIRTUALLY ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES BUT NOT ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES.
I AND DIVERSITY IS REQUIREMENT
ON ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES AND I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE WERE -- WE
CERTAINLY HAVE SOME DISAGREEMENT --
BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE NO
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
I I I WOULD I WOULD SAY -- WELL.
I'M MAY LET DOCTOR WEBER CLOSE
AND THEN I'LL.
UNLESS MR LIVING CAROL ALSO
FEATURES SOME REMARKS -- I'M A
I'M A GRADUATEOF CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE THAT WAS A GREAT --
EXPERIENCE FOR ME TO LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT CALIFORNIA
THAN WAS MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
GROWING UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND AND SO I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL BECAUSE OF
THE EXPERIENCE I HAD AT CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE IN RELIGIOUS MY
WHOLE MIND -- OPENING UP WITH MY
EYES -- TO THAT EXPERIENCE AND
THE PEOPLE THAT I MET THROUGH IT
WE LIVE KIND OF IT A BIT AT AT A
TRAGIC TIME AND A LACK OF
EMPATHY.
TOWARDS OTHERS.
LIMITED BY THE LANDS BY WHICH WE
SEE THE WORLD.
AND I THINK THAT -- DOCTOR WEBER
ELIMINATED SOME OF THOSE
INSTANCES THAT -- EXPANDING.
PEOPLE'S MINDS IN COLLEGE THE
WHOLE POINT A COLLEGE -- COULD
REALLY BENEFIT SOCIETY AND SO
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO COLLEGE AND
ARE HAVING PEOPLE COME INTO OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
WHEN -- WE'RE TRYING TO PREPARE
PEOPLE. TO CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY.
THAT THAT THEY HAVE TO SEE. TO A
BROADER LANDS AND THIS BILL IS A
GREAT STEP TOWARDS DOING THAT
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I SIMPLY WANT TO SAY THAT UP YOU
KNOW.
I AND I APPRECIATE THE ALL OF
THOSE WHO ARE HERE AND THOSE WHO
PROBABLY LISTING IN THEIR
OFFICES THAT -- IT'S TIME. FIFTY
YEARS IS A LONG TIME.
AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION FOR THAT LONG AT
VARIOUS LEVELS AND AS I SAID AS
A SET LISTEN TODAY REMINDED ME
OF THE FIFTY YEARS OF STRUGGLE.
AT THE C. ISSUE.
IN TERMS OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND
AT EVERY TURN ETHNIC STUDIES HAS
DEMONSTRATED IMPROVING.
ITS RIGHT TO BE ON THE CAMPUS AS
AN ACADEMIC UNITS.
IT CAME ON THE CAMPUS IS NOT
BECAUSE OF FACULTY WANTING
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AND COMING TO A
REALIZATION ETHNIC STUDIES WAS
IMPORTANT IT DID NOT.
HE CAME TO CAMPUS BECAUSE
STUDENTS PROTESTED FOUGHT AND
BURNED IT DOWN BERMAN CAMPUSES
IN ORDER TO GET ETHNIC STUDIES
ON THE CAMPUS IT WAS NOT AN
ENTERPRISE.
EMBRACED BY THE FACULTY -- AND
IT WAS YEARS EVEN AFTER THAT OF
STRUGGLING ON THE CAMPUSES TO
EVER GET THE FACULTY ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZE THE VALIDITY OF THE OF
THE COURSE STUDY AND THE
CURRICULUM AND ITS UNIQUENESS --
AND STILL CONTINUE SOMEWHAT
TODAY IN TERMS OF FOLKS BATTLING
IT -- BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT IT IS EVERY AT EVERY TURN
DEMONSTRATED ITS STRENGTH.
AND IS AT ITS ACADEMIC WORTH OF
A LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY AND I'M
ENCOURAGED BY THIS I I HOPE THAT
WE FINALLY TAKE THE STEP TO
BASICALLY.
MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES A
REQUIREMENT.
AND WHO KNOWS MAYBE AFTER A
NUMBER OF YEARS AS WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT IT ONCE WE RE EDUCATE ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN AND THOSE WILL
BECOME THE PROFESSORS.
THAT WE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE AN
AMERICAN STUDIES COURSE THAT IS
EVERYBODY.
THAT WE WILL NO LONGER HAVE AT
OF HISTORY AMERICAN HISTORY IN
AN INSTITUTION BEING TAUGHT WITH
AFRICAN AMERICANS ONLY BE IN A
FOOTNOTE TO SLAVERY.
BUT BASICALLY TOTALLY
INCORPORATED IN THE CURRICULUM
SO THAT TRULY REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA AND THIS NATION THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT TAKING
THE FIRST STEPS OF REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT'S OUR ULTIMATE GOAL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE I. BUT WE
GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER -- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD -- WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CALL FOR A VOTE BUT BEFORE I
BEFORE [inaudible]
THIS -- GO ON TO OUR NEXT WHEN I
COUPLE OF THINGS -- AS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE RICE
SERVED AT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
[inaudible]
AND UNDERSTAND.
OF THE RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE ADMINISTRATORS AND
FACULTY.
AND AS SOMEONE WHO I BELIEVE IS
VERY -- MUCH DEDICATED TO THE
IDEA.
WHETHER IT'S AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR CSU.
OR THE UC.
THAT IT SHOULD BE THE FACULTY
THE DICTATES THE ACADEMIC
[inaudible]
EVERYTHING ACADEMIC [inaudible]
BELIEVING THAT.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AMANDA ASKED THE AUTHOR TO BE CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
BECAUSE I AGREE THAT FIFTY YEARS.
IS A LIFETIME TO HAVE WAITED.
I ALSO HAD THE THE GOOD FORTUNE
TO COME TO THE UNIVERSITY AT A
TIME WHEN THE UNIVERSITY WAS
BEING QUESTION THE GROUP THE
ROLE OF THE UNIVERSITY WAS BEING
QUESTION -- WHAT WAS TAUGHT BY --
THE ACADEMY WAS BEING QUESTIONED
THE CANON -- THE HISTORY WAS
BEING QUESTION AND I BENEFITTED
I BENEFITTED FROM BEING A
STUDENT.
LIKE OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
LEVINE SAID OF THE BROADER A
BROADER CURRICULUM.
AND AS WE TALK ABOUT CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE I'M REMINDED OF
DOCTOR RIDDLE FULL OF BUNYE
WHOSE BOOK -- OCCUPIED AMERICA
IS PROBABLY THE MOST WIDELY USED --
CHICANO STUDIES BOOK.
AND IS PROBABLY GONE TO I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY DIFFERENT EDITIONS
THAT WAS THE BOOK THAT I HAD.
AND I USED AND I REMEMBER THE
HISTORY OF OF CHICANO HISTORY BY
A RIVERA FROM SAN JOSE STATE.
FELICIANO AND REPAIR.
FROM SAN JOSE STATE AND THE
IMPACT THAT HAD ON MY OWN LIFE
LIKE I SEE THAT THE STUDENTS
LINED UP HERE TODAY.
AND I WOULD SAY.
THAT IF WE DO NOT ACT I AGREE
WITH.
DOCTOR WEBER THAT IF WE DO NOT
ACT WE WILL BE BACK HERE IN
FIFTY YEARS SAYING THE SAME
THING THAT WHEN WILL THE
CURRICULUM CHANGE WHEN WILL --
WE HAVE TEACHERS AT UNDERSTAND
ALL CULTURES AND HISTORIES -- BE
PREPARED WHEN WILL THAT HAPPEN.
SO I I AND SUPPORTING THE BILL
AND ASK AGAIN -- DOCTOR WEBER TO
PUT ME ON AS A CO AUTHOR AND WE
WILL -- LEAVE IT OPEN TO THE
VOTE ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WITH THAT ON A HAND THE GAVEL TO
THE VICE CHAIR AND I AM GOING TO
PRESENT MY BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL OKAY GOT IT YEAH.
IN ORDER TO ADD A GOOD WAY IF
YOU.
I REMEMBER HIM YEAH SO HE HAS
SOMEONE BILL.
THIS IS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF PROBLEMS ON
CAMPUS.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
OKAY AUDIO AS IF IN A ACTS IT --
PLEASE DO SO QUIETLY YEAH SO WE
NEED TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT B.
L. UP IN ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB --
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BY --
CHAIRPERSON MEDINA --
ASSEMBLYMAN A MEDINA YOU CAN GO
AHEAD TO WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IS
OUTDATED AND OVERLY COMPLEX WITH
TOO MANY BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
STATE AID DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
SERVE TODAY'S COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND DOES NOT REFLECT THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM IS NEEDED TO MAKE OUR
SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE ENSURE
MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE DEGREE.
AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN ANSWERS
THAT CALL BY EXPANDING THE
EXISTING CAL GRANT SYSTEM TO
HELP COVERED NON TUITION COSTS.
FOR OUR LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS.
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ACCESS SUCH
AS AGE RESTRICTIONS TIME OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND DOCUMENTATION
STATUS.
CONSOLIDATING AND SIMPLIFYING
THE PROGRAM INTO ONE AWARD AND
ADDING COVERAGE FOR SUMMER
SCHOOL CLASSES.
THIS BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FINANCIAL AID STAKEHOLDERS
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROCESS.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM AS WE CONTINUE TO FLESH OUT
THE DETAILS OF THIS CRITICAL.
LEGISLATION.
I AM JOINED BY CAROLINE SIEGEL
SAYING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
SABRINA EDWARDS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT.
DAVID O'BRIEN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSIONS AND LUPITA AT THE
LATTER CHIEF DEPUTY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION CHAIRED BY
STERN MEMBERS -- IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TO BE THAT CORTES
ALKALINE THE CHIEF DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT FOR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND WE ARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB --
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE BELIEVE
THAT WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF
THE MOST GENEROUS STATE
FINANCIAL AID -- PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION THAT IS LACKING IN A
LIVING EXPENSES -- THE LIVING
EXPENSES IS IS SEVERELY
INSUFFICIENT -- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT A TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE REVIEW IS NECESSARY
NEEDED.
THE CURRENT CAL GRANT SYSTEM IS
CONFUSING.
IT'S CONFUSING TO APPLY FOR
COMMUNITY FUSING TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR A ELIGIBLE -- YOU HAVE A CAL
GRANT A. B. C. IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP -- WITH
DIFFERENT GPAS WITH DIFFERENT
INCOMES WITH HIM A TIME OUT OF
SCHOOL AND IT'S TIME FOR US TO
LOOK AT WHAT THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE IS FOR A STUDENT
REGARDLESS OF THE SYSTEM THEY
ENTER INTO.
OF THE THE THERE IS A HUGE
INTRIGUE CREASING COLLEGE DEBT
FOR THE LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS.
THERE'S A ALSO AN INCREASE IN
FOOD AND HOUSING BECAUSE IT IN
SECURITY AMONG ALL STUDENTS AT
THE AT ALL TIME HIGH.
THE NEED FOR REFORM IS NOW -- WE
THE DEMOGRAPHIC OF THE STUDENT
TODAY IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN TEN
TO TWENTY YEARS AGO.
STUDENTS NEED TO WORK IN MAY
NEED TO NOT GO -- INTO COLLEGE
RIGHT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL -- AND
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOESN'T
ACCOUNT FOR THAT WE CAN'T BE
OKAY WITH STUDENTS LIVING IN
THEIR CARS -- THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CHANCE A REAL
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY.
AND SO -- AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
WOULD STREAMLINING CONSOLIDATE
ALL OUR PROGRAMS IT WOULD BE
EASIER TO ADMINISTER AN EASIER --
TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT WOULD ALSO --
SUPPLY THE SUMMER CAL GRANT SO
IT'S A BETTER EASIER TIME -- FOR
ON TIME OR ARE -- TIME TO GRIEVE
WOULD BE REDUCED CURRENTLY IT'S
AS LONG AS SIX TO EIGHT YEARS OR
LONGER.
PRIVATE NONPROFIT SCHOOLS WILL
ALSO BE PROVIDED WITH A
PREDICTABLE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE VALUE CHOICE
NOT ALL STUDENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL
IN A PARTICULAR INSTITUTION AND
SO WE OFFER THAT CHOICE WHICH IS
A GREAT ASSET TO CALIFORNIA AND
FINALLY ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
DREAMER STUDENTS.
WOULD NOW BE ELIGIBLE LIKE ANY
OTHER STUDENT FOR FINANCIAL AID
IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS SINCE
MAJOR CAL GRANT REFORM HAS
OCCURRED.
THE CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM SHOULD BE STUDENT
CENTERED THAT MEANS THAT IT
NEEDS TO REFLECT THE STUDENT
NEEDS OF TODAY SO WE WERE WE
STRONGLY REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
TIME YOU HAVE CONSUMED ABOUT
THOUGH BUT TERROR USE AT THAT
EIGHT MINUTES.
OR SO.
WHAT'S UP.
FRIEDMAN. FOUR MINUTES FOUR
MINUTES OF EACH OR ARE IS
SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
OUR OUR OUR AT AS A COULD YOU
SEE SINCE -- YOU ARE HERE OUR
EACH ALLOW ONE MINUTE ONE ME ONE
ME ONE MINUTE OKAY I THINK SHE
ALREADY USED TO FOUR MINUTES BUT
GO AHEAD [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIR MEMBERS
DAVID O'BRIEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WE ARE
THE ADMINISTRATORS OF THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM -- I WON'T USE UP
TOO MUCH OF THE TIME BY
REPEATING WHAT ARE HONORABLE
FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HAS
SAID THE POLLS -- AS THE CHIEF
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT SAID THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED
FOR STUDENTS OF A DIFFERENT ERA
AND THIS LEGISLATION IS.
A KEY STEP TOWARD DESIGNING A
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT TODAY'S STUDENTS
CAN'T AFFORD AN ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND RECTIFYING THE BUILT IN
INEQUITIES OF THE CURRENT CAL
GRANT SYSTEM SO -- WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL PROGRAM
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT I DO WANT
TO RESERVE TIME FOR STUDENTS AS
WELL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S CAROLYN SIEGEL
SAYING I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S CHEN
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TIME
TO SPEAK.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM OF FINANCIAL
AID IN THE STATE HAS FAILED TO
SERVE ON DOCUMENTS STUDENTS MANY
NONTRADITIONAL TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND REALLY STUDENTS WHO NEED
EIGHTY YEAR ROUND SO I'M GLAD TO
SEE AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN SEEKS
TO REMEDY THIS.
IN JANUARY ALL THREE STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS CAME TO THE CAPITOL
WITH A CLEAR SET OF FOUR
PRIORITIES THAT WE WANTED TO SEE
ADDRESSED.
IN THE REFORM OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THE FIRST BEING A SUMMER
AWARD SECOND COVERING THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE.
THIRD HELPING OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH THEIR
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE BEYOND
TUITION.
I ALSO COVERING THE BASIC NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS SO AGAIN WE DO
NOT HAVE TO HAVE STUDENTS USING
FOOD PANTRIES FOR THEIR MEALS
ARE SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS.
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO SEE
WHERE THIS GOES SENATE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR MAKING SENSE OF
PRIORITY THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MANY.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
MY NAME IS SABRINA EDWARD I MISS
A STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE.
AND I'M ALSO -- THE CLUBS AND OF
IN SUPPORT PRESIDENT.
AND AS THE CLUBS AND OF IN
SUPPORT PRESIDENT -- HELLO.
A LOT OF THINGS THAT I SEE
REGARDING -- CALIBER GRANTS IS
VERY DISHEARTENING FOR ME -- AB
ONE MAJOR THING THAT I FEEL IS
IMPORTANT IS THAT ARM.
THIS CALL GRANTS ARE LIKE ARE
LIKE A PORTAL.
AND THIS PORTAL.
CAL GRANTS ARE A WAY OF EITHER.
YOU KNOW FINDING A WAY TO BE
EDUCATED OR NOT BE EDUCATED.
AND ARM I THINK THAT ARM A LOT
OF THAT BIKE LOS TRANSPARENCY AS
FAR AS THE WEBSITES ARE SHOWING
ACCURATE INFORMATION -- AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
INFORMATION -- THAT IN A LOT OF
TIMES IT GETS LOST IN
TRANSLATION WITH THE STUDENTS.
I THINK THAT'S VERY ARM IS
TOTALLY LUDICROUS VERY CRUEL IN
VERY CRUDE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
STUDENTS -- THEY SHOW UP YOU
KNOW.
AT SCHOOL EXPECTING -- TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR SCHOOL AND YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THEM DON'T FIND
OUT UNTIL LATER THAT 10% OF YOU
KNOW.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE QUALIFIED
WITH GPAS AND THEY GO OR ENABLE
THANK YOU NOW I HAVE BEFORE I
TURN IT OVER TO A CHAIR -- IDEA
I NOTICED THAT THOUGHT WHAT'S
GOING TO WITH -- WITH THEM IN MY
ROOM MCAFEE'S HERE SO DIRECTOR
TO YOUR WILL CONTINUE OR
CONTINUE.
OKAY SO -- AT THE FINER PERSON
THE WOULD YOU HAVE US.
THE JOB ORDER EXPRESS.
ALL RIGHT THEN -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROCEED.
OKAY GO AHEAD.
WITH WITH WITH THAT OUT CALL.
FOR A CALL FOR OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE LINE UP AT THE
MIKE [inaudible]
THEIR NAMES.
ORGANIZATION THERE WITH.
CHEN MEMBERS ALSO EXTRA BEHALF
OF THE COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT NO
FORMAL SUPPORT POSITION YET --
BUT WE ARE VERY THANKFUL TO
CHAIR MEDINA AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARTY FOR THEIR CONTINUED
EFFORTS TO REFORM THE GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ALSO NO FORMAL
POSITION YET BUT WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORKING
CALTRANS.
I GET AFTERNOON WAS AT EVERITT
ON BEHALF ME COLLEGE LEAGUE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DIRECTION AND
REALLY THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK.
AND LISTENING TO THE NEEDS OF
CLINICAL STUDENTS.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
SINICIZATION AND LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION YET BUT WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AFTER IT'S ON THIS BILL
TO REALLY PRIORITIZE STUDENT
NEEDS -- AND ACT ACTUALLY
COMPREHENSIVELY FIX FINANCIALLY.
JOHN TO JACKSON SECRETARY
MEMBERSHIP CHAIR FOR AND OF A
CPA AT FRESNO STATE'S CAMPUS WE
SUPPORT.
SERENITY WHITEY LOW LATE
TREASURE OF FRESNO STATE AND
OVERLY C. P. AND FULL SUPPORT.
SRI PAIN PRESIDENT AND DOUBLE
ACP AM FOREMAN FORMER HOMELESS
CSU STUDENT I SUPPORT.
JERRY FOR SIDE FOUNDER BAND OF
VOTERS WIFE OF A FORMER DEAN OF
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND HE WOULD
DOES.
TOO SKY WAGONER CAL STATE LONG
BEACH STUDENT -- RECENTLY WAS --
MADE HOMELESS AND WAS WENT BUT
WENT THROUGH TEMPORARY HOUSING
AND GOING TO BE ALMOST ON MAY
EIGHTEENTH IF I DON'T FIGURE OUT
NEXT HOUSING.
BECAUSE HOUSING IS EXPENSIVE AT
SEA ISSUES DURING THE SUMMER SO
FULLY SUPPORT -- ANYTHING FROM
IRVINE -- COLLEGE STUDENT
PROBABLY ABOUT TO BE HOMELESS
SOON SO FULL SUPPORT -- MARIANNA
BONSOR OF THE TREE WHERE AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE.
ALSO THAT'S BECAUSE THEY IN OUR
FROM CSU STANISLAUS AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE OF AS
THE CALIFORNIA ADDS COALITION
OUR COALITION DOESN'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION THIS TIME BUT WE
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING IN THESE
EFFORTS AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
UNTIL EDUCATION AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THANK YOU.
HI LARA'S EITHER KEEP IT FROM
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS NO FORMAL POSITION
YET BUT WE COMMEND THE AUTHORS
FOR ENGAGING IN MUCH NEEDED
STATE FINANCIALLY REFORM EFFORTS
THAT FOCUS ON COVERING TOTAL
COLLEGE COSTS FOR NEEDY STUDENTS.
WELL IT MAY MAKE SENSE FOR
STUDENTS CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM TO BE DETERMINED THREE
REGULATION.
WE WERE GONNA STOP YOU OKAY --
INDUSTRY LOOK FOR TO WORKING
TOGETHER THANK YOU.
I'M SERRA R. C. WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE ALSO HAVE NOT TAKEN A FORMAL
POSITION BUT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE -- THE CONCEPT OF
MOVING THE STATE A PROGRAM TO
FOCUS ON TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE CONSULTING KALRA
REMOVING ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION.
CHRIS THE MCGUIRE YOUNG
INVINCIBLES NO FORMAL STANCE YET
BUT WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THINKING ABOUT ALL STUDENTS AND
HOW THEY CAN IT'S IN COLLEGE.
THE I. GUIDANCE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION -- WE'D LIKE
TO THINK -- MEMBERS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FOR THEIR WORKING ON
FRENCH AID FOR FARM THANK YOU.
ALEX GRAYS THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ALSO WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION AT THE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ENGAGEMENT -- FROM STAFF AND
MEMBERS ON THIS ISSUE AND
SUPPORT OF THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
DOES NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION AT THIS TIME HOWEVER WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
ENGAGING WITH US OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS COMPANIES REALLY
REFORM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATION WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AS THE BILL ADVANCES AND
WE LOOK FOR TO ENSURING THAT THE
CSU STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM THE
FINAL PRODUCT THANK YOU.
TYLER I ARMY AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE ALL
OF HIS -- FOR OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT ALL ECHO THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES AND WE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
ROSA DEANDRE WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
WE'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY FOR ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS
TO TRY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPTS AND THE
BILL AND WE HAVEN'T GOT A FORMAL
POSITION YET BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICES
THANK YOU AGAIN.
VICKI BOYD ALUMNI OF SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S FOCUS ON
THE FINANCIAL AID REFORM IN THE
STUDENTS TOTAL COST OF COLLEGE
AND WE JUST HAVE A CONCERN
AROUND THE IMPLEMENTATION TIME
FRAME.
ESPECIALLY WHEN SEE SACK HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSING THE NEED
FOR MANY OF THESE CHANGES SINCE
LAST FALL SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MERECE
AGE I'M A USC COLLEGE STUDENT --
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS THESE CONCEPTS IN
ADDRESSING THE NEED --
ESPECIALLY FOR A SUMMER TUITION
FOR THE HOMELESS POPULATION
FOSTER'S POPULATION IT'S VERY
MUCH NEEDED THANK YOU.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
CANYON PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS AND I THINK WE HAD
SOME ALREADY.
SEE NO MORE TWEETERS ANYMORE TO
ENTERS -- THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- DR.
I WONDER IF -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY HAS HAD ANY CHANCE -- TO
TO HAVE SOME ESTIMATE OF ACOSTA.
INVOLVED GO WITH THIS
IMPLEMENTATION.
YES I HAVE -- IT WON'T BE CHEAP
AND ONE OF THE TWISTERS BEHIND
IT SAID THEIR CONCERNS WE
HAVEN'T DONE THIS FAST ENOUGH.
AND WE'D LIKE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
RIGHT AWAY.
BUT CERTAINLY TO REVAMP OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM. TO ADDRESS
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT
FOR SOME ARBITRARY DEADLINE TO
ADDRESS THE TRUE COST OF OF OF
OF COLLEGE WITH THE NON TUITION
COSTS.
PROBABLY SOMEWHERE UPWARDS OF
TWO BILLION DOLLARS -- SO IT
WON'T BE CHEAP.
BUT WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT DIVERSE ONE OF THE
ISSUES OF OUR GENERATION IS
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY AND
GETTING MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES
IN THE PIPELINE TO FILL THE JOBS
OF TODAY AND TOMORROW.
SO WE THINK THAT WE CAN DO THIS
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS WE'RE
GOING TO TRY -- TO ADDRESS THIS
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WITH THE
DOWN PAYMENT -- BUT WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POLICY
CHANGE THAT WE NEED.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT AS FAR AS THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
IS MEANT AS WE STATED EARLIER
IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS SINCE WE
CREATED THIS CAL GRANT
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
AND EVERY YEAR WE HAVE THESE NEW --
CAL GRANT TWEAKS AND BASICALLY
OUR PROGRAM WE HAVE ALWAYS
EXCLUSIONS.
THE IT DID THERE ARE THERE ARE
SO MANY -- OFFSETS OF THIS BILL
WHO DOESN'T GET IT WHAT WE
SHOULD B<c.cyan> FOCUSING ON YOU AT</c>
THIS WHO DOES GET IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS.
IS ABOUT THE AND AND WORKING AND
WORKING IN THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS AS WELL AS THE
BILL THROUGH THE LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE -- I I THINK THAT.
THAT THAT THAT HIT RIGHT THERE
WITH THE ANSWER IS THAT YOU KNOW
THIS IS BEEN MANY MANY YEARS IN
THE MAKING WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
TWEAKING.
AROUND THE EDGES OUR FINANCIAL
AID AND CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND
EXTENDING A NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS AND FOCUSING
ON YOU KNOW STUDENTS WHO ARE
VETERAN AND STUDENTS WITH THE
WHO ARE THE IMMIGRATION STATUS
IS IN LIMBO.
AND SO WE THIS IS A HOLISTIC
VIEW OF STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AS FAR AS WHAT THE TOTAL THE
NEEDS ARE FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND LET'S FACE IT.
THE COST OF GOING TO COLLEGE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT.
THEN WHEN IT WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO TWENTY YEARS AGO YOU COULD
GET.
THE CAL GRANT -- NOW IT'S MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND HAVE A
PART TIME JOB AND GRADUATE WITH
ZERO STUDENT DEBT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD PAY YOUR
TUITION.
ON YOUR OWN THREE YOUR PART TIME
JOB OR TO YOUR FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION YOU COULD PAY FOR
YOUR HOUSING YOUR TUITION YOUR
BOOKS AND THAT'S JUST NOT THE
REALITY ANYMORE.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PIECES OF THIS BECAUSE THE
AVERAGE STUDENT DEBT LOAD IS
NORTH OF TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THAT LIMITS -- STUDENTS
AVAILABILITY AT START THEIR
CAREER START A FAMILY -- SAY FOR
YOUR RETIREMENT THE BASICS AND
IT'S IT'S HARD HURTING OUR
OVERALL -- ECONOMY AND SO WE
LOOKED VERY HARD ABOUT THIS AND
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK --
THIS INNATE COMMISSION FRANKLY
THANK OUR OUR BUDGET STAFF A
HIGHER HIGHER EDUCATION.
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING ON
THIS FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW THE
COMING UP WE THINK IS A VERY.
SMART ROBUST PACKAGE NOT JUST
PIECEMEAL BUT LOOKING AS FAR AS
WHAT DO WE NEED FOR FINANCIAL
AID FOR TODAY.
AND TEN TWENTY YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD AND WITH THIS IS THIS BILL
AND WITH THAT ASK FOR THE I BOOK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- STILL NOT HAVING A
QUORUM WE WILL.
YEAH STILL NO QUORUM WILL WAIT
TILL WE HAVE A QUORUM TO TAKE A
VOTE BUT I THINK THE STUDENTS
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
PRESENTING.
THANK YOU ALSO TO THE TO THE
PIZZA FROM THE PUBLIC --
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION
THANK YOU FOR THE YOU OFFER.
NEXT WE HAVE A YES ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR A. B. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE SMITH
.
WELCOME THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
READY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M DOING MOMENT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHICH TAKE PLACE ON HIGHER
INSTITUTION CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN
EXCELLENT TOOLS FOR ENCOURAGING
COLLEGE READINESS.
TAKING COLLEGE COURSES WHILE IN
HIGH SCHOOL KNOWN AS CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT OFFERS THREE KEY
BENEFITS ONE REDUCTION OF TIME
TO DEGREE COMPLETION. TO
INCREASE IN COLLEGE ATTAINMENT
AND THREE CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS.
PARTICIPATING STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMPLETE COLLEGE THAN
THEIR NON PARTICIPATING PEERS
AND CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT HAS
PROVEN PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE
FOR YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
STUDENTS NOT ONLY GAIN VALUABLE
CAREER SKILLS OR GENERAL
EDUCATION UNITS THAT CAN
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY BUT THEY ALSO LEARN
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE.
THIS GIVES THEM THE CONFIDENCE
TO CONTINUE WITH COLLEGE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL PUTS THEM ON A PATH
TOWARD ACHIEVING THEIR ACADEMIC
GOALS.
SUMMER IS THE IDEAL TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AS STUDENTS
ARE FREE OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND WORKLOAD THAT COME WITH
RIGHT THEIR REGULAR HIGH SCHOOL
ACADEMIC YEAR.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHO CAN ENROLL IN SUMMER COURSES
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ONLY 5% OF STUDENTS PER GRADE
LEVEL HER SCHOOL ARE PERMITTED
TO ENROLL IN THESE PROGRAMS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE EXPAND
COLLEGE ACCESS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS DURING THE SUMMER BY
REMOVING THE 5% LIMITATION FOR
STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN GENERAL
EDUCATION COURSES THAT TRANSFER
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY OR
CAREER EDUCATION COURSES.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY A WITNESS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL ERIC HARNISCH VICE
PRESIDENT PUBLIC INFORMATION
ADVOCACY AND EXTERNAL RELATIONS
FOR COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE TERM MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE AS A
MEMBER SAID THIS BILL REMOVES
LIMITATION ON THE NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO CAN TAKE
CLASSES AT THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
DURING THE SUMMER -- FOR US A
CALL TO THE CANYONS.
MORE THAN A THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS GET A JUMP START ON
COLLEGE EACH YEAR -- BY TAKING
CLASSES AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS MATH THROUGHOUT THE THE
DIFFERENCE MASTERS.
WE WE'RE WE WAIVE ENROLLMENT
FEES FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SO
CLASSES ARE FREE FOR THEM.
THEY NOT ONLY GAIN VALUABLE
CAREER SKILLS WERE IN GENERAL
EDUCATION UNITS THAT CAN
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY.
BUT THEY WERE IN THE THAT THAT
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE -- ARE THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE IN ROLE
SUCCEED ACADEMICALLY IN THEIR
COLLEGE COURSES -- THEY REALLY
OUTPERFORM -- THE NATIVE --
COLLEGE AGE STUDENTS THAT
THEY'RE SITTING NEXT TO IN THEIR
CLASSES.
AS OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
CONTINUES ITS EFFORTS TO MEET
THE AMBITIOUS VISION FOR SUCCESS
GOALS OF INCREASING DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES.
TRANSFER MORE STUDENTS TO FOUR
UNIVERSITIES AND HELPING MORE
STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY MOVED FROM
CLASSROOMS O CAREERS WE NEED TO
CREATE MORE THESE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS -- AB SEVENTY
TWENTY I HAS SOME IMPORTANT
DISTINCTIONS FROM THE COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS OTHER
ALSO IN EXISTENCE.
SEE CAP CLASSES AS THEY ARE
KNOWN ARE GENERALLY HELD AT HIGH
SCHOOL SITES DURING THE REGULAR
SCHOOL DAY.
AND AND AND THOSE CLASSES ARE
ONLY AVAILABLE IF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT ESTABLISH A FORMAL
PARTNERSHIP -- AS WELL COLLEGES --
MUST PAY FOR THE COST OF
TEXTBOOKS IN ENROLLED IN THOSE
PROGRAMS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE OFFERS
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR STUDENTS
GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENROLL IN ALMOST ANY COURSE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OFFERS DURING
THE SUMMER.
SOMERS THE IDEAL TIME FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO ENROLL THE
FREE THE RESPONSIBILITIES A
WORKLOAD -- THE COME IN THE
REGULAR ACADEMIC YEAR -- MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEY TAKE THE
CLASSES AT THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
GIVING THEM A CHANCE TO
EXPERIENCE CAMPUS LIFE.
MAKE USE OF SUPPORT RESOURCES
LIKE FREE TUTORING.
AND LEARN THAT THEY CAN INDEED
BE SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE.
FINALLY OUR LOCAL PARENTS TELL
SAID THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT FOR
STUDENTS -- WHEN WE SURVEYED THE
PARENTS OF ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH
GRADERS -- IN OUR DISTRICT. 88%
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN THEIR
STUDENTS TAKING CLASSES AT
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE WOULD
ALLOW MORE THAN TO DO JUST THAT
AND THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WINNERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM [inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTION.
BUT WE STILL DON'T HAVE A I
DON'T THINK WE WE STILL HAVE A
QUORUM -- SO.
WILL HOLD OFF ON THE MOTION AYE
AYE QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR -- ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS --
THE COMMITTEE OF BRINGS UP TO
TWO TWO CONCERNS ONE HAVING TO
DO WITH -- THE SCENARIO WHERE
THE THE STUDENT ADULT STUDENT
POPULATION GOES UP -- AND THE
IMPACT.
THAT THE REMOVING THE 5% CAP ON
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WOULD HAVE
ON THEM AND THE OTHER --
CONCERNED THAT THEY BRING UP IS --
PROTECTING -- MINERS ON ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES SO
JUST -- HOPING THAT I GET
COMMITMENT FROM FROM THE AUTHORS
THAT CHILL WORK WITH THE STAFF
ON ON THOSE TWO CONCERNS OF
COURSE WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF
ANALYSIS ON THIS AND AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION AS WE MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
THAT ONCE WE HAVE A CORE WILL
TAKE A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A ITEM SEVEN A. B.
NINE THIRTY MR GLORIA.
WHO'S BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY.
WELCOME MR GLORIA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
VERY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
PRESENT AB NINE THIRTY TO
PROMOTE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY WHILE
PROHIBITING THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES FROM INCREASING
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION.
IN YEARS WHEN SITUATION IS
INCREASED THE BOARD TRUSTEES WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR CHANGES TO
THE SALARIES OF EXECUTIVES VOTED
TO INCREASE TUITION BY 5%.
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY IN JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
VOTED TO INCREASE SALARIES A
PRESENCE BY 3% DESPITE THE THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN'S URGE TO REJECT
THIS THESE AUGMENTATIONS.
UNDER GOVERNOR NEWSOME -- PARTS
PROPOSED BUDGET THE CSU RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED MILLION --
IN ONGOING FUNDS FOR STUDENT
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CONDITION
THAT STUDENT TUITION NOT BE
INCREASED AB NINE THIRTY WOULD
MAKE SURE THE CSU LIVES UP TO
THIS CONDITION BY REQUIRING THE
FOLLOWING.
FIRST THAT EXECUTIVE PAY CANNOT
INCREASE IN YEARS WHEN THERE'S
STUDENT TUITION INCREASE.
IN SECOND ANY POLICIES OR
PROCEDURES OR INCREASES TO
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION MUST BE
PLACED ON THE BOARD TRUSTEES
AGENDA FOR INITIAL PUBLIC
HEARING WITH THE VOTE TO TAKE
PLACE AT A SECOND CONSECUTIVE.
HERE.
FINALLY THE CSU CHANCELLOR MUST
MANDATE ICHI CAMPUS TO PREPARE
AND REPORT QUARTERLY COMPARISONS
OF CAMPUS BUDGETS TO ITS ACTUAL
SPENDING LEVELS.
LAST YEAR WITH A HUGE WIN FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS AND BY
INCREASING STERN ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY IN EQUITY WITHIN
THE CSU SYSTEM.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE EVEN MORE
OPTIMISTIC START -- TO THE
BUDGET CYCLE AND WE MUST PUT
STUDENTS FIRST EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY DOES PRECISELY THAT WITH
ME TO USE TESTIFIED SUPPORT IS
JENNY IN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION PRESENT.
AS WELL AS NEW I'M -- I'D MOPAR
I KNOW WHY THAT WAS HARD FOR ME
TO GET OUTSIDE OF A IT'S A AS I
PRESIDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
GOOD AFTERNOONMISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS JENNY AGAIN I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND US YES
YOU EAST BAY PROFESSOR OF
PHILOSOPHY AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AND ADMINISTRATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTY AND AT
SPONSOR OF THE BILL -- I'D VERY
MUCH LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA FOR ALL HIS
WORK ON THIS BILL -- AND A. B.
NINE THIRTY IS THAT STRAIGHT
FORWARD GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL.
AB NINE THIRTY WOULD SEEK TO
PROHIBIT CSU TRUSTEES FROM
APPROVING EXECUTIVE PAY
INCREASES DURING YEARS CSU
INCREASES.
STUDENT TUITION.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT EXECUTIVE PAY
INCREASES INCLUDING ANY POLICY
OR PROCEDURE RELATING TO
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION PAY
INCREASES.
MUST BE PLACED ON THE CSU
TRUSTEES BOARD AGENDA AS AN
INITIAL INFORMATION ITEM WITH
THE SUBSEQUENT VOTE ON EXECUTIVE
COM AT COMPENSATION TO TAKE
PLACE AT A FOLLOWING CONSECUTIVE
BOARD MEETING -- THIS IS TO
ALLOW FOR MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
COMMENT BETWEEN THE INTRODUCTION
OF THE PAY INCREASES IN THE VOTE.
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED JUST
THIS PAST JULY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES SWIFTLY APPROVED A 3%.
ACROSS THE BOARD PAY INCREASE
FOR EXECUTIVES.
THIS ACTION ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER PAST ACTIONS HAS
DEMONSTRATED AN INSENSITIVITY TO
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND IT
SHOWS THE CSU BOARD THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO BE OUT OF STEP WITH
WHAT THE PUBLIC EXPECTS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE GREATER
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND SEE THAT THEY
PRIORITIZE STUDENTS OVER
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION.
FINALLY THIS MEASURE REQUIRES
EACH OF THE TWENTY THREE CSU
CAMPUSES TO SUBMIT QUARTERLY
BUDGET COMPARISON REPORTS TO THE
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
A AB NINE THIRTY IS A BILL THAT
WILL BRING GREATER FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
TO THE USUAL WAY OF THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
THAT IS THE USUAL WAY THEY DO
BUSINESS.
THE LAW IS CLEAR THE CSU IS
SUBJECT TO FULL LEGISLATIVE
CONTROL UNDER STATUTE AND ALL OF
CS USE EXEMPT EMPLOYEES ARE
STATE EMPLOYEES.
THE CSU IS NOT A PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTITY THAT IS SUBJECT TO THE
FREE MARKET.
IT IS A PUBLIC ENTITY MAKE
FUNDED THROUGH STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES -- THROUGH
TUITION DOLLARS AND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO THE GENERAL FUND AND
IT IS OPERATED BY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DELEGATED AUTHORITY TO THE
TRUSTEES MEANING THAT THE
TRUSTEES CAN DETERMINE EXECUTIVE
PAY BUT ONLY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATUREHAS DELEGATED THAT
AUTHORITY TO THEM.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN AT ANY TIME
MAKE CHANGES TO THAT AUTHORITY
OR PUT CONDITIONS ON THAT AT THE
READY.
AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF AB NINE THIRTY TO
SEE GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND HOW THEY OPERATE
WHEN VOTING FOR EXECUTIVE.
COMPENSATION INCREASES.
I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE MIDI
COMMITTEE THAT THE MAIN PURPOSE
OF THE CSU IS TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE PUBLIC
EDUCATION TO OUR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. FOR THE MORE THE
QUARTERLY BUDGET REPORTING PIECE
OF THE BILL IS NOT DUPLICATIVE.
THE WAY IN WHICH IN WHICH THE
CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES DISPERSES
ITS ANNUAL GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION TO EACH CAMPUS.
IS OPAQUE CERTAINLY TO THOSE OF
US TO KEEP AN EYE ON IT AND HOW
EACH CAMPUS MANAGES THAT UP BY
LOCATION THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO TRACK TO
ENSURE THAT BASIC STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
REQUIRED. TO BE FUNDED THROUGH
TUITION ACTUALLY ARE FUNDED IN
WAYS THEY SHOULD BE.
THIS AGAIN POINTS TO LACK OF AND
AND TO LACK OF IN GREATER NEED
FOR FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE CSU.
WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAKE HOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND ON BEHALF OF CFA WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND TO CHAIR MEDINA.
THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AND TO CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND IN
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- MY
NAME IS NO WELL MORE -- AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT
OF ASSOCIATED STUDENTS AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AS WELL AS A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
AS YOU KNOW TUITION FOR THE CSU
SYSTEM HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY IN RECENT YEARS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME SO HAVE
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION PACKAGES.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THIS BILL ENCOURAGES
FOR TRANSPARENCY IN OUR SYSTEM
BY ACQUIRING THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO INCLUDE.
THE PROPOSED EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION INCREASES -- ON
THEIR AGENDA AS INFORMATION
ITEMS AND FOR PUBLIC HEARING
PRIOR TO BEING CONSIDERED FOR A
VOTE IN THE NEXT MEETING.
AT THE SAME TIME THERE SHOULD BE
NO DOUBT WHATSOEVER THAT WE
VALUE OUR EXECUTIVES
TREMENDOUSLY I NOT ONLY
APPRECIATE MY CAMPUS PRESIDENT.
BUT I THINK HIS ROLE OUR
UNIVERSITY HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE AND INVALUABLE.
THERE'S NO BIGGER
DISILLUSIONMENT FOR STUDENTS
HOWEVER.
THEN TO SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATE TO
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE AND TO OUR
GOVERNOR -- FOR THE ADEQUATE
FUNDS TO RESOURCE ARE
EDUCATION'S ONLY TO HAVE THESE
FUNDS -- USED FOR EXECUTIVE
SALARY INCREASES RATHER THAN
AGAIN SAID EGGS EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES.
IN FACT THIS YEAR THE CSSA BOARD
APPROVED TO PRIOR RESOLUTIONS.
TO ADDRESS THESE EXACT ISSUES.
TO CLARIFY THIS IS NOT AN EITHER
OR SITUATION IF CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE SO DIRE THAT ARE CSU BOARD
OF TRUSTEES NEEDS TO CONSIDER OR
EVEN IMPLEMENT.
A STUDENT TUITION INCREASE THANK
CLEARLY THERE SHOULDN'T BE --
ANY MONEY AVAILABLE TO INCREASE
THE SALARIES OF OUR
ADMINISTRATORS.
I REMEMBER VISITING THE CSU
WEBSITE EARLIER THIS YEAR FOR
SOMETHING -- AND I'VE BEEN
READING A VERY POWERFUL MISSION
STATEMENT THAT REALLY SPOKE TO
ME.
AND IT'S DEFINED STUDENT SUCCESS
PARTIALLY AS MAKING COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE TO MORE CALIFORNIANS.
I LOOK AT THAT WHEN WE COULD SEE
CONTINUING RAISES TO SEE CSU
STUDENT TUITION.
AND HOW THIS DOES NOT DELIVER TO
THE PROMISE NOR CORE PRINCIPLES --
WHEN WE DO THINGS LIKE THIS I'M
ESPECIALLY WHEN INCREASING
SALARIES WHICH DEVIATES EVEN
FARTHER FROM OUR OVERALL
PROGRESS?
BUT IT'S REALLY AN ETHICAL
APPEAL.
WE JUST ASK THAT THERE BE AN
ETHICAL CONSIDERATION AS TO THE
OVERALL BUDGET PROCESS AND
STUDENT RIGHTS.
WE ASK FOR THESE REASONS TO FOR
YOU TO SUPPORT AB.
NINE THIRTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THEY COME UP TO THE MIKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
OF THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS RENE
BAYARDO SO YOU CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THEY COME UP TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ENTER MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY -- WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY BE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE -- WE DON'T SEE A
CORRELATION BETWEEN WHAT.
WHAT OUR STUDENTS TO FEED
TUITION FEE INCREASE AND THESE
ARE CONVERSATION?
WHAT THE CONNECTION IS BETWEEN
THOSE TWO ENTITIES THEY'RE MADE
IN SEPARATE?
OUR PACKAGES AND FRANKLY IT
REALIZE WHAT WE GET FROM THE
STATE WE CONSIDER TUITION
THE FACT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR HAVE PROVIDED
FUNDING FOR US THIS YEAR.
AND THERE WILL BE A TUITION FEE
INCREASE THIS YEAR FOR STUDENTS --
FRANKLY TUITION AT THE CSU HAS
BEEN REMAIN FLAT FOR THE LAST --
EIGHT SEVENTY YEARS BUT WE HAVE
INCREASED TUITION A RELATIVELY
MODESTLY Là LAST YEAR -- AND
THAT WAS TO ADDRESS GRADUATION
IS DEPOSED ALTER SUPPOSEDLY
SPELL FOR GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
WE HAVE INCREASED -- WE HAVE
GIVEN COMPETITION POLLS TO OUR
EMPLOYEES ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES --
CLICK A BARGAIN BOYS AND OUR
EXECUTIVES.
THE COMPETITION PROVIDED FOR
IS AT A AT A RATE LOWER ART AT
THE SAME RATE AS WE GET INTO OUR
PLACE OUR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
WE THINK WE'VE BEEN GOOD
STEWARDS WITH THE STATE'S
DOLLARS WE'VE BEEN RESPONSIVE.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL
PUNISHES THE SYSTEM FOR
SOMETHING I'M NOT REALLY SURE
THAT WE'VE DONE WRONG. FOR THAT
REASON WE MUST BE OPPOSE THE
MEASURE AND THEN FRANKLY THE
OTHER ISSUE IS THE COURT
REPORTING WE WE DON'T HONESTLY
KNOW WHAT IT IS THAT WE HAVE NOT
PROVIDED THE STATE.
WE'RE COMES TRANSPARENCY WE ARE
WORK WITH A LOOK THE PART OF
FINANCE WE WERE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES.
EVER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
IT IS THAT WE PER WEEK HOW WE
SPEND OUR TO OUR EXPENDITURES.
SO WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT IT IS THE
ADDITIONAL VALUE OF THE COURT
REPORTING FOR THE CAMPUS IS TO
ASSIST OFFICE TO THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD PROVIDE TO YOU.
AFTER THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED.
ANY TWO WINNERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
MISTER GLORY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TO CLOSE THE SHERMAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPTION PRESENT
THIS BILL IN FOR CONTINUED
DIALOGUE WITH MY OFFICE -- TO
GET TO THE OF THE NINE
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE HAVE
TODAY AND OVER THERE WAS A
STRONG CONCERNS I'M HOT FOR THE
CHAIR BUT I THINK YOU KNOW MY
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING.
BOTH YOUR CONCERNS THE
COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS AS WELL AS
THE CSU SYSTEM ABOUT ME THESE
THINGS ARE CONNECTED -- TO SAY
THE TUITION AND EXECUTIVE PAY
ARE NOT CONNECTED -- I THINK IS
IS IS.
HARD TO MAKE THAT CONNECTION I
MEAN HARD TO HARD TO MAKE THAT
CONCLUSION OF A FOR ASKING
STUDENTS TO PAY MORE -- WHAT
SOME OF HIS HE RAISING EXECUTIVE
SALARIES I DON'T KNOW THAT ANY
OF US CAN GO HOME TO OUR
DISTRICTS EXPLAIN -- I THINK
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR WORK
CERTAINLY ALLOWING THE CSU TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS THIS YEAR THEY'RE
NOT A FORECAST NAY TUITION
INCREASE -- SO THEREFORE THEY
CAN INCREASE EXECUTIVE SALARIES --
BUT I THINK THE ABILITY TO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THOSE
DECISIONS A TO PROVIDE JUST
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS HOLDING TRUE TO THAT
NOTION OF THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A TUITION INCREASE EXACTLY PAY
INCREASE.
I THINK THIS BILL IS HOPEFULLY
SOMETHING THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
TODAY -- IT OF COURSE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK -- I KNOW THE
CHAIRMAN HAS SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE REPORTING WE CAN ACTUALLY
WORK ON THAT MR CHAIRMAN -- IS
POSING A CONCERNS NEVER THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
EVERY STEP ESCRIBIR THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING IT FORWARD IT DOES HAVE A
NINE RECOMMENDATION.
I'D I'D DO WOULD SHARE THE THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE -- THE
POTENTIAL FOR TAKING AWAY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE TRUSTEES -- BUT
BUT THE THAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VOTE AS THEY SEE FIT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD AND ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL CALL FOR THE VOTE
GOD WILLING THANK YOU SIR.
SO WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER --
ONE A. B. FORTY EIGHT MISTER
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE WELCOME MISTER O'DONNELL.
MAYBE GET THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR THEIR GUIDANCE -- AND
SUGGESTIVE LANGUAGE.
AB FORTY EIGHT IS A VEHICLE FOR
TO SCHOOL FACILITY BONDS ONE IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ONE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE STATE HAS
BEEN A STRONG PARTNER TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
AND MODERNIZATION OF K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LOCAL BONDS AND DEVELOPER
FEES.
THESE FUNDS ENSURE THAT OUR K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AREN'T SAFE.
AND UPDATED FACILITIES.
AND BENEFIT THE ECONOMY BY
GENERATING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS.
THE LEGISLATURE PLACED AND
VOTERS APPROVED.
TO US STATE TO STATE FACILITIES
BONDS ONE AND WELL ACTUALLY
SEVERAL ONE AND THE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TWO THOUSAND SIX
THE LAST BOND PROPOSITION FOR
FIFTY ONE WAS PASSED TEN YEARS
LATER.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE WAS A
LARGE GAP IN TIME.
DO THE LANKY GAP FUNDS FROM THE
PROPOSITION FUNNY FIFTY ONE ARE
NEARLY DEPLETED.
THE NEED IS GREAT AND I ALWAYS
SAY SCHOOL FACILITIES SET THE
TONE FOR THE SCHOOL DAY.
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FIVE YEAR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PLAN ESTIMATES A
TEN YEAR NEED A FORTY TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION.
THIS BILL PLACES CATER FOR THE
A. K. THROUGH FOURTEEN BOND ON
THE MARCH THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
PRIMARY ELECTION BALLOT.
AND ANOTHER ONE IN ON THE
NOVEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO GENERAL ELECTION BALLOT.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS WILL BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS.
BASED ON A RECOMMENDATION BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS OFFICE THIS
BILL PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON HOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOND FUND
SHOULD BE SPENT.
BALANCING LIFE SAFETY PROJECTS
WITH PROJECTS TO ADDRESS GROWTH
AND OTHER NEEDS.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BASED ON
PRIORITIES ESTABLISHED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND PROVIDE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION FOR BOND
EXPENDITURES.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS THE STATE'S
PARTNERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
OUR K. FOURTEEN STUDENTS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
REBEKAH CURLY WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION --
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH
CURLY ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION.
AB FORTY EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDS FOR OUR VERY SUCCESSFUL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROGRAM AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL MENTIONED THE NEED IS
GREAT. FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
ALONE IT'S ACTUALLY THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN OF COURSE
THAT GROWS.
AS WE LOOK OUT FOR THREE YEARS
FACILITIES ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
AND CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
PROVIDING A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
EDUCATION.
AS WELL AS CAREER TRAINING AND
THEIR CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING
PRIORITIES SUCH AS STUDENT
SUCCESS.
AB FORTY EIGHT WOULD FIND AT THE
EXISTING CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM
THAT WE KNOW AND LOVE IT WILL
PROVIDE COLLEGES MORE CERTAINTY
AS THEY PLAN THEIR PROJECTS AS
WELL AS THEIR BOND PROGRAMS.
BY ADDING DETAIL TO THE BOND
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE ON
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WHICH
PROJECTS TO PRIORITIZE AND
ULTIMATELY WHICH PROJECTS TO
FUND.
THIS PROGRAM ALWAYS PRIORITIZES
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROJECTS FIRST
AND AB FORTY EIGHT WOULD
MAINTAIN NOT APPROACH BUT IT
WOULD ALSO ENSURE PRIORITIZING
PROJECS THAT WILL.
ADD ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTIONAL
SPACE THINK LABS CLASSROOMS
OTHER FACILITIES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO EDUCATING STUDENTS
AND IT WILL ALSO HELP MODERNIZE
RENOVATE AN UPGRADE OUR
FACILITIES TO OUR TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY STANDARDS.
THIS PROGRAM HAS SERVED COLLEGES
WHILE AND IT PROVIDES ACCESS TO
A HIGHER EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS
ALL ACROSS THE STATE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN FOOT HELD THE
ENDS -- SAN FRANCISCO SAN
BERNADINO PERALTA AND YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS ALL
IN SUPPORT I THINK THE ANALYSIS
LAYS OUT -- EXCELLENTLY THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL THE AUTHOR DIDN'T
EXCELLENT JOB EXPLAINING THE
STATE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE'VE HAD OVER THE LAST FEW
BONDS -- AND THIS WOULD CONTINUE
IN THAT DIRECTION.
ADDITIONALLY AS MY COLLEAGUES
STATED THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL RELATED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD HELP SCHOOLS --
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THEY
NEED TO PRIORITIZE AS THEY APPLY
FOR THESE BONDS -- TO THE STATE
MOVING FORWARD SO WE WOULD URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALSO WEBSTER ON
BEHALF OF THE RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS THAT NEVER IT
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S --
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE HERE
IN SUPPORT -- AND ALSO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INCLUDING MEASURES
THAT REDUCE A WHAT HAS BECOME AN
A CONFUSING PROCESS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IAN
PEDIA WITH THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION AND THE COUNTY
SCHOOL FACILITIES CONSORTIUM
STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KEVIN FROM
AROUND THE HALF THE COMPTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATION ASSOCIATION
OF BLACK SCHOOL EDUCATORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU -- BALK
AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD LION ON
BEHALF OF THE HOME BUILDERS
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND OF FUNDING
PARTNER ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE HAVE STUDENTS
ATTENDING THROUGH THE ENTIRE
SPECTRUM OF K. THROUGH FOURTEEN
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LARA MATS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WE SHOULD HAVE A FOUR THIRTY
CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK -- SOME REMOTE TOWN ON
THE FUNDING QUESTIONS SIDE.
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT I KNOW WHAT THE
OUT AGING IN OKAY.
TO TWELVE FOR BUT THE MOSTLY --
DEUCE.
WE'RE TRYING TO MATT THE BY A OF
LOCAL ENTITIES SO RAISING THERE.
ARE NOT A LOCAL TAX.
IN THAT THIS WILL A MAN --
READING GET ANALYSIS HERE WE
ALREADY HAVE A ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
OUTSTANDING BONDS.
NUMBER OF BOND SAID THAT HAVE
BEEN ALREADY UP APPROVED HAVE
NOT BEEN EVEN ISSUED THE THIS
ARE NOT FULLY UTILIZED.
AND ON TOP OF EXISTING.
KNOWLEDGE THAT'S THAT THOUGH YOU
ARE TRYING TO ADD THE AND NOT
THE I MEAN THIS IS A GOOD CASA I
KNOW THIS PART OF COMMITTEES ARE
NOT THE BUDGET COMMITTEES OF THE
POLICY COMMITTEE BUT THE HOWEVER
WE WE HAVE -- TO CONSIDER THE
IMPACT OF YOUR BILL WHEN IT
PASSES.
AND I HEAR THAT THE NORMAL PRICE
TAG THAT HAS BEEN NOT CALCULATED
FOR IMPLEMENTING THIS BE AND HOW
MUCH I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU
HAVE DISCOVERED THE LATER BUT
THAT THIS ANALYSS AS NOAH.
UPON THE MOUNT THE HAS BEEN
DISCLOSED.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHEN -- WITH --
DISTORT THE GOOD IDEA. TO HAD A
SEVERAL HUNDRED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TOP ON NEW BOND.
RATHER THAN NOT LEAVING ARE
LOCALLY OF FOR EXAMPLE -- IT.
HI IN THE AREA THAT I COME FROM
MARCH IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TRY TO PASS A THE OWN
POSITIVE TAX OF FOUR WEEKS AFTER
MISS A MINUTE OF A PURPOSES SO.
SO.
I KNOW IT IS A STRUGGLE.
BUT NOW WHEN WE TRY TO IMPLEMENT
THIS OF THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS REGARDING THE LOCAL
SITUATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THIS IS THE
ANSWER.
WELL I THINK THERE COUPLE
QUESTIONS MAYBE A COUPLE
STATEMENTS IN THEIR FIRST WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE EXISTING BOND --
THAT BOND MONEY HAS BEEN CLAIMED
IT HASN'T ALL BEEN DISTRIBUTED
BECAUSE THE BONTA HAVING ALL
BEEN FLOATED AT THE STATE LEVEL
BUT AGAIN THAT MONEY WILL GO
DOWN TO THE LOCALS ONCE.
ONCE -- ONCE THOSE BONDS ARE
SOLD WERE WAITING FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO ALLOW MORE THOSE
LAWS WE STILL GET THAT'S FROM
THE LAST BONTA THAT MONEY HAS
BEEN ESSENTIALLY CLAIM.
GOING FORWARD THIS IS A BOMB I
DON'T EXPECT THIS BOND WILL BE
ANYWHERE NEAR A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS I DON'T THINK IT'LL BE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS -- AT
BEST IT MAYBE TEN BILLION
DOLLARS WE DON'T KNOW TODAY BUT
WE I I IMAGINE ALL THE SOMEWHERE
IN THAT RANGE SO WHERE YOU.
YOU'RE GETTING THE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FIGURE I
DON'T KNOW BUT THAT THAT THAT
ACTUALLY IS IS AN ACCURATE.
NOW THE LOCALS MIGHT FLOAT THEIR
OWN BOND.
WHICH COULD MATCH THE STATE
DOLLARS BUT AGAIN THAT WOULD
EXCEED.
THE STATE BOND DOLLAR THRESHOLD
IF YOU.
ABOUT THE HERE I I DO SEE I DO
READ THAT THAT IF I MAY TAKE
SOME TIME ME -- THEN WHAT THAT
TOO MUCH TIME -- IT SAYS IN
ADDITION THE STATE HAS A THIRTY
THREE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
OF AUTHORIZED UP BUT THE ISSUE.
YOUR DEATH.
AND THE MORE SO -- USTED HIS --
A NIGHT IN THIS POINT I MAY I I
THINK THAT SPEAKS -- TO THAT
POTENTIALLY SPEAKS [inaudible]
TO THE ENTIRE.
THE THE ENTIRE AMOUNT OF
OUTSTANDING BONDS THE STATE HAS
CURRENTLY.
AND IN A STATE THIS LARGE A
STATE WITH AS MUCH REVENUE AS WE
HAVE I WOULD MANAGE THAT I WOULD
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT FIGURE IS
PRETTY MANAGEABLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT THE MINISTER.
HAS CHUNK OF MONEY A LOT OF
MONEY NO DOUBT BUT THERE ARE ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TEN THOUSAND
SCHOOLS. SIX POINT TWO MILLION
SCHOOL CHILDREN SO IT'S A BIG
OPERATION AND IT DOES TAKE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- OKAY HAVE
YOU -- CONTACTED -- A DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- WHETHER THEY
COULD TAKE CARE OF ALL.
ON THE ON DISTRICT -- I'M SORRY
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
I MEAN -- ANY SCHOOL FACILITY --
UP FUNDS SO NECESSARY BY EACH IS
A DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICT I
EAT US MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
UNION NOT LAW.
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
THEY MAY HAVE -- DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS UP IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT MAY NOT NEED TO SUCH A
BOND.
OKAY -- WHEN THEY NEED IT THAT
THEY COULD -- FLOW THROUGH OWN
BOND.
AND DETERMINED UP IDA UP OF A
BORDERS TAXPAYERS OF THAT
DISTRICT THE RATHER THAN WE
IMPOSE THEM.
SO SO IN THIS CASE IF THEY IF
THEY CHOSE TO FLOAT AROUND BOND
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THEY COULD
SEE EACH SEEK A MATCH FROM THE
STATE.
DID THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I
MEAN IF THEY DON'T NEED THE
MONEY THEY SHOULDN'T FOR THE
BOND.
BUT THIS IS THE ISSUE MAY WAIT
ROB ON MAYBE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND.
I'D LIKE TO ADD AS WELL THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE NEED FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO FOR
EXAMPLE OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
IT'S THIRTY BILLION THAT GOES UP
TO ABOUT FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
WE LOOK AT WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
AUTHORIZED FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT IS YET ON ISSUED IN
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF REASONS
WHY SOME.
OF FUNDS MAYBE ON ISSUED YOU
KNOW YOUR ASSESSED VALUATION
GOES DOWN YOU CANNOT ACCESS WHAT
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY VOTERS
GIVEN WHERE THE ECONOMY IS AND
AND WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY ACCESS THIS FIRST CASH.
WE LOOK AT ALL OF THAT NEED AND
WE LOOK AT THIS A YOU KNOW A
COUPLE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE STATE
BOND IT STILL DOESN'T MEET THE
ENTIRE GAP OF THE NEED TO THAT
WE HAVE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES ALONE.
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING ABOUT
THIRTY TO FORTY BILLION DOLLAR
RANGE AND THEN YOU ADD FOR K.
TWELVE THAT AMOUNT IS WELL OVER
A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
AND FOR RENOVATING MODERNIZING
EXISTING FACILITIES SO WE HAVE
THIS VERY BROAD DEEP NEED AND WE
KNOW THAT THE LOCAL AND STATE.
RESOURCES WILL NOT BRIDGE THAT
GAP WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE CAN --
BUT THE NEED FAR EXCEEDS THE
RESOURCES THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
AVAILABLE.
WAS THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
WOULD THIS BE ON OF COMPETITIVE --
APPLICATION BASED -- HE SAID
THERE'S A THERE'S AN ESTABLISHED
PROCESS FOR DISTRICTS TO APPLY
FOR THE FUNDING [inaudible]
THANK.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A QUORUM --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE -- ITEM.
TEN AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE MISS
WICKS [inaudible]
SHE'S HERE.
WELCOME IS WICKS.
I THINK I HAVE TO WITH YOU RIGHT
YOU DO YOU HAVE A AB. ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE TWELVE TWENTY NINE
WATCH WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO.
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE ELEVEN FIFTY
THREE WHERE MY AGAIN. 1-156-
REELS PRESENTING.
TO ITEM.
TEN THE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- THE CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT REPORTING ACT
AS WE REFER TO REQUIRES THAT A
MANDATED REPORTER.
AT REQUIRES THAT A MAN THAT A
MANDATED REPORTER REPORT
WHENEVER HERE SHE IN HIS OR HER
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY OR WITHIN
HIS OR HER SCOPE OF EMPLOYMENT.
HAS KNOWLEDGE OR IS OBSERVE A
CHILD THAT HAS BEEN A VICTIM OF
CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUS.
NOW AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE MORE
MORE MINERS ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE ARE CREATING CHILD
CARE CENTERS THERE WHICH IS A
GREAT THING.
WE ALSO HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT ARE -- ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I WAS ONE OF
THOSE MYSELF -- BUT IT MEANS --
FOLKS UNDER EIGHTEEN ARE ON OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES MORE
MORE -- SO WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO
HAVE THIS IMPORTANT TRAINING TO
RECOGNIZE AND UNDERSTAND -- WHEN --
ABUSE OR NEGLECT IS HAPPENING
ALTHOUGH SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE SETTING HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THIS TRAINING
EMPLOYEES AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED.
MY BILL -- ELEVEN FIFTY THREE
WILL SIMPLY EXTEND THE TRAINING
AND REQUIRE CLASSIFIED STAFF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO UNDERGO
THE TRAINING MODULE THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS SO IT'S ADDING.
SOME MORE CURRICULUM ONTO A
CURRENT EXISTING TRAINING
PROGRAM.
AND TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMENTS -- WE PLAN TO CLARIFY
AN OFFER GUIDANCE TO DISTRICTS
ON OTHER TRAINING MODELS THAT
THEY MAY OPT TO USE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND INTRODUCE OUR
WITNESS CHRISTY BULMA.
CAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
VELMA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I'LL BE OF INTEREST
AND BROWN.
AND OUR OTHER SAID IT PERFECTLY
SO JUST SAY WELL YOU KNOW THE
OBLIGATIONS EXISTS BUT THE
TRAINING ISN'T ALWAYS PRESENT
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
STAFF SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TO MAKE SURE WE'RE TRAINED.
TO KEEP THE CHILDREN AROUND AS A
SAFE AND PROVIDE THE
INTERVENTIONS THEY NEED. TO
PREVENT SUCH VIOLENCE WE ARE
YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
I I I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD --
BEING A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND
ELEMENTARY TEACHER BEFORE THAT I
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
MANDATED -- TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND HAVING BEEN ALSO IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
KNOWING HOW -- HOW MUCH MORE --
MINERS ARE NOW BEEN ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I THINK YOUR
BILL IS IMPORTANT.
AND I THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS
THAT THEY RIGHT.
THE DAY REYES.
AND I BELIEVE WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT BILL OKAY THANK YOU.
GREAT NUMBER A LAP.
I WILD WHILE MY GUESTS ARE
COMING UP HERE I WILL BEGIN I
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
TODAY -- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING US TO
BE HERE TODAY -- I'M DOING A
HANDFUL OF BILLS ADDRESSING
HUNGER.
AND IT'S EMBARRASSING TO ME THAT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE NOT FUNDAMENTALLY
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE IF PEOPLE
ARE GOING HUNGRY EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN OUR STATE -- AND I'VE YOU
US IS HAVING A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO LEAD THE NATION SHORING THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO FOOD -- IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WHAT I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT SPECIFICALLY TODAY
IS -- AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE THE
AND FOSTER USE.
IT'S THE END OF FOSTER YOUTH
STUDENT HUNGER.
ACT A MAJORITY FOSTER USE --
INSPIRED HIGHER EDUCATION.
HOWEVER ONLY 324% OF FOSTER
YOUTH EARNED A BACHELOR DEGREE.
AND LESS THAN 1% WILL TEN A
MASTER'S OR DOCTORATE DEGREE.
ISSUES OF HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS ARE PREVALENT ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND MANY
STUDENTS STRUGGLE WITH THE
RISING COST OF BASIC NEEDS AND
LIVING.
A SIGNIFICANT FACTORED LEADS TO
LOWER HIGHER EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
IS THE LACK OF FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND OTHER SUPPORT FOR
MORE THAT MORE TRADITIONAL
STUDENTS RECEIVE.
MANY FOSTER YOUTH DEPEND ON
FINANCIAL SYSTEMS AND OFFICIAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS CALPERS WOULD
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTEREST AND BENEFITS THAT
SUPPORT THEIR HEALTH WELL BEING.
AND SCHOOL AND WORK READINESS
FOR FOSTER YOU STUDENTS CAL
FRESH ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED FOR BASIC
LIVING WHILE THEY WORK TOWARDS A
DEGREE.
A COLLEGE EDUCATION IS NECESSARY
FOR FOSTER YOUTH TO GET OUT OF
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY AND BE
SUCCESSFUL IN TODAY'S ECONOMY.
THEREFORE WE SHOULD TAKE STEPS
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CAL FRESH
FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO FOCUS ON
THEIR STUDIES AND BE SUCCESSFUL
STUDENTS.
MY BILL WILL ENSURE THAT FOSTER
YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO BE.
A TO BE FOOD SECURITY PURSUE
WORK OPPORTUNITIES AND HIGHER
EDUCATIONS BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING THINGS ONE PROVIDE
PROGRAMS.
UP PROVIDING PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE TEN MEALS PER WEEK FOR
FOSTER YOU STUDENTS TO TO
PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS
IN THE FORM OF CALIBRATION.
I THREE EXPANDING THE TYPE OF
WORK HOURS AN ALLOWABLE -- AT
WORK HOURS ALLOWABLE FOR FOSTER
YOU STUDENTS TO QUALIFY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AS ME WILL AS WE MOVE FOR WE
PLAN TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
IN KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
THE ADMINISTRATION AND IMPLEMENT
AN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL.
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS
THE WESTERN CENTER.
ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND JOURNEY HOUSE AND INTRODUCE
OUR WITNESSES JESSE AGUILAR AND
JESSICA BARTHOLIN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND REMIND THE
WITNESSES THAT THERE ARE. TWO
MINUTES A PIECE.
SURE THANK YOU -- AND GOOD
AFTERNOON OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSE
AGUILAR AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF JOURNEY HOUSE -- AND AS THE
CO SPONSORS OF AB TALK.
TWENTY NINE WE HAVE WORKED WITH
WATCHES OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
YES DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS.
WE SPENT MUCH OF OUR TIME HOPING
OUR MEMBERS CREE ACTION PLANS --
TO MEET THEIR EDUCATIONAL
HOUSING.
EMPLOYMENT AND HEALTH NEEDS.
OUR STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO MAKE VERY DIFFICULT
LIKE DECISIONS AND THEY'RE IN
DETERMINING THEIR PRIORITIES.
TOO OFTEN THEY HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO STAY IN SCHOOL OR
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS --
CONTINUE TO PAY FOR CHILDCARE.
OR TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE --
BUT THAT IS WHY WE'RE HERE TO
THE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE TWENTY NINE THIS BILL
SEEKS ACCOMPLISHED -- TO REALLY
PRIMARILY A OBJECTIVES. ONE IS
TO EXPAND THE TYPE OF WORK HOURS
PERMISSIBLE TO QUALIFY FOR
COVERAGE ELIGIBILITY.
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING NON PAID
INTERNSHIPS TO QUALIFY FOR THE
TWENTY HOUR WORK REQUIREMENT OF
COVERAGE.
THIS PROVIDES STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD THE WORK
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD THAT
ALIGNS WITH THEIR ACADEMIC.
AND CAREER GOALS INCREASING THE
CHANCES THAT SELF SUFFICIENCY.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO PROVIDE
FOOD RESOURCES FOR YOUTH
CURRENTLY RECEIVING A HOUSE HOW
THESE TYPE INTO EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE ALSO KNOWN AS THE TWELFTH.
CURRENTLY FARSI THE RECEIVING TO
BE TOP HOUSING SUPPORT ARE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE BECAUSE
THE HOUSING SEVEN IS COUNTED AS
INCOME WHICH PUTS THE WHICH PUT
THEM OVER THE INCOME LIMIT FOR
CONFERENCE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO UTILIZE
CURRENT A. B. TWELVE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE THAT WOULD
BE ALLOCATED SPECIFICALLY FOR
FOX USED TO COVER THEIR FOOD.
FOR FORMER FARSI YOU SUPPORTED
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ARE
CRUCIAL PURSUING THEIR ACADEMIC
AND CAREER GOALS.
IT IS THE ONLY SUPPORT THAT THEY
CAN RELY ON SINCE THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE LUXURY OF A FAMILY
FOUNDATION.
BY MAKING THESE CRUCIAL
INVESTMENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE ITS
COMMITMENT AS A LEADER IN SOCIAL
WORK TO THE LIVES OF FOSTER
YOUTH.
IT IS FOR THIS THESE REASONS
THAT WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON A.
B..
TWELVE TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST GO BACK OVER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SPONSOR IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA'S MADE.
GREAT STRIDES IN THE WAY OF
REDUCING COLLEGE SHOULD HUNGER.
UP FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'VE
DOCUMENTED THE PROBLEM OUR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE UC SYSTEM TO
THE CSU SYSTEM TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
HAVE ALL PUT RESOURCES IN AND
THEIR CHANCELLORS HAVE
PRIORITIZED ENDING.
COLLEGE SHOULD HUNGER.
PEOPLE IN THIS COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
PUT IN SIGNIFICANT TIME AND
ENERGY AND YEARS IN TRYING TO
REDUCE COLLEGE STUDENT HUNGER.
AND WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS WE'VE
ALSO DONE A GREAT JOB IN COMING
UP BEHIND OUR FOSTER YOU THAT
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE
TRANSITIONAL BENEFITS -- AND
THAT'S HELPING.
TO UP THE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S SOME GAPS FOR THIS VERY
VULNERABLE GROUP OF PEOPLE. FOR
WHOM WE AS A CITY CALIFORNIA.
SERVE FOR THE IN FOR BETTER FOR
WORSE AS THEIR PARENT.
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN AND AND
THE PRO THE PROBLEMS IN SERVING
CAL FRESH -- SERVING THE
STUDENTS WITH CALPERS SH
BENEFITS ARE SO VERY DIFFICULT.
CREATED BY FEDERAL STATUTE
THAT'S LIKELY NOT GOING TO
CHANGE IN THE ANY TIME SOON AND
SO WE'RE WORKING AROUND THEM --
THIS BILL IS THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND TO COME FORWARD AND SAY WE
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO ADDRESS
COLLEGE SHOULD HUNGER AMONG
FOSTER YOUTH -- THESE ARE REALLY
HARD ISSUES TO WORK ON AND WE'RE
WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE MAKING SOME
MOMENTUM WITH THIS BILL SO
GRATEFUL TO PARTNER WITH OUR CO
SPONSORS AND AND TO THE AUTHOR.
AND WE WE OR DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. ONE REPRESENTS
AMERICAN CANYON PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING EXPERIMENT
WHEN LARGEST PROVIDERS OF FOSTER
CARE SERVICES WITH THAT WORKING
WITH NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
FOSTER YOUTH AND PLACES WHERE
THE REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
SHANTI HAS BEEN WITH THE ALLIES
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS THE MCGUIRE FOSTER MOTHER
AND WESTERN REGION DIRECTOR OF
YOUNG INVINCIBLES I'M I'M THE
PARENT OF A COLLEGE BROWN FOSTER
CHILD A IN IB AND AP CLASSES AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH CURRENTLY AT
USC I AM ONE OF THAT 13%.
AND A ONE PERCENTER IN MY
MASTERS PROGRAM.
I'M ALSO A CAL GRANT I MEAN A
CAL FRESHER SERBIAN.
I'M CURRENTLY STRUGGLING WITH
THAT AS A COLLEGE STUDENT THAT.
I DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE SERVICE
DURING THE SUMMERTIME WHEN I
NEED IT THE MOST AND MY UNPAID
INTERNSHIP AT A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER MARQUEES TERRACE DAWSON
OFFICE IS NOT.
QUALIFIED AS WORK -- IN THIS
SITUATION AND I THINK THAT WE
ALL KNOW THAT THAT WORK DOES
QUALIFY SO.
I SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEENER NOT SEEN ANY.
MS WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD LET THE STORIES OF
OTHERS AND THE ADVOCATES SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES HERE -- AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD --
HAVING WORKED WITH -- FOSTER
YOUTH -- MYSELF HAVING.
ONE IN MY OFFICE AS A INTERN.
OF FOR THE SUMMER HI VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
BRING IT TO A VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NEXT ITEM.
TO AB FIVE FORTY MISLI MORE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF I CALIFORNIA HAS
A LONG HISTORY OF EMBRACING ALL
STUDENTS LIVING IN THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF THE RESIDENTS HERE
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNDER THE CURRENT AB FIVE FORTY
LAS CERTAIN NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS ARE EXEMPT FROM PAYING
NON RESIDENT TUITION AND MAY
QUALIFY FOR STATE AID AND
INSTITUTIONAL INSTITUTIONAL AID
IF AVAILABLE.
THIS YEAR'S VERSION OF AB FIVE
FOR ITS FORTY FURTHERS
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO SUPPORT
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR RESIDENCY OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
AB FIVE FORTY WILL ESTABLISH THE
CAL GRANT BE SERVICE INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM AND TO THE
CALIFORNIA SOON EIGHT COMMISSION.
THIS SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT WILL
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE AND GAIN
EXPERIENCE AND THEIR SELECTED
CAREER PATH.
THROUGH VOLUNTEERING AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE CHRISTY AT SANCHES HERE
REPRESENTING CHIEF BLACK TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
CHRIS RESPONSES MATURE Là THE
COLLEGE OF REMAINING AGAIN
RIGHTS AND ARE.
YOU THOUGHT ARM THE CALIFORNIA
JR NETWORK PRADA SPONSOR THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION
UNFORTUNATELY OUR DOCTOR ANSWERS
HOW TO GET ON THE BUS AND I DO
WANT TO SAY MISTER CHAIR ONE OF
OUR STUDENT TESTIMONY WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT WHO IS ADMITTED
TO UC ARE.
WANTED TO TESTIFY YOU SAW BEHALF
OF RYAN HERE DOES YOUR AYE VOTE --
WE KNOW THAT ALL THE STUDIES
POINT TO THE ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS OUT FOR AN
AND DOCUMENTS SUIT TO OBTAIN THE
EDUCATION.
IS FINANCING THE EDUCATION WE
BELIEVE HAVING AN ADDITIONAL CAL
GRANT WILL BE ABLE TO LESSEN THE
BURDEN ESPECIALLY NOW THAT.
THE DOC A PROGRAM HAS BEEN
RECENT IT AND A LOT OF STUDENTS
WILL NEED TO HAVE -- ALTERNATIVE
WAYS AND MEANS TO FINANCE
EDUCATION THEREFORE WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES YES MY NAME IS
BRANDON BIGGER AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
WE WORK ON THIS BILL IN ITS
PREVIOUS ITERATION FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS NOW AND FILLING THIS.
UNMET NEED FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL PROGRAMS
LIKE WORK STUDY IS A PRIORITY
FOR THE COMMISSION AND I'M HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
AND WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER I YOU ARE
BEHALF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND PROUD SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR ARE SEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION WHICH WE
HELP FACILITATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
PRIME MACLAINE YOU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
YEAH A GUY GOES WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SEEMS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GENTLY JACKSON AS A STUDENT
COMING FROM UNIVERSITY WITH FIVE
HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED DOCTORS
OPINIONS WE SUPPORT OUR I
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CRAZY
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
JERRY FOR SIDE BAND OF ORDERS IN
SUPPORT.
ROSA DEANDRE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION AT THIS POINT BUT WE'VE
RECOMMENDED.
A STRONG SUPPORT TO OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS -- FOR THE MAY MEETING
THANK YOU.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS.
SEEING NONE -- MISLI MON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS IS BEEN A THREE YEAR EFFORT
AND WE'RE BACK AT IT AGAIN AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD AGAIN I SUPPORTED A
SIMILAR MEASURE LAST TIME.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING AGAIN
THIS TIME THANK YOU -- WITH THE
UNCERTAINTY OF DOC AND THE
ADDITIONAL FINANCES FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THAT ARE DREAMERS
FACE I BELIEVE WE SHOULD DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE THE
NECESSARY FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
SO THEY CAN PERSIST AND GRADUATE
WITH BACCALAUREATE DEGREES I'M
JUST SORRY I MISSED THE INCOMING
UCR'S DOING -- ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL CALL FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE'VE MOVED TO ITEM
NINETEEN MISTER HOLD
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE A BILL
THAT GIVES COLLEGE ATHLETES EVEN
MORE TOOLS.
AND PROTECTION TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES OR ABUSES THEY MAY
FACE ON CAMPUS.
WE CONSTANTLY SEE EXAMPLES OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND ATHLETES
DEALING WITH ABUSE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM IN A NEW WAY BY
EDUCATING AND EQUIPPING OUR
COLLEGE ATHLETES TO BE EVEN
BETTER ADVOCATES FOR THEMSELVES
AND PROTECTING THEM.
AS THEY DO IT.
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO INFORM
STUDENTS OF THEIR RIGHTS WITH
THE DOCUMENTATION AND PUBLIC
SIGNAGE.
IT ALSO PROTECTS STUDENTS BY
PROHIBITING RETALIATION BY
SCHOOLS OF A STUDENT REPORTS
VIOLATIONS OF ABUSE OR VIOLATION
OF RIGHT.
IT ALSO ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO CREATE
A DEGREE COMPLETION FUNDING
WHICH IS A MECHANISM SCHOOLS CAN
CHOOSE TO CREATE.
AND SHOES HOW IT WILL BE USED.
THESE COLLEGES THESE COLLEGE
ATHLETES ARE PUTTING EVERYTHING
ON THE LINE AND RISKING THEIR
BODIES.
AND FOR SOME ONE INJURY AWAY
FROM LOSING EVERYTHING.
OTHERS ARE AT RISK OF LOSING IT
ALL BY SPEAKING OUT FOR THEIR
TEAM OR ANY ABUSE THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING AS COLLEGE COACHES
HAVE THE POWER TO KEEP YOU ON OR
OFF THE TEAM.
I APPLAUD ALL SCHOOLS THAT ARE
DOING.
THE GOOD WORK OF PROTECTING
COLLEGE ATHLETES HEALTH.
ACADEMIC PROGRESS IN ECONOMIC
FUTURE.
HOWEVER NOT EVERY SCHOOL IS
DOING SO.
AND WITH THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EUROPE OF ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION AND
EIGHT WINNERS.
SEEING NONE SAY NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- MR HOLDEN UTE YOU
AGREE TO THE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FOUR YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I WAS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN LAST
YEAR HAPPY TO SUPPORT A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVEN THE THREE THIS
YEAR.
STUDENT ATHLETES CERTAINLY
DESERVE THE PROTECTIONS THAT
YOUR BILL PROVIDES -- ONCE WE
HAVE -- CHOIR WILL CALL IT TO A
VOTE APPRECIATE THAT RESPECT FOR
LAST FOREVER.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANYBODY.
THE GROUP WILL GO -- TO ITEM SIX
A. B. SEVEN OH THREE DOCTOR
WEBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOUR PAYS OFF OKAY.
LOOKS LIKE YOU WOULD TESTIFY BUT
OF GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB.
SEVEN OH THREE WHICH WOULD WAIVE
TUITION AND CERTAIN FEES FOR ANY
EXONERATE WHO ATTENDS A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
OF CAL STATE UNIVERSITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA PRIOR TO
TEN YEARS AFTER RELEASE -- AND
EXONERATED SOMEONE WHO HAS WHO
WAS INCARCERATED THAT IS LATER
FOUND BY A COURT ORDER IF THEY
WILL BE THIS CHARGE FROM
LIABILITY.
IN CRIMINAL CASES -- CONTACTS
THE TERM EXONERATE MEANS REFERS
TO A STATE OF WHERE A PERSON
CONVICTED OF A CRIME IS LATER
FOUND TO BE INNOCENT.
IT'S NOT A REASON MAY BE
RELEASED BUT LEFT SCARRED FROM
THE TREATMENT FROM THE MEMORIES
OF TRAUMA FROM THEIR BEING IN
PRISON FOR A CRIME.
THEY DID NOT COMMIT THIS
INCLUDES THE LOSS OF USE OF OUR
DECADES OF THEIR LIFE THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN SPENT PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION JOB EXPERIENCE AND
TRAINING.
THE MAJORITY OF EXONERATES 57%
DO NOT REACH THE INCOME LEVEL
THAT THEY ARE IN BEFORE BEING A
CAR SERRATED.
THIS RESULTS IN OVER ONE THIRD
OF EXONERATES BEING FINANCIALLY
DEPENDENT ON OTHERS ACCORDING TO
THE COLLEGE BOARD HIGHER
EDUCATION CORRESPONDS TO LOWER
LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT POVERTY
AND INCARCERATION.
THIS BILL WOULD TO WAIVE TUITION
AND CERTAIN FEES THAT ARE
REQUIRED AT ANY CAL STATE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY OR UNIVERSE
OF CALIFORNIA PRIOR TO TEN YEARS
UPON RELEASE.
OF THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
EXONERATED NATION IN CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
A HERE TO SPEAK I'M NOT SURE IF
IT MAKES YOU'LL STILL HEAR.
PEOPLE BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE
ROOM YOU MAY NOT BE HERE WHO'S A
WHO'S SUPPOSED TO SPEAK
CONCERNING THIS BILL BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND THE OTHER WILL.
THE ON TO THE JACKSON IS A
STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE WHO
WORKS WITH OUR OF FELONY
POPULATION I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
SEEING NONE WELL I THINK YOU'RE
A WITNESS IN.
SUPPORT IS HERE.
OKAY BUT WE LOVE THE BILL ANYWAY
I KNOW I KNOW.
IT'S UP TO YOU KNOW LOOK.
AT THE GYM AT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS IGNITES YOUR HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF EXONERATED NATION
CO SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE --
WHICH IS ORGANIZATION -- CREATED
BY EXONERATES -- AND ALSO ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WHICH WAS ALSO
A CO SPONSOR OF THE THE MEASURE
AT THE STATE WHAT SUBSTATION
PREVENTS ATTORNEYS.
THE ONLY THING I'LL MENTION IS
THAT OVER THE LAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
EXONERATE SOME OF WHOM WERE
TRYING TO BE HERE TODAY COULD
MAKE IT.
UP TO IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE --
WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED FROM FROM
PRISON WHAT WE REALIZED A FEW
YEARS AGO IS THAT IF SOMEBODY'S
ON PAROLE THEY RECIEVE -- FULL
SPECTRUM OF SERVICES.
UNDER THE PAYROLL DEPARTMENT --
AND UNFORTUNATELY EXONERATES AT
THAT TIME RECEIVED NONE OF THOSE
SERVICES SO.
I WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A OF
A PROBLEM WITH THE LAW.
IN SO OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
WE'VE TRIED TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL IMMEDIATE SERVICES.
A TWO EXONERATES ON THIS PAST
YEAR IT'S OUR NATION CONVENE.
A MEETING OF EXONERATES FROM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY TO TALK ABOUT
THE POLICIES IN THE NEEDS.
OF EXONERATES AND WHAT WE COULD
DO IN CALIFORNIA.
ON TO LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES
FROM OTHER STATES -- ONE OF
WHICH WAS THE CHALLENGE OF FOR
THOSE FOUR HANDFUL OF A GENEROUS
TO DO PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION
ONCE THEY'RE RELEASED -- IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE IN
TEXAS HAS BEEN ADOPTED A COUPLE
OF OTHER STATES -- TO PROVIDE
SOME OTHER ADDITIONAL -- SERVICE
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY MEDIA
UPON RELEASE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
SOMEWHERE DOWN THE LINE.
ON THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF EGGS
HONOREES TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TAKE
ADVANTAGE AND GET INTO HIGHER
EDUCATION -- THE MAJORITY OF
THESE HONOREES WE DEAL WITH
ANYWHERE FROM NINE TO OVER
TWENTY YEARS IN STATE PRISON --
AND SO THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND BUT THEY'LL SO OFTEN
TIMES THEY CATCH UP ON MY DID
HAVE CONVERSATIONS HONORING LA.
WHO WENT ON TO HIGHER EDUCATION
AFTER ABOUT?
AFTER ABOUT SEVEN YEARS OF BEING
OUT -- WE JUST HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH ANOTHER ONE
WHO'S IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE TODAY
ON HAS A NEED BASED SCHOLARSHIP
BUT HAS THE PROBLEM HE WAS ONE
SIX WAS TESTIFIED THE PROBLEM
THAT HE CANNOT WORK.
IF YOU WANT TO MAINTAIN THAT
SPECIAL SCHOLARSHIP THAT HE HAS
BUT HE HAS TO WORK.
THE PACE WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
THE END OF THE DAY.
THESE EXONERATES HAVE.
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
HAVE ENDED UP IN PRISON FOR
YEARS AT A TIME BECAUSE OF OUR
SYSTEM SO THIS IS JUST A WAY TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM DOWN THE
ROAD. FOR THOSE REASONS OUT FOR
SUPPORT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I I
WANT TO THANK MY EXPERT WITNESS
FOR COMING AND OUT BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE I THINK THAT
THREE OF THREE HAVE WE HAVE
THREE BILLS THAT ARE DEALING
WITH THE ISSUE OF EXONERATES.
AND THIS ONE IS A EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THE OTHER ONE DEALS
WITH HOUSING ONE DEALS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THIS ONE DEALS WITH
EDUCATION IT'S A TRAGIC IT'S A
SMALL POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS
ACTUALLY BUT IT'S BUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
UNFAIRLY. FOR TEN TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE DISRUPTED THEIR
LIVES OFTENTIMES THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE GONE SOMEWHERE ELSE THE
WIVES OF ESPOUSES HAVE DIVORCED
THEM WHATEVER IT IS WAS SO THEY
COME OUT WITH NOTHING.
OFTENTIMES WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
OF FAMILIES AND WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN FIND FOLKS
THEY ONCE WORKED FOR A WHATEVER.
AND SO WE THEN IT NEED TO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DON'T GO BACK IN THE
THEY'LL GO BACK INTO PRISON A
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES -- AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
THIS IS THE LEAST WE CAN DO I
THINK TO SAY TO THEM THAT WE WE
WERE WRONG BECAUSE WE WANT TO
HELP YOU REBUILD YOUR LIFE.
AND GOING TO SCHOOL IS ONE OF
THOSE AS WELL AS THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WOULD DEAL
WITH AS WELL AS HOUSING SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE I. BUT WE
GET A QUORUM.
THEY COULD BE USED TO EXONERATE.
AT LEAST TO EXONERATE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- AWHILE BACK ONE OF
WHO IS I REMEMBER CORRECTLY EVEN
RAN FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
OF WHAT THE OTHER WAS -- AT
LOYOLA MARYMOUNT DOING VERY WELL --
BUT SO I THINK THE AUTHOR -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD A
IT'S IT'S I THINK NEEDED AND I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NOW WE WILL GO TO ITEM EIGHT A.
B..
NINE SIX THREE THERE'S BETWEEN
NORSE.
WELCOME.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
THREE THE STUDENT CIVIC AND
VOTER EMPOWERMENT ACT.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
DESIGNATE A CIVIC AND VOTER
EMPOWERMENT COORDINATOR ON EACH
CAMPUS.
THE BE TASKED WITH DEVELOPING AN
ACTION PLAN IN ORDER TO INCREASE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND DEMOCRATIC
PARTICIPATION.
AVAILABLE DATA SHOWS THAT WHEN
COLLEGE CAMPUSES DEPORT DIVERT
RESOURCES INTO ABOUT DEVELOPING
AN ACTION PLAN.
THE RESULT IN STRONG VOTER
TURNOUT ONE EXAMPLE IS UCLA UCLA
VOLUNTARILY TAKES PART IN THE
ALL IN.
CAMPUS DEMOCRACY CHALLENGE WHICH
THIS BILL IS PARTLY MODELED ON
AFTER PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM UCLA REPORTED A FIVE
HUNDRED AND 37% INCREASE.
IN IN PERSON STUDENT VOTER
TURNOUT DURING THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MID TERM ELECTION WHEN
COMPARED.
TO TWENTY FOURTEEN THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED THREE POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS THROUGHOUT OUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE INSTITUTIONS CAN AND
REALLY SHOULD PLAY A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN ENCOURAGING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND INVOLVING YOUNG
PEOPLE.
IN OUR DEMOCRACY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENTS SAID THEY CAN VOTER
EMPOWERMENT ACT AND I AM PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE.
COUPLE SUPPORTERS HERE TO
TESTIFY.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING US.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR PATTY ROBINSON
I'M FACULTY IRECTOR OF OUR
CIVIC A COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT UP
PROGRAM AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS.
I AM HERE TO SUPPORT.
AB NINE SIX THREE I WANT TO
BEGIN BY SAYING WE FACE A
GROWING CHALLENGE IN THIS
COUNTRY BY GETTING YOUNG PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRACY ESPECIALLY VOTING.
SOME SUGGEST THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A CIVIC RECESSION.
HIGHER EDUCATION MUST PLAY A
ROLE IN CREATING CIVIC MINDED
CAMPUS CULTURES THAT ORGANIZE
FACILITATE AN IMPLEMENT CIVIC
AND POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR NOT JUST
BEFORE AN ELECTION.
I REPRESENT THE VOICE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT ARE ALSO
KNOWN AS DEMOCRACIES COLLEGES.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN CAMPUSES.
WE SERVE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
ARE FIRST GENERATION AND ARE
AFFECTED BY ECONOMIC CHALLENGES.
AS A RESULT MANY STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE THE CIVIC OPPORTUNITY
GAP THEY DO NOT KNOW HOW TO USE
OR NAVIGATE THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
AND ITS PROCESS SEES.
THIS ONLY INTENSIFIES THEIR
MARGINALIZATION AND KEEPS TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF OUR STUDENTS
FROM FULLY UNDERSTANDING OR
PARTICIPATING IN AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH MILLENNIALS
AND CHEN Z. GOING TO WRECK
COMPRISES THE LARGEST VOTING
BLOC OR AT LEAST HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE THE LARGEST
VOTING BLOC.
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES TEND APPROACH
CIVIC AND POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT
AS ONE AND DONE.
CIVIC AND POLITICAL INVOLVEMENT
IS TYPICALLY STRESS SIX TO EIGHT
WEEKS BEFORE AN ELECTION.
AND GREATER EMPHASIS IS PLACED
ON VOTER REGISTRATION NOT VOTER
EDUCATION A PARTICIPATION.
OVERALL CAMPUS INVOLVEMENT IS
INCONSISTENT AND IT DEPENDS ON
WHO MOVES THE PROCESS FORWARD.
ALTHOUGH A LARGE LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
REGISTERING THEY ARE NOT VOTING.
WHY THEY CAN'T CONNECT TO ISSUES
ARE CANDIDATES THEY DON'T SEE
THE RELEVANCY OF POLITICAL
ENGAGEMENT IN THEIR OWN LIVES
AND THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO VOTE?
AB NINE SIX THREE WILL CREATE
CAMPUS WILL CREATE A CAMPUS
COMMITMENT TO POLITICAL
ENGAGEMENT AND INCREASE VOTER
EDUCATION.
LAST FALL THIS EXISTED ARE WE
HAD A HAD AN EXIT -- X. EXCUSE
ME HAD A DEDICATED EFFORT A
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS TO
INCREASE POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT
AMONG THE ENTIRE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY.
MUCH WAS A RICK MUCH CAME OUT OF
THIS DEDICATED -- EFFORT
ESPECIALLY GETTING INVOLVED WITH
AND SOLVE IN LOOKING AT THE DATA
OF OUR OWN VOTING STUDENTS FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE WERE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A BASELINE NUMBER FROM
WHICH TO IMPROVE POLITICAL
ENGAGEMENT.
WE FOUND THAT IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ELECTION --
ONLY TWELVE POINT 6% OF OUR
STUDENTS ACTUALLY VOTED.
WE ARE NOW WAITING FOR A NIGHT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OUR DATA.
THIS YEAR WE CREATED A VOTER
ACTION PLAN TO HELP GUIDE THE
OVERSEAS RAPPER.
YES OUR VOTER ACTION PLAN WE
ALSO WORK WITH THE LA REGISTERS
OFFICE TO HAVE A BOTH A BALLOT
BOX PLACED ON OUR CAMPUS AND WE
ALSO -- HAVE AND SOCIAL ACTION
TEAM NOW WORKING -- TO GO
TOWARDS THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION -- I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT IS
VERY MUCH SUPPORTED BY THIS BILL
AND I HOPE THAT -- YOU WILL
ACTUALLY SUPPORT IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN TO JACKSON
AND I'M A THIRD YEAR AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO -- MAJORING IN PSYCHOLOGY
AND DOUBLE MINOR IN CRIMINOLOGY
AND POLITICAL SCIENCE I'M ALSO
THE SECRETARY MEMBERSHIP CHAIR
FOR THE PRESIDENCY CHAPTER OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF COLORED PEOPLE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE IN W. C. P..
AS WELL AS THE NATIONAL CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT TRAINER FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
I AM HERE REPRESENTING AS A
STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE AS WELL
AS OUR ASSOCIATED STUDENTS
INCORPORATED ALSO KNOWN AS OUR
STUDENT BODY GOVERNMENT.
AND I AS A STUDENT AND A MEMBER
OF THE OF MY CAMPUS AND DOUBLE
ACP WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR END
OF LACI P. STATE PRESIDENT ALICE
HOFFMAN STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY NINE SIX THREE AS A
STUDENT I CAMPUS AS WELL AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR ALL YOUNG
VOICES IN HIGHER EDUCATION I'M
HERE TO SAY THAT MY GENERATION
HAS NOT PROPERLY BEEN PREPARED
TO COMPETENTLY AND CONCISELY.
NAVIGATE OUR NATION CIVIC
PROCESS.
STUDENTS GO BY ON EDUCATED AND
AWARE OF THE POWER OF THE VOICE
THE VOTING AND THE IMPORTANCE
INTANGIBILITY OF THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WITH IN OUR SOCIO
POLITICAL SYSTEMS.
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ONE OF TWENTY
NATIONAL CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
TRAINERS FOR THE END OF LACI P..
SPECIFICALLY MY EXPERIENCES IN
THIS ROLE HAS TAUGHT ME THAT
STUDENTS AT FRESNO STATE ARE
HUNGRY FOR CHANGE STUDENTS
WITHIN THE CSU SYSTEM ARE
THIRSTY FOR CIVIC SUPPORT AND
EDUCATION.
STUDENTS PERCENT HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND OUR NATION ARE ACHING FOR
GUIDANCE AND A MORE UNIFORM
SYSTEM BUT ARE UNAWARE OF HOW TO
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.
THE STATUS QUO FOR ACADEMIA HAS
SHALL WE TAUGHT STUDENTS ABOUT
HOW OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM WORKS
BUT NOT ABOUT THE CIVIC WE
ENGAGE VOTERS AND GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZERS WHO MAKE THE SYSTEMS
WORK.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST STUDENT VOTER TURNOUT
AS OF TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN MID
TERM ELECTIONS WHICH IS
UPSETTING AS MILLENNIALS ARE SET
TO BECOME THE LARGEST VOTING
BLOC.
IN AMERICA MEANING THAT STUDENTS
VOICE.
IN THE ELECTORAL PROCESS CAN
TRULY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
STATE AND IN OUR COUNTRY.
THIS BILL MANDATES THAT THOSE
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENSURE THAT THERE'S
A DESIGNATED NONPARTISAN
POSITION WITH A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PREPARE US FOR FURTHER --
REPAIRS FURTHER FOR CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND VOTING BY
EMPOWERING US TO EDUCATION AND
RESOURCES THAT ALLOW STUDENTS TO
ACTIVELY BE A PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
BY DESIGNATING FUNDS WERE
PROGRAM THAT IS CATER TO FURTHER
IN THE CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS COUNTRY'S
NEXT LEADERS.
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER
PREPARE THEMSELVES TO TAKE ON
THE ROLES AND THEIR FUTURE
CAREERS.
IT IS ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE MY GENERATION FLOODS THE
JOB MARKET POLITICAL ARENAS AND
OTHER SECTORS OF SOCIETY THAT
WILL REQUIRE A TYPICALLY
EDUCATED MIND AND TENDENCY TO
VOTE.
AND IN KNOWING THAT IT WOULD BE
BE IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BEHOOVE
OF THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED TO BUILD UPON
THIS COUNTRY'S LIKE SEE FOR THE
BETTER.
AS A COLLEGE STUDENT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE END OF THE C. P.
AS WELL AS FRESNO STATE STUDENT
BODY GOVERNMENT WHO COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY UNFORTUNATELY BUT
DEFINITELY SENDS THEIR SUPPORT.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO FULLY SUPPORT
AB NINE SIX THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SO FORTH.
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
GETTING I GUESS WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SERENITY WHY THE LOWLY ALSO PART
OF FRESNO STATE'S AND DOUBLE ACP --
IN FULL SUPPORT.
SHE RETAIN PRESIDENT OF THEN
DOUBLE ACP AT FRESNO STATE AND I
SUPPORT.
THE SHAMAN THE LONG ON BE HAVE A
SECRETARY STATE ALEX BUT THE AT
NO FORMAL POSITION YET BUT WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR ON WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE TO LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
KRISTA MCGUIRE WESTERN REGION
DIRECTOR YOUNG INVINCIBLES CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
AND I'M JERRY FORESIGHT SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND A BAND OF VOTERS
AND WE HAD FIVE STUDENTS FROM
MARCH FOR OUR LIVES WHO ARE ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT WHO HAD TO LEAVE
EARLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
JOINT.
MEMBER PETRIE NORREYS SAW I
UNDERSTAND -- I THINK TO YOUR IN
INTENT OF THE PLO BUT I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS.
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE.
CONSIDER TO BE ALL ADULTS.
AND IF FOR A CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
EDUCATION NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IT.
MAY BE BETTER -- DURING THE A
HIGH SCHOOL.
THE BECAUSE MOST COLLEGES TO
WOULD HAVE -- LACK OF COLLEGE
REPUBLICANS COLLEGE DEMOCRATS --
THERE ARE -- CLUB SAID THAT THE
YOU CAN GET ENGAGED.
AND THEN ALSO -- OTHER THAN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO MOST OF
THE CSU UC SYSTEM SO -- ORDERED
A TRAP THE STUDENTS -- OUT OF
TOWN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGE
MAY BE DIFFERENT THE DEPEND UPON --
THE CAMPUS -- THE RATIO OF PART
OF TOWN STUDENTS.
SOME MAY -- NEED.
TO RE REGISTER ON THE CAMPUS OF
FOR THEM.
TO REALLY GET ENGAGED IN IN.
EACH ELECTION -- SO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT.
IT IS TO EDUCATION IS GOOD
THOUGH BUT TELLING Là DOLLARS
SURVEY KNOWN THEY ARE OR IN IN.
AT THAT AT LEAST IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND NOT TWENTY IS -- MANY
OF THEM.
AND GETTING INVOLVED IN IN THE
ADULT EDUCATION AND CIVIC AND
ENGAGEMENT.
WHEN THE END OF THIS ORDER --
REQUIRE A CONDITION.
OF OF TALENT GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE END OF THE BURDEN
YOU'RE GONNA.
A POINT IN -- NINE DE ONE FACTOR
MEMBER STAFF MEMBER. TO
ADMINISTER OF HIS -- CIVIC IN
VOTER IN PALM -- SO.
EVEN THOUGH I DO SEE SOME BASIC.
IT'S UP WITH I HAVE A MORE
CONCERNS SO CAN YOU ADDRESS ON
THAT CERTAINLY I'LL TRY TO TOUCH
ON THAT THE POINTS YOU MENTIONED
SO -- AS FAR AS KIND OF WHAT IS
THE RIGHT STAGE TO GET TO AS
YOUNG PEOPLE IN STUDENTS ENGAGE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
I THINK YOU'RE YOUR IDEAS OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE IS
GREAT -- IN IF IF WE CAN START
TALKING TO PEOPLE ABOUT BEING
ACTIVE CITIZENS AND WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE A VOTER WHEN THEY'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL THAT'S TERRIFIC.
I THINK I'M.
MOST STUDENTS TURNING EITHER
TURN EIGHTEEN RIGHT BEFORE THEY
GO TO COLLEGE OR WHILE THEY'RE
IN COLLEGE.
SERVER FOR MOST STUDENTS THEY'RE
IN COLLEGE THE VERY FIRST TIME
THAT THEY VOTE.
AND I THINK THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
FOR OUR PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY IT AT THE COLLEGE AGE
AND AND YOUNG ADULTS.
IS THAT WE WE HAVE VERY LOW
LEVELS AS VOTER PARTICIPATION
VERY LOW LOW LEVELS OF
PARTICIPATION IN OUR IN OUR
CIVIC LIFE AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US. TO
THINK ABOUT EDUCATION NOT JUST
AS SOMETHING THAT THAT ENDS
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF A
CLASSROOM BUT EXPANDING BEYOND
THE BOUNDARIES.
AND INCLUDING YOU KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE A CITIZEN WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE PART OF OF OUR
DEMOCRACY I THINK THAT WILL ONLY
MAKE.
MAKE US STRONGER -- IS IN TERMS
OF THAT CONCERN AROUND THE CAL
GRANTS.
I I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
SO AT THERE WAS YES THERE WAS AN
AMENDMENT TAKEN SO THAT THAT
CONCERN HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED.
SO.
YOU MENTIONED THE AMENDMENT
TAKEN SO I JUST WANT TO VERIFY
THAT YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
YES WE ENGAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS YES THANK YOU AND AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE ANALYSIS AND
TAX AND FOR A FREE NOT.
YES WE CERTAINLY ACCEPT THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
BOB I WOULD SIMPLY SAY AS I
MENTIONED CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
ACTIVE PARTICIPATION OUR CORE
ELEMENTS TO HEALTHY DEMOCRACY IN
THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO. TO GET
YOUNG PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE ENGAGE THE THE STRONGER
THAT THAT OUR DEMOCRACY WILL BE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORD AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE COMMENTS --
IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGES TWO AND
THREE AS WELL AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
CERTAINLY THANK YOU CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL WILL BRING IT TO
VOTE.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA CALL
FORWARD ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB -- SEVEN MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY I
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK.
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S CRITICAL TO
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT HAS ACCESS
TO FUNDING FOR COLLEGE AND COST
SHOULD NEVER BE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION WHEN CHOOSING A
COLLEGE TO ATTEND.
THAT IS WHY I AM VERY EXCITED TO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
ACT THIS BILL WILL BRING
STABILITY TO THE CAL GRANT AWARD
BY IMPLEMENTING A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR WORDS FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES.
UNLIKE THE AWARDS FOR UC AND CSU
THAT ARE ADJUSTED BASED ON
CHANGES IN TUITION THE AWARD
ALLOCATION FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES WAS SET TO A STATIC
AMOUNT IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND UPON SUCCESS OF AB.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CAL GRANT
AWARDS FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES WILL INCREASE AND A
JUST WITH FUTURE INCREASES THAT
ALLOCATION.
FOR THE CSU.
CAL GRANT AWARDS PROVIDE
CRITICAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS.
AND OFTEN ARE AND CAN OFTEN BE
THE FINAL DETERMINATION ON
SCHOOL ACCESS.
NOT ONLY DOES THE CAL GRANT
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE IT SERVES A SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF UNDERSERVED SERVE
STUDENTS IN FACT 48% OF THE CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS ARE NOT THE
EMAIL WHICH IS WHYTHE BILL IS A
TWENTY NINETEEN LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW THE RECENT
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS CANDLES HAVE
BROUGHT ADDED SCRUTINY TO A LOT
OF THESE UNIVERSITIES.
THIS MAKES MY BILL THAT MUCH
MORE IMPORTANT CAL GRANTS GO TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT CAN
LEAST AFFORD COLLEGE.
THESE ARE THE STUDENTS WHO LOST
OUT ON ADMISSION SPOTS BECAUSE
OF THE SCANDAL.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT WE INCREASE ACCESS TO
COLLEGE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SO THAT STUDENTS
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES DO NOT
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAN AFFORD COLLEGE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE TIME TO
PRESENT WITH ME TODAY IS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS TO TESTIFY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSICA
CAM I AM A RECENT GRADUATE FROM
POINT LOMA NAZARENE UNIVERSITY.
I AM A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT AN IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO
AND THE SEX TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR.
BECAUSE OF THE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION IN THE HANDS OF A
TRAFFICKER I WAS ONLY ABLE TO
COMPLETE A THIRD GRADE EDUCATION
FROM THE AGES OF TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN I WAS SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED IN SAN DIEGO.
AND ACROSS THE BORDER IN THE
CITY OF TIJUANA THE RED LIGHT
DISTRICT LIKE WHAT WE Là.
IT'S A SQUARE MILE AREA OF
LEGALIZED PROSTITUTION WHICH TO
THIS DAY STILL OPERATES TWENTY
FOUR HOURS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
I HAVE SURVIVED OVERCOME THRIVED%
IN CHAMPION TO MY WAY BACK FROM
WHAT CONTINUES TO DESTROYING
KILL MANY SURVIVORS INTO -- SO
MANY OF US INTO NOW YOU SEEN
THAT GUT WRENCHING EXPERIENCE TO
HELP OTHER VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
GET OUT OF EXPLOITATION AND
FOLLOW THEIR OWN HOPES AND
DREAMS.
LAST DECEMBER I GRADUATED FROM
POINT LOMA NAZARENE UNIVERSITY
WITH A DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK AND
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED AT SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY. TO CONTINUE
TOWARDS MY MASTER'S DEGREE.
THIS STRAIN WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE IF NOT FOR THE BEAUTY
FOR ASHES SCHOLARSHIP A
SCHOLARSHIP FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS.
FULL RIDE COMMITMENT FROM PLN
YOU AND THE CAL GRANT.
A MAJOR PART OF THE BEAUTY FOR
ASHES SCHOLARSHIP PACKAGE AT PM
P. ALLEN YOU IS THE CAL GRANT
THIS STATE INVESTMENT IN A
SURVIVOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IS MULTIPLIED BY THE
UNIVERSITY'S COMMITMENT TO SEE
SURVIVORS LIKE ME COMPLETE THEIR
COLLEGE EDUCATION IT IS THE
INTENT OF AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
TO MAKE THE CAL GRANT AWARD FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE.
NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES LIKE P.
ALLEN YOU KNOW PREDICTABLE AND
PERMANENT.
THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES A
COMMITMENT BY THE STATE TO
ENSURE NOT ONLY STABILITY TO THE
AWARD BUT EQUITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S IN MY CASE
SPECIFICALLY ENSURING SURVIVORS
AND THE DIVERSE POPULATION THAT
I AM REPRESENTING HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO LIFT THEMSELVES
OUT.
OF THE DARKEST OF SITUATIONS AND
CREATE A FUTURE THROUGH THE
REALIZATION OF AN EDUCATION.
WE RESPECTFULLY AS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MER
SAGE THE ME UP HERE A COUPLE
TIMES.
I'M A TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
SINGLE MOTHER FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT CURRENTLY
SITTING PUBLIC POLICY THE
CONCENTRATION OF LAW AS WELL AS
SIMULTANEOUSLY OF STUDYING MY
MATH AND MY MASTER'S PROGRAM.
IN PUBLIC ADMINISTRATIONS AT THE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- FOR SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND CONTENT I PROBABLY
IDENTIFY MYSELF AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH.
INCARCERATED YOUTH AND ADULT --
HOMELESS YOUTH AND SEX
TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR.
AND LOS ANGELES -- BECAUSE OF
THE STATE SYSTEMS CARE I
EXPERIENCE SEVERAL FORMS OF
ABUSE RANGING FROM SYSTEMIC
MADELINE DREADS PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
I WAS INCARCERATED ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS -- AND I WENT TO
SIXTEEN DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS
GOING UP SO EDUCATION WAS NOT
IDEAL. FOR ME -- IT WASN'T TILL
AFTER I WAS HOMELESS ON SKID ROW
LIVING IN TENTS -- HAD A CHILD
THAT I DECIDED I WOULD BECOME A
NONTRADITIONAL COLLEGE DIDN'T RE
ENTER -- THE EDUCATION FORCE
[inaudible]
MY IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS INSTILLED WITH
FEAR DUE.
TO ME NOT BEING ABLE TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT MYSELF AND
OBTAIN THAT TYPE OF LIFESTYLE --
I WAS VERY AWARE THAT THEY CAL
GRANT PROVIDED AN EDUCATIONAL
SERVICE FOR A STIPULATION PERIOD
OF FOR FOUR YEARS THEREFORE I
TAKE TWENTY FIVE UNITS A
SEMESTER.
AND I AM PART OF THAT 3% PART OF
THAT 1% POPULATION NOT REALLY
VALUES EDUCATION -- THE CAL
GRANT.
IT'S POSSIBLE FOR ME YOU KNOW
AND AS POSSIBLE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT ADVOCATES HAVE DONE LIKE
ASSEMBLY -- RIBBON [inaudible]
AND I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
CHAIR AND THIS COUNCIL HERE TO
REALLY.
UTILIZE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROMOTE FOR OUR DIVERSE
POPULATIONS WHAT THE CAL GRANT
US IN PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES AT
USC WE REALLY FOCUS ON A NEED.
BASIS METRIC SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
ME TO NOT ONLY SUPPORT MYSELF
THROUGH TUITION BUT FOR EXTERNAL
FACTORS THAT GO WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WHICH IS HOUSING FOOD.
CHILD CARE SERVICES 20% OF OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND CALIFORNIA
ARE.
PARENTING STUDENTS SO -- I THINK
THAT THIS CAL GRANT EXPANSION
AND IN THE PRIVATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS AND REALLY -- HONING IN
ON IT AS IDEAL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS ALEX
GRAVES OF THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES OR THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL AND I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
RIVER DOG RECORD EDUCATION FOR
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LIKE HEALTH NETWORK
AND SUPPORT.
PHILIP S. CAREER WILLIAM JOSEPH
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
A TINY THIRTEEN A FROM THE
CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT AND PERSONALLY AS A
FORMER PRIVATE SCHOOL STUDENT
OFTEN SUPPORT.
HI MICHAEL LINES ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CHRISTIAN COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR OF TO THE INCREDIBLY
BRAVE WITNESSES.
JOHN MUNRO POINT LOMA NAZARENE
UNIVERSITY ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
THERE ARE SEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL AND
STRONGLY -- AGREE WITH THE NEED
TO RE STAFF WISH A FORMULA FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS -- WE
JUST HAVE ONE CONCERN THAT THE
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE
EXPECTATION INCLUDED IN LAST
YEAR STATE BUDGET THAT THESE
INSTITUTIONS HAD MET.
MORE TRANSFER STUDENTS ON THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
PATHWAY WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THOSE OF THE AUTHORS OFFICE
IN THE SPONSOR -- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING TO SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- CHOI
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARE.
RUBIO THANK YOU FOR YOU ARE
REACHING OUT TO ME -- TO INCLUDE
ME YES OF COURSE I'D BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT AND THAT THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT IDEA.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CLOSE YES --
IT'S MY HONOR TO WORK ON BEHALF
OF THE STUDENT THAT'S AS A
FORMER TEACHER FIVE NOTHING'S
MAKES ME HAPPIER THAN TO HEAR
THE SUCCESS STORIES OF ALL OF
THESE INCREDIBLE -- YOUNG LADIES
AND YOU KNOW I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU TO THE STUDENTS THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD WITH OVER 20%
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT
ATTEND THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE THIS FORMULA WILL
ALLOW HER PREDICTABILITY AND
HELP FOR TWO FAMILIES TO PLAN
FOR THE EDUCATIONAL GOAL.
OF A THEIR STUDENTS AND DO THE
SAME FOR STUDENTS SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGING A BILL FOR IT
AND ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU ALL I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU AND WITH THAT IF
I COULD CALL FORWARD MR GABER
[inaudible]
ITEMS.
FOR AB.
SIX TWENTY FOUR WELCOME MISTER
DAVID.
PKO.
MAYBE IT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT.
AB SIXTY FOUR WHICH WILL REQUIRE
SCHOOLS THAT CHOOSE TO ISSUE
STUDENT ID CARDS TO INCLUDE ON
THOSE CARS.
PHONE NUMBERS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOTLINES.
THIS LEGISLATION BUILDS ON SB
NINE SEVEN TWO WHICH WILL SOON
REQUIRE STUDENT ID CARDS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO INCLUDE THE
NUMBER FOR THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE FACING A
CHALLENGING SITUATION INVOLVING.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR SEXUAL HEALTH ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS TIMELY AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION THAT BE THAT MAY BE
A CENTRAL TO THEIR PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL WELL BEING.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A REAL AN
URGENT NEED FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION.
STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE THAT
NEARLY ONE IN FOUR YOUNG WOMEN
IN COLLEGE ARE VICTIMS OF RAPE
OR SEXUAL ASSAULT NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
EXPERIENCE INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE.
AND SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS ARE GROWING IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE HIGHEST IN
YOUNG PEOPLE AGES.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR IN SHORT
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES INCLUDING INFORMATION
SUPPORT.
COUNSELING AND TREATMENT
REGARDING SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
AB SIX TWO FOUR WOULD MAKE THIS
INFORMATION MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHOSE INTERNET USAGE MAY BE
MONITORED BY INTERVIEWS ARE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS LEE ENTRE CLARK
HARVEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU.
I AM WE HONOR HER KARBI -- HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES WE REPRESENT TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE -- SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ALSO PROVIDE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND ONE OF OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES RECEIVE STATE
FUNDING TO OPERATE THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE THAT
IS NOW REQUIRED TO BE LISTED ON
THE BACK OF STUDENT ID IS.
BUT SUICIDE IS NOT THE ONLY
CHALLENGE THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE FACING AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL MENTIONED THE
RATES OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS STAGGERING.
IN FACT TWO THIRDS OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT 35% OF THEM ARE
VICTIMS OF ASSAULT AND 90% OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE ASSAULTED DO
NOT REPORT IT.
IN ADDITION RATES OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED ILLNESSES ARE
HIGHEST AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE AGES.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR THE
IMPACT OF A SALT CAN BE LONG
LASTING AND CAN AFFECT THE
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH.
UNFORTUNATELY STUDENTS MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES THAT CAN HELP THEM
COPE WITH THESE ISSUES.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF EFFORTS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
TO GREATER -- ACCESS TO
RESOURCES THAT PROMOTE BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ONE REPRESENTS PROBLEMS FOR
PEOPLE.
AS TOOLS.
THE OTHER ONE WHERE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME TO THE TABLE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S RAYBURN AL
AND I SERVE AS THE EDUCATION
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE WOULD
DIMINISH THE EFFICACY OF THE
ONLY NUMBER NOW QUIET AND
STUDENT ID AND FATE.
STERN IDENTIFICATION CARDS FROM
GRADES SEVEN THROUGH COLLEGE.
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
SUICIDE AMONG OUR TEENS AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS AN
UNPARALLELED NATIONAL CRISIS
SUICIDE RATES AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
OF ALMOST DOUBLED IN SEVENTEEN
YEARS.
AND SUICIDE IS NOW THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH. FOR
THOSE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR ONE IN
TEN COLLEGE STUDENTS SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER ATTEMPTING SUICIDE. ONE
IN TWELVE ACTUALLY HAVE MADE A
SUICIDE PLAN.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS AND MUST
BE PROTECTED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN MOST WEAK AND
VULNERABLE.
REQUIRING ONLY THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE ON
ID'S HELPS PREVENT IMMINENT
DEATH AMONG OUR YOUTH WHO ARE AT
RISK OF KILLING THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHY THIS SINGLE NUMBER
WAS REQUIRED BY LAW ON STUDENT
ID'S WITH UNANIMOUS APPROVAL OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
WITH UNIVERSAL SUPPORT AMONG OUR
STATE'S PUBLIC AS WELL AS
PRIVATE SCHOOLS IN COLLEGE
COMMUNITIES.
THIS NUMBER GIVE STUDENTS
CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE AND OTHER
STUDENTS WHO KNOW CLASSMATES
THAT MIGHT BE DOIG SO.
A DEDICATED RESOURCE TO
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS VITAL
SUPPORTS NECESSARY TO CHERISH
THEIR LIVES.
WE SHOULD NOT DETRACT FROM THIS
RESOURCE AS AB SIX TWO FOUR
WOULD DO.
BY ADDING UP TO FIVE MORE
HOTLINES AND STILL THERE ARE
OTHERS THAT ARE CONSIDERED VERY
WORTHY.
BUT ALL CRITICAL IS HAS THE
NUMBERS WILL NOT FIT ON STUDENT
ID'S.
UNLESS THERE ARE MADE SO SMALL
THAT THEY BECOME USELESS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST YOU
VOTE NO ON A. B..
SIX TWO FOUR MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FILL BUSKER ME WILLIAM
JOSEPH UNIVERSITY WE DID
ORIGINALLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT DID CONTAIN A
PROVISION REGARDING -- OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT STOOD NINETIES
WHAT KERRY -- HOTLINE MESSAGES
THAT WOULD DIRECTLY LINKED -- TO
NOTIONS AND IDEAS THEIR
UNIVERSITY AND ITS STUDENTS
WOULD NOT SUPPORT WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHOR FOR OF A
MANY THE BILL BECAUSE ACTUALLY
REMOVED THE PROVISION THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STUDENT ID'S A
CONTAINED A HOTLINE DIRECTLY.
FOR SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
HOWEVER WHEN WE REVIEWED AGAIN
THE HOT WINDS ARE LISTA FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALMOND AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT WITH A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITE IN PARTICULAR WE
KNOW IT'S UNFORTUNATELY AT THOSE
SITES STILL CONTAIN.
THE SAME KIND OF MESSAGES THAT
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST --
BUT THOSE ARE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL BE ADDRESS SO WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNTIL THOSE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL ARE DRESSED BUT WE
DO SUPPORT THE IDEA.
OF PROVIDING SOME KIND OF A
DIRECT CONNECTION SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN GET SUPPORTS OF ANY
PARTICULAR FAIR VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- GREG BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR MR GABLE YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE THREE I YET
INTERN FATALITY ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE -- WE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU --
WITH THAT WE WILL -- GOING TO
THE NEXT.
ITEM AND WAIT FOR A QUORUM TO
TAKE THE VOTE AND THE NEXT ITEM
WILL BE.
ITEM. SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN MISS
PER WHEN AB [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX WELCOME
MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
MEMBER -- I GREATLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE INPUT FROM COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
CALIFORNIA'S JUST ONE OF A
HANDFUL OF STATES LACKING A DATA
SYSTEM THAT SPANS ACROSS
EDUCATIONAL SEGMENTS AND INTO
THE WORKFORCE.
OUR CURRENT DATA SYSTEMS
EXISTENCE SILOS.
DO NOT TALK TO EACH OTHER AND
THAT MEANS POLICY MAKERS AND
RESEARCHERS ARE UNABLE TO ANSWER
BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENT
PROGRESS OUTCOMES.
US SUCH AS THIS -- AS SOON
PROGRESS AND OUTCOMES SUCH AS
WATER LONG TERM EFFECTS OF STATE
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS AND
SPENDING AN EARLY IN PRIMARY
EDUCATION.
HOW WELL ARE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
GRADUATES PREPARED TO SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE WHAT EQUITY GAP EXISTS
WITHIN THE EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR AND THOSE
FROM DISADVANTAGED SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS?
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX WOULD
CREATE A TASK FORCE A COMPOSED
OF CROSS CUTTING GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO STUDY THE
CREATION OF A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM AND PRODUCE A PLAN THAT
ADDRESSES.
KEY ISSUES OF STRUCTURE GOVERNOR
AND GOVERNANCE AND ACCESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SERRA
R. C. SENIOR DIRECTOR OF POLICY
IN ADVOCACY WITH THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY -- A
STATEWIDE POLICY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
DO YOU KNOW WE'RE CALIFORNIANS
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES APPLY TO
ENROLL IN COLLEGE.
DO WE KNOW IF STUDENTS ARE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFERRED FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO UC'S CS
USE OUR OTHER FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS.
WHAT ARE THE WORK FORCE OUTCOMES
OF THOSE WHO DO NOT GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL OR WHO
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL BUT
DO NOT ATTEND COLLEGE?
THE CAMPAIGN SUPPORTS A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BECAUSE IT
WOULD SET CALIFORNIA ON A PATH
TOWARDS ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THAT WILL ENABLE THE STATE TO
ANSWER THESE CRITICAL QUESTIONS
AND TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES ROAD BLOCKS AND
OUTCOMES OF OUR STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND THE REST
OF THE NATION IN THIS REGARD WE
KNOW THAT IN THE COMING YEARS
THE STATE WILL NEED A GROWING
SUPPLY OF EDUCATED WORKERS TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF A DYNAMIC
STATE ECONOMY.
AND WE CANNOT MEET THAT WITHOUT
ENSURING THE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
OF STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
HOWEVER SILO TO HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM WITH DATA THAT IS NOT
LINKED TO OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS FROM WHERE OUR STUDENTS
COME.
NOR IS LINKED TO THE WORK FORCE
WHERE STUDENTS WILL GO MEANS WE
ARE UNABLE TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST -- OF TO TO CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO ADDRESS GROWING
EQUITY GAPS IN EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS AND MEET FUTURE WORK
FORCE DEMANDS REST ON ANSWERING
THESE CRITICAL QUESTIONS.
OTHERWISE THE STATE LACKS AN
INCOMPLETE PICTURE ABOUT WHO THE
SYSTEMS ARE SERVING WELL WHO IS
BEING LEFT BEHIND WHEN THEY'RE
BEING LEFT BEHIND AND WHY.
AN INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM FROM
EARLY EDUCATION FOR TO WORK
FORCE ALLOWS POLICYMAKERS TO
ANSWER THESE CRITICAL QUESTIONS
AND IN NAPLES THE DATE INFORMED
DECISION MAKING THAT IS CRITICAL
TO ADDRESSING.
GROWING EQUITY GAPS IN STUDENT
SUCCESS IMPORTANTLY CAN BETTER A
GUIDE POLICY SO LUCIEN'S AND
INVESTMENTS AND HELP US ASSESS
THE IMPACT OF THOSE EFFORTS --
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN TO
IT ON BEHALF OF ADVICE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF AT
IMPROVE SYSTEMS OF TRANSPARENCY
SO WE CAN SEE IN IN P. TWENTY
PROGRAMS -- WHAT WHERE THE
SUCCESSES ARE AND WHAT WE NEED
TO REPLICATE AND THAT ALSO WE
CAN POINT OUT MIL ELIMINATE THE?
INEQUITIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM SO WE
APPRECIATE THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
ASSESSMENT DATA.
ARE SO THAT WE CAN GET A BETTER
IDEA OF STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT THAT
THAT'S MORE TRANSPARENT SO THANK
YOU.
CATHERINE NEVER GONE ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS SEE.
NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES DOCTOR CHOI.
MY CONCERN NOT WHEN THIS ONE IS
SO WHEN YOU COLLECT -- KNOWN TO
OUR TO A DINNER IS DATA -- OF
EACH IS JUNE ON THE IS THERE ANY --
WAY YOU CAN PROTECT YOUR PRIVACY
ONCE THAT THE DATA.
IS COLLECTED THE US SO VAST
AMOUNT OF LAW.
A DATA ONE H. SHOULD -- THAT
WELL THAT'S ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS IS MAKING SURE THAT THE
DATA WOULD BE PROPERLY --
PROTECTED AND AND YOU KNOW THAT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT ENCRYPTION
OR ANONYMIZING.
DATA.
SO -- WE HAD THERE'S ANOTHER
BILL IN THE SENATE THAT'S
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE TO AND AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
GOVERNOR SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD ASSEMBLY VEHICLE AND
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST ISSUES IS.
A DEFINING HOW -- TO PROTECT
THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION.
SO WHO'S GONNA MANAGER OR OF THE
STATE.
OF WE HAVE NOTS WE WE GET OTHER
SOME TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
GOVERNING BODY YOU KNOW BEEN IN
THE PREVIOUS ITERATIONS WHAT THE
GOVERNING BODY WOULD BE BUT
WE'VE LEFT -- THAT ISSUE OF YEAH
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THAT'S
HERE THESE ARE ON CHARTER
TERRITORIES FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT'S WHY.
I'M THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A TASK
FORCE AS THIS BILL DOES IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT WE GET
THE SYSTEM RIGHT AND AND ONE
OTHER CHARGES IS TO KIND OF COME
BACK WITH.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON
GOVERNANCE AND HOW WE PROTECT
YOUR PRIVACY OKAY FINALLY TO
HAVE ANY -- THE BUDGET NECESSARY
[inaudible]
IMPLEMENTED SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE AYE AYE IT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE IS --
MONEY I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH BUT
THE WE'RE WE'RE REALLY TODAY
JUST TALKING ABOUT THE THE
POLICY OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE -- TO TRACK STUDENT UP
PROGRESS LIKE I MENTIONED BEFORE
MANY STATES -- HAVE THIS IN
PLACE ALREADY AT ALL AND I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA --
FOLLOW SUIT SO YOU CAN LOOK AT
WHAT OUR OUR GOOD PRACTICES SO
FOR INSTANCE IF YOU HAVE.
THOSE BEEN A LOT OF THE LC FF IT
IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE.
BEEN -- THE THE THE MOORED.
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND YOU
WANT TO SEE HOW IS THAT MONEY
BEING SPENT AND AND ARE YOU
GETTING BETTER OUTCOMES AND THIS
IS EXACTLY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU COULD -- BE TRACKING
RIGHT NOW IN SOME WAYS -- WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD WAY -- TO
TRACK THOSE THINGS ARE GONNA
TAKE UP TOO MUCH TIME BUT THE
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME IN A
SITUATION WHAT KIND OF A DATA --
SPECIFIC INFORMATION WILL BE
CRITICAL. FOR THIS SYSTEM TO BE
DEVELOPED.
HOW THAT'LL HELP?
YOU COULD BE LOOKING AT OF
HEALTH BEHAVIORS IN KINDERGARTEN
AND GRADES IN KINDERGARTEN --
THE HOW HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE IN
A CLASS YOU COULD BE.
LOOKING AT OUT CUT HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE DROPPING OUT HOW
MANY STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING
FROM CERTAIN HIGH SCHOOL GOING
DIRECTLY INTO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOW MANY ARE GOING ON CAREER
PATHWAYS YOU KNOW STARTING EARLY
ON IF YOU STARTED WITH THE
CAREER PATHWAY LIKE OF THEIRS.
HAPPENING A LOT OF THE HIGH
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW -- HOW MANY
STUDENTS MAINTAIN THAT CAREER
PATHWAY WHERE IS IT THAT YOU CAN
BEST SPEND RESOURCES TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES?
YOU PROBABLY HAVE SOME SPECIALS.
I'M SORRY YOU OUT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS DATE ARE.
FROM MY KINDERGARTEN.
THAT MEANT THREE ALL THE WAY
MIGHT BEHAVE YES MY GREYS SO
WHERE I LIVED OUT.
AND THEN ALSO -- BECAUSE EACH
SCHOOL STATISTICS.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING TO TO DO IS MAKE SURE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM WOULD
INTER CONNECTED A SYSTEMS FROM.
EARLY CHILDHOOD READ THROUGH K.
THROUGH TWELVE THROUGH POST
SECONDARY THROUGH THE WORK FORCE
INDIVIDUAL.
MORE COMPLETE PICTURE OF A
STUDENT'S TRAJECTORY THROUGH OUR
EDUCATION HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS AND FOR TO WORK FOR SO
WE CAN UNDERSTAND HOLD IT BE
USED BY THE EMPLOYERS.
BEFORE WHEN I HI YOU YOU --
WOODEN.
ACCESS TO THAT DATA AND THEN
ANALYZE SO HOW YOU GREW UP OF
LOOKING OF OF ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT -- WITH YOUR TEACHER
TALKED ABOUT YOU.
I I DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THAT
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE USED BY EMPLOYERS THIS IS
REALLY MORE ART.
GET MAKING SURE THAT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS PERFORMING
THE WAY THAT IT SHOULD BUT ALL
OF THAT STILL HAS TO BE DEFINED
THIS IS REALLY THE THE CONCEPT
OF OF MAKING SURE THAT THAT DATA
IS AVAILABLE.
TO LOOK AT THE YOU KNOW.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
THE CORRECT -- CORRECT POLICIES
IN PLACE AND PUTTING BACK
RESOURCES IN THE CORRECT PLACES
ALL I DON'T KNOW YOU ARE SAYING
MORE DATA SPEED UP BUT I'M VERY
WE WE KNOW WHEN.
FIRST ORDER.
INFORMATION IS.
IS OF BROUGHT TO LIFE IS
ACCUMULATED AND OF HOW THAT ARE
THE USED TO BUY HOME IN A AND
THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE DEFINED
STILL CERTAINLY WE ALL HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT OUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS USED AND AND AND
THE THE WE JUST HAD THE PRIVACY
INITIATIVE PASSED WHICH PUTS.
A LOT OF RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT WE
NEED TO PROTECT THAT DATA WE
NEED TO HAVE AN ENCRYPTED WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT -- THAT THAT INFORMATION IS
PROTECTED BUT THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT YOU DON'T
USE DATA FOR GOOD THERE IS THERE
IS.
USING BIG DATA CAN HELP WITH
RESEARCH IT CAN HELP -- CHANGE
OUTCOME SO OF YOU KNOW WHAT WE
WE HAVE THIS INFORMATION IN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PLACES THIS IS
BEING ABLE TO PUT IT TOGETHER
AND AND DETERMINE HOW OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IS DOING AND
WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE.
THANK.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER.
OF I JUST ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHENEVER YOU OF A QUORUM.
RIGHT.
COURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE
AS WE WORK -- TO SOLVE THIS LONG
STANDING ISSUE OF SILO DATA.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
FOR A NEXT.
ITEM.
FIVE AB SIX NINETY SEVEN MR TING.
WHAT THE FAQ MATURE THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ME?
ON THIS LEGISLATION I KNOW THAT --
THIS LEGISLATION WAS.
INTRODUCED TO LATER THAN MOST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT --
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US.
THIS LEGISLATION WAS INTRODUCED
TO VERY MUCH IN RESPONSE TO THE
IGNITION SCANDAL THAT HAS REALLY
ROCKED.
THE COUNTRY AND FRANKLY ROCKED
MANY OF THE ELITE INSTITUTIONS
AROUND -- AROUND THE STATE AND
ALSO AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE FAMILIES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE SCANDAL WERE
CALIFORNIANS.
THE COMPANY THAT DID IT WAS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMPANY --
THE UNIVERSES OF THE CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS ALSO THE TOP RECIPIENT
OF CAL GRANTS -- HAD THE MOST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CHEAT THEIR WAY
INTO THE SCHOOL -- SO WHAT WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS -- TAKE A STEP OF
SEPARATE TAKE A STEP BACK FROM
THE ORIGINAL BILL THAT WE
PROPOSED AROUND.
CAL GRANT SOME PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT AND COME UP WITH SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD LIKE --
TO ASK THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
AND AND TO PASS -- TO GIVE US A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
REFINING AND AMENDING THIS
LEGISLATION -- WE AGAIN --
COMMIT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT WE
WOULD NOT SET THE BILL IN
APPROPRIATIONS WITHOUT WORKING
THINGS OUT WITH THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS.
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
AGREED TO AS OF RIGHT NOW BUT
I'VE OBVIOUSLY WILL CONTINUE
REFINE OUR ONE THAT WE WOULD.
STRIKE THE CURRENT CONTENTS OF
AB.
SIX NINE SEVEN AND WE WOULD
SPECIFIED WHEN WE WOULD STATE
NOW THAT SPECIFIED THAT A
QUALIFYING INSTITUTION FOR THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM THAT GIVES
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT ADMISSION.
TO APPLICANTS WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP TO A DONOR OR
ALUMNI AT THE INSTITUTIONS SHALL
DISCLOSE ALL OF THE FOLLOWING.
ONE IS THE NUMBER OF APPLICANTS
WHO DID IN THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS WHO DID NOT MEET THE
INSTITUTIONS EMISSIONS STANDARDS.
REQUIRED OF ALL OTHER APPLICANTS
BUT WERE OFFERED ADMISSIONS TO
THE NUMBER OF THOSE IN.
NUMBER ONE WHO ACCEPTED THE
OFFER OF ADMISSION.
AND THREE THE NUMBER OF THOSE IN
TWO AND ROLLED AT THE
INSTITUTION.
SO AS WE ARE MERELY ASKING. FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK.
DATA -- ON ON THE INSTITUTIONS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM BUT WHO ARE
ADMISSION A MEETING --
APPLICANTS BASED ON A DONOR FOR
ALUMNI PREFERENCE -- SO WITH
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND
THAT'D TAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR IN ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN [inaudible]
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON SORRY TESTING
MIKE FROM.
OKAY.
ALEX GRAYS THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES -- WE HAD
SUBMITTED -- A POSITION LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE OF OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST OUR CONCERNS WITH
INDICATED THAT LETTER -- WAS THE
TIE -- IN THE MANDATE TO
PARTICIPATION FOR INSTITUTIONS
IN THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE'VE HAD.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO DO SELL --
AND I THINK AT LEAST AS I
UNDERSTAND IN THE CONVERSATION I
JUST HAD ABOUT -- CAN BE INTENT
I THINK I DON'T KNOW.
IN LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW FOR
POSITION WILL CHANGE I THINK WE
REMAIN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TIDE OF THE CAL GRANT I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE'VE INDICATED THAT
WHERE -- WILLING TO EXPLORE --
POLICIES OR DISCLOSURE REPORTING
WHAT HAVE YOU -- OUTSIDE OF THAT
THAT CONTEXT OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS AS CAL GRANTS ARE FOR
STUDENTS -- THAT AGAIN EYES WHEN
REITERATE THAT WILL BE HAPPY TO
TO ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BUT OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST
CONCERN REMAINS -- THE THE TIDE
OF THE CAL GRANT -- IS YOU KNOW --
THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS -- WE HAVE OVER TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CAL GRANT
STUDENTS OVER.
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND RECIPIENTS --
AND 47% OR CAL GRANT POPULATION
IS LATINO AND 49% OF THE FIRST
THEIR FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE
SO FIRST AND FOREMOST WE JUST
WANT TO INSURE THAT.
THAT -- THERE'S NO --
JEOPARDIZING OF THEIR ACCESS TO
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT OUR OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE COMMITTED TO
EMISSIONS RECRUITING POLICIES
THAT ARE GROUNDED IN THE
COMMITMENT TO INTEGRITY AND
ETHICAL CONDUCT.
AND IN THE WAKE OF THE SCANDAL
WHICH I THINK WAS SHOCKING TO IN
ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS THEY
HAVE BEEN TAKING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW.
THEIR OWN INTERNAL POLICIES
PROCEDURES AND PROTOCOLS.
AND OUR INSTITUTIONS DON'T HAVE
A SEPARATE ADMISSIONS POLICY OR
APPLICANT POOL -- FOUR CRITERIA
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE -- WHAT
WOULD BE REFERRED TO IN THIS
INSTANCE IS A LEGACY IN THOSE
WHOM?
RELATED TO AN ALUMNI OR WHO MAY
FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTION TO THE
UNIVERSITY -- OUR COLLEGES TO
UTILIZE HOLISTIC ADMISSIONS
REVIEW HICH IS A STRATEGY THAT
ASSESSES THE APPLICANT UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES OR QUALITIES BEYOND
JUST MEASURES OF THEIR TEST
SCORES ARE GPA.
AND IT'S A PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED TO ME BY.
OUR ADMISSIONS STAFF IS ONE PART
SCIENCE ONE PART ART BUT IT
ALLOWS THEM TO LOOK AT A NUMBER
OF FACTORS THAT CAN BENEFIT
STUDENTS IN EMISSIONS RUBIO --
INCLUDING YOU KNOW IF YOUR FIRST
GENERATION OR A BETTER AND IF
THE STUDENT HAS OVERCOME
SIGNIFICANT OBSTACLES TO GET TO
COLLEGE WITH -- IS INDICATED IN
THEIR PERSONAL STATEMENT OR IN
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION -- YOU
KNOW THEY CAN ALSO -- LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW HERE'S YOUR
GPA BUT WHAT.
WHAT AMOUNT OF AYE A BEER AP OR
IB COURSES ARE AVAILABLE AND DID
YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THEM IF
YOUR INSTITUTION DOESN'T OFFER
MANY OF THEM IN ANY NUMBER OF
THESE THINGS IN THE?
IN THE ADMISSIONS POLICIES AND
THAT ARE SET ON THE FRONT END
FOR ALL APPLICANTS BE REVIEWED
AGAINST -- ANY NUMBER THESE CAN
BE -- MEASURED IN A WAY THAT A
STUDENT COULD COULD RECEIVE A
BENEFIT AND THEY'RE IN THEIR
APPLICATION SO -- WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS --
BUT AGAIN OUR CONCERN FIRST AND
FOREMOST REMAINS ABOUT THE TIED
TO THE CAL GRANT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
DOCTOR.
SORRY I HAVE A TOO MANY
QUESTIONS CHAIR -- NO SUCH THING
IN MY OPINION.
HERE ARE A SEE.
YOUR BILL IS.
NOT ONE OF THE SIX A MEASURE SO
INTRODUCED IN THE WAKE OF THE
THE RECENT COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
SCANDAL.
ARE HAVE YOU SEEN -- FIVE PHOTO
APPEARANCE SO HOW WE CAN
CONSOLIDATE THAT TOGETHER.
DO WE HAVE TO DEAL EACH
INDIVIDUAL OR ALL OF THIS IS SIX
BEERS A SEPARATE.
IT'S IT'S IT'S A GREAT -- IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION DOCTOR CHOI --
MISTER LOWE MISS MCCARTY WHO'S
COMING UP NEXT ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT PIECES.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE DID DIFFERENT
BILLS BECAUSE THEY ALL -- ARE
DIFFERENT PIECES OF CODE SO
AGAIN MY MIND WAS AMENDING TO
SPECIFIC EDUCATION CODE AROUND
CAL GRANTS -- WITHOUT GOING INTO
GREAT DETAIL BUT WITH ALL THE
OTHER BILLS ARE THEY ALL DO
DIFFERENT THINGS SO THAT WAS
THAT PARTICULAR REASON WHY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I CAN GIVE YOU A BETTER
ANSWER FOR THAT.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
NO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SEARCH OF JUST ON THE IN IN
RESPONSE TO THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES I
I WOULD SAY -- THAT IS NOT
ENTIRELY TRUE FOR HIM TO SAY
THAT THERE'S NOT A SEPARATE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS BECAUSE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS OR THERE
ISN'T -- IS VERY WELL DOCUMENTED
THAT ALUMNI AND DONOR --
RELATIONSHIP CHILDREN WITH OUR
STUDENTS WITH ALUMNI OR DONOR
RELATIONSHIPS.
GET AND AT A SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER RATE THAN CAL GRANT
STUDENTS AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT IS A FACT THAT'S AN
UNDISPUTED FACT FRANKLY.
AND SO -- IF IF THEY'RE ALL
BEING EVALUATED UNDER THE SAME
CRITERIA WHY DOES ONE GROUP OF
STUDENTS -- SEEM TO GET IT AT A
MUCH MUCH HIGHER RATE.
THAN OTHERS -- AND AND FRANKLY
WE WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
PROBABLY BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PUBLIC.
DATA THIS IS ALL BASED ON
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION IF YOU
SCOUR THE INTERNET IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT PUBLISHED NOT
DOCUMENTED.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE
ARE ASKING FOR THE COMMITTEES
ASSISTANCE.
TO GET MORE INFORMATION IF IF
THE FACTS ARE THAT EVERYONE'S
GETTING INTO THE SAME RATE AND I
THINK THAT'S THEN IT'S
COMPLETELY TRUE WELL WHAT THE
GENTLEMAN SAYS.
IF THEY ARE GETTING IN A
DIFFERENT -- RATES THAT'S THE
STRIKES ME AS TWO DIFFERENT
DOORS TWO DIFFERENT PROCESSES
I'M ALSO IN TERMS OF CAL GRANTS
AYE AYE TO SHOW THE CONCERN I
KNOW YOU HAVE A CONCERN AROUND
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE -- TO IN
EXPLORING THE ISSUE WITH LEAD
COUNSEL THAT WAS -- THEIR ADVICE
ON THE DIRECTION TO GO IF THERE
ARE OTHER DIRECTIONS WE ARE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO EXPLORE.
OTHER.
WAYS -- TO TO GET THIS
INFORMATION SO WITH SO WE'RE
VERY OPEN -- WHEN I WOULD ASK IS
DURING THIS PERIOD IN THE NEXT --
FEW WEEKS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY WORK WITH
THE PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS AND SEE
IF WE CAN FIND A PATH THAT'S A
LITTLE MORE AMENABLE TO ALL OF
US.
BUT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY DO
ASK FOR YOUR AYEVOTE FOR A. B.
SIX NINE SEVEN SO WE CAN HAVE.
FRANKLY A LITTLE MORE TIME WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS HAD BEEN READ
AND HANDED OUT.
I I WANT TO ASK THE AUTHOR AND
TO MAKE CLEAR.
THAT THE AUTHOR WILL NOT HAVE
THIS MEASURE HEARD IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND TELL THE BILL
IS IN PRINT.
ABSOLUTELY AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
WHAT I STATED EARLY AND
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH.
AND WE WON'T HEAR IT WITHOUT.
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRS
APPROVAL SIGNING OFF ON BOTH OF
THOSE -- AND AND AND LET ME JUST
FURTHER MAKE THE COMMENT THAT
TODAY I I I STARTED THE DAY WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY -- THE
PRESS CONFERENCE ON EXPANDING
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND WE
HEARD HERE.
AND COMMITTEE -- THERE'S BEEN
TWENTY YEARS SINCE -- CAL GRANT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN EXPANDED -- I
KNOW THIS BODY IS WORKING.
DILIGENTLY TO EXPAND THE CAL
GRANT WE ALSO HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE A BILL -- TO TO
ESTABLISH THE FORMULA SO THAT
THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE
TO KEEP COMING BACK.
A YEAR AFTER YEAR -- TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THE CADRE STAYS
THE SAME FOR THE PRIVATES AS
WELL -- I I THINK WE ALL VALUE
THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE I THINK TWO
OR THREE IN MY OWN DISTRICT --
THEY THEY ARE VALUABLE
INSTITUTIONS INSTITUTIONS WERE
OUR STUDENTS GAIN MUCH FROM
ATTENDING.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OUR STUDENTS ARE CONTINUED TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND THAT SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THE CAL
GRANT IS AVAILABLE ACROSS THE
BOARD -- TO ALL STUDENTS WHETHER
THEY ATTEND PUBLIC.
AND PRIVATE.
BUT THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON YOUR BILL.
AB SO IN THE END THANK YOU AND
AGAIN WE WOULD LOVE CAL GRANTS
AND WE ACTUALLY LOVE ALL OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN THE STATE.
AND I GUESS WE STILL DO NOT HAVE
A CORE.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR.
THANK YOU WITHOUT YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER MCCARTY.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO BILLS TO
PRESENT.
I DON'T FIFTEEN AN ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT FIRST.
HOW ABOUT -- ACR -- SIXTY FOUR I
DON'T.
TWENTY FIVE IT WOULD NOT LOOK AT
THE TOP SHEET ON MY PACKET AND
START WITH ITEM TWENTY WRITER.
YES SO I WOULD LIKE TO START BY.
ADDRESSING OUR VICE CHAIR DR
CHOI THAT THISIS. ONE OF THAT
FIVE MEASURES AS FAR AS THIS
PACKAGE THE SIXTH PIECE IS AN
AUDIT.
I REQUEST FOR AN AUDIT OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS OTHER FIVE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. ONE IS
THAT A TAX MEASURE SAYING THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO FRAUDULENTLY --
MADE CONTRIBUTIONS CAN'T USE
THAT AS A TAX DEDUCTION SO IT'S
IN THE REVAN TAX CODE -- ONE'S A
REGULATION THE BEING P. THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS CODE AS FAR
AS THE COLLEGE CONSULTANTS.
THE OTHER THREE ARE HIGHER
EDUCATION BILLS OF WHICH WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE THREE RIGHT
HERE SO THIS IS AN AC ARE
RELATED. TO THE SAT ACT ISSUE
OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST THIS --
OPERATION VARSITY BLUES WE KNOW --
KIND OF ROCK THE THAT THE NATION
AS FAR AS THE AUDACITY OF THE
FRAUD AND UNDERMINE THE PUBLIC
TRUST IN THE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS AND AND FURTHER
PERPETUATED THE QUESTION AS FAR
AS WHAT ABOUT THESE TROOPS.
OPPORTUNITY GAPS IN COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY OF COURSE THERE WAS
OUT RIGHT FRAUD WITH THIS SAT
AND ACT EXAMPLES OF INDIVIDUALS.
PAYING OFF THE PROCTORS TO
CHANGE THE ANSWERS -- HAVING
DOCTORS -- FAKE -- DISABILITIES
TO GET MORE TIME -- TO TO TAKE
THE EXAM.
OTHERS AN EXAMPLE IN BEFORE THIS
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WERE IN
NEW YORK A LONG ISLAND HIGH
SCHOOL -- COHORT OF STUDENTS
WERE CAUGHT IN A SCHEME WHERE
THEY THAT PAID -- TEST TAKERS TO
GO AND TAKE THESE -- PLACEMENT
EXAMS AND SO.
THIS IS AS OUT RIGHT -- FRAUD
ILLEGAL ACTIONS BUT IT RAISES
THE BIGGER QUESTION AS FAR AS
YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT THIS SAT SAT
EXAM YOU KNOW IS IT TIME TO TO
RE EVALUATE IT -- THERE ARE A
THOUSAND COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS OUR NATION
THAT HAVE NEXT THE SAT AND SAT.
AND THEY ARE DOING WELL LOOK AT
OTHER MEANS TO IDENTIFY THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE STUDENTS.
AND SO WE'RE ASKING HERE IS IT A
C. R. -- PROPOSAL TO ASK THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CSU SYSTEM TO CONDUCT A STUDY ON
THE USEFULNESS EFFECTIVENESS AND
NEED FOR THE SAT AND ACT TO
DETERMINE STUDENT MISSIONS.
AND THAT THE PROPOSAL WE HAVE
FOR BEFORE US TODAY.
AND THAT WITH ME ARE TO STUDENTS
ALEX LOPEZ A STUDENT UC BERKELEY
AND NESTOR CARTOONISTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND NESTOR CARTON AS A STUDENT
AT UCLA.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SOMEONE NAME IS
ALEX LOPEZ I'M FROM UC BERKELEY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE WITH SAT
AND SAT TESTING.
AS A FORM OF EMISSIONS
EVALUATION -- SO ACR SIXTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THE EDUCATIONAL GAPS
THAT ARE UNACCOUNTED FOR IN
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS PARTICULARLY
FOR UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF.
AS A LOW INCOME FOR GENERATION
LETTING A COLLEGE STUDENT
GETTING INTO A PRESTIGIOUS
UNIVERSITY LIKE UC BERKELEY
SEEMED UNREACHABLE.
BECAUSE OF THE DISADVANTAGES
PLACE BY EXAMS LIKE THE SAT AND
ACT.
I HAD TO APPLY MYSELF OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM TO FIND SUPPORT
WITH TEST PREP BUT EVEN THEN I
STRUGGLE TO REACH A COMPETITIVE
TEST SCORE IN EITHER EXAM.
MY HIGH SCHOOL ONLY OFFER TWO AP
CLASSES AND MY JUNIOR YEAR ON
TOP OF IT F. EXTRACURRICULAR
PROGRAMS.
AND A FULL DAY SCHOOL THEY
SCHEDULE I ENCOURAGE MY PEERS TO
SIGN UP WITH ME FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSES. TO CHALLENGE
OURSELVES AS A LATINO LOW INCOME
STUDENT FROM THE EAST BAY I HAVE
TO SEARCH FOR COST FREE PROGRAMS
TO DEMONSTRATE MY POTENTIAL
APART FROM THE SAT OR ACT. FOR
EXAMPLE I SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
THREE SUMMERS IN STAFFORD
THROUGH THIS MATCH LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD AND STEW PROGRAM. TO
ENHANCE MY MATH SCIENCE AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE SKILLS THAT MY
PEERS BLACK TO BACK HOME IN MY
HIGH SCHOOL.
WITHOUT NONPROFIT PROGRAMS IN MY
OWN URGENCY TO SEEK WAYS TO
ENRICH MYSELF I WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO ATTEND UC BERKELEY SO I ASK
YOU THAT YOU TAKE ACTION TO
ASSURE THAT MORE MINORITY UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS.
ARE GRANTED AN EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY INTO COLLEGE THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTHY.
I LIKE TO THINK YOU OFFER HAVING
HERE AND FOR PROVIDING ME WITH
THE PLATFORM TO VOICE MY
TESTIMONY.
MY NAME IS MAY I'M GONNA.
ADDRESS TO STOP BECAUSE WE WE
FINALLY HAVE A QUORUM AND I WANT
TO ESTABLISH A CORE.
WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU.
WE'RE GONNA STATUS A QUORUM
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MEDINA HERE CHOI [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
MOVE THE BELL.
WE HAVE A CORE.
PLEASE CONTINUE.
MY NAME IS NESTER KIND OF AN
**** AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES AS A STUDENT WHO.
HAS SURVIVED THE KEY TO TWELVE
EDUCATION ACADEMIC PIPELINE I AM
HERE TO STRONG SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ROSE TO COMBAT
FUTURE FRAUDULENT PRIMARIES.
AND OR FRAUDULENT ENROLLMENTS
PREVENTING THE CONTINUOUS
OBSTRUCTION OF EDUCATION ABILITY
AND OPPORTUNITY THAT IS EVIDENT
THAT EXISTS TODAY FOR STUDENTS
COMING FROM DIVERSE AND TO WEAR
NON AFFLUENT BACKGROUNDS.
MY EXPERIENCE NAVIGATING THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE PIPELINE WAS ONE
OF THE MOST STRENUOUS HURDLES
THAT I HAD TO FACE.
AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THAT IS A
THOROUGHLY DIVIDED AWARE IN MANY
CASES PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
UNDERFUNDED LACK OF RESOURCES.
AND STUDENTS UNDERGO COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR SCHOOLS
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE INDEX
SCORES IT'S SOMETHING THAT
AFFLUENT SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT FURTHER I NAVIGATED
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THROUGH
TOLL IN ROMAN COLLEGE CLASSES.
ON TOP OF MY HIGH SCHOOL WORK
QUARTERS.
I WAS ALSO INVOLVED AND ANSWER
THE TRAINING FOR THE LOS ANGELES
MARATHON THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
YEAR FOR TWO CONSECUTIVE YEARS.
AND ALSO IN AND ALSO ENTERED FOR
THE GARMENT WORKER CENTER OF LOS
ANGELES FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS ARE AT GREATER
DISADVANTAGE WHEN APPLYING TO
ELITE UNIVERSITIES.
MANY COME FROM EDUCATION A
HUMBLE BACKGROUNDS WERE HAVING
ACCESS TO ONE ON ONE TUTORING IS
NOT A POSSIBILITY AMONGST ALL
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND ELITE UNIVERSITIES MANY
HAD TO BE VALEDICTORIANS.
OR TOP UP OR TOP 10% OF THE
GRADUATING CLASS YOU CAN BE
CONSIDERED COMPETITIVE THIS
SHOWS HOW CLASSES AND ELITIST.
THESE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
REALLY ARE WHEN ADMITTED WHEN
ADMITTING STUDENTS AFFLUENT
FAMILIES BRIBING THEIR WAY INTO
THE LEAD UNIVERSITIES IS A FORM
OF OPPRESSION AND ILLEGAL ACT
THE FURTHER.
NEGATIVELY EXPLOITS ALL STUDENT
APPLICANTS TO THE SAID
UNIVERSITIES AT A GLOBAL LEVEL
INCLUDING PEOPLE LIKE ME.
WITH EVERY SENSE MENTIONED THIS
IS WHY I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF A. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
I AM NUMB.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS -- BO
[inaudible]
OR IT IS IT IS A RESOLUTION THIS
IS YOUR IS MEANT TO BE A
RESOLUTION.
YES IT IT'S A RESOLUTION.
I SEE.
IT'S A REQUEST FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CSU TO STUDY.
THE USEFULNESS OF THE YEAH.
I AM VERY FAMILIAR ARE -- ABOUT
THIS CITY ACT.
OF THESE SCORES.
ARE ARE VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
EVALUATION OF MEETING OUR
STUDENTS SO INTO COLLEGES SENIOR
UNIVERSITY IS SO I'M ON MANY OR
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND OR SOUL
GPA ETCETERA ETCETERA.
AND DID -- TWO ATOMIC MAJORS WHO
WERE USED TO FOR A LONG TIME.
AND THE TO MY OPINION THEY
WORKED OUT VERY WELL.
IT MAY NOT BE PERFECT.
BUT THEY IF YOU.
RECOMMEND THROUGH THE RESOLUTION.
OUR TO PHASE OUT THE THIS --
IMPORTANT.
A TO MAKE -- NAM MEASURING TOOLS.
I WONDER THE FUTURE OF THE
QUALITY.
OUR IN THIS STATE WHERE IT'LL GO.
AND THE MAYBE NEXT TIME.
ARE YOU MAY QUESTION THE
VALIDITY OF GPAS.
AND THE WHAT BASIS HOW CAN WE
USE.
OUR TO SORT OUT THE ON ON
UNFORTUNATELY.
OUR GOD HAS GIVEN US SELL OR
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF ABILITY IN
THE TALENTS -- AND THE BASED
UPON A THROUGH COMPETITION OUT
WE NURTURE BECAUSE SO WE CANNOT
SEND EVERYBODY TO A HARVARD DOES
DODD THE DIFFERENT NOT NAY US OF
A SCHOOL OR SO AND THAT THEIR
CHOICES -- AND THAT'S IT THIS
HAVE BEEN NOT VERY IMPORTANT --
TOURIST. TO MAJEL THAT KIND OF
LIABILITY SAID THAT COLIN SO.
BUT THE NOW WITH THIS IS SO
REVOLUTIONARY STEP.
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE IF
NOT THE IS AS A TEA AND THEN A.
C. T..
WHAT ARE THE MEASURES SO WOULD
YOU RECOMMEND THAT IF YOU AT THE
COLLEGE PRESIDENT THE HARVARD?
IN A WAR YOU YOU.
JUST SEE BERKELEY PRESTON HOW
WOULD YOU ADMIT A STUDENTS BASED
UPON WHAT.
WELL THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO AND THOUSAND COLLEGES
ARE ALREADY DOING THIS.
AND WHAT WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
ALSO.
A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY EVERY SAID
TEXAS THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
LOOKING AT TEST SCORES -- NOT TO
NOT TEST SCORES I'D GPA AND YOUR
CLASS RANK BECAUSE THERE'S
RESEARCH IS THOSE THAT YOUR
SUCCESS AMONG YOUR PEERS.
IS JUST THE EQUAL AS A PREDICTOR
OF YEAR SUCCESS IN COLLEGE THEN
YOU'RE YOU'RE AT SCORES ON THE
SAT ACT BUT THE BIGGER QUESTION
DOCTOR CHOI IS THAT.
WE'RE ASKING THE UC AND CSU. TO
STUDY THIS AND A POTENTIAL PHASE
OUT THEY MAY COME BACK AND SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE ARE FINE WITH THE S. A. T.
WE'D LIKE TO KEEP IT AS FRANKLY
WITH THE UC SYSTEM A BIG PART OF
BY A PIE Y. WORKS FOR THEM IS
JUST.
THE THE THE THE RAW NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS YOU KNOW.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
APPLICATIONS IT IS EASY TO SORT
THEM.
BY -- BY TEST SCORE THROUGH
THROUGH THE SAT SO AGAIN THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA -- AND THE
CSU SYSTEM ARE GOING.
TO STUDY THIS AND REPORT BACK TO
US SO IT'S NOT A GUARANTEED THAT
THIS WOULD HAPPEN IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THIS AND WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE UTILIZED GOING FORWARD.
I UNDERSTAND BUT THAT THIS IS SO.
I I THINK FOR YOUR GENESIS OF
THIS OUT RESOLUTION IS A YOU
KNOW QUESTIONING THE VALIDITY OF
NECESSITY AND THE A. C. T..
SO MUCH WE BEGIN THIS A
QUESTIONING -- RANKING STUDENTS
ACADEMIC ABILITIES SELF UP BASED
UPON THIS KIND BUT TOURISTS ARE
DONE WE CAN -- NEXT STEP WOULD
BE WE CAN A QUESTION.
ANY TYPE OF A QUESTION ARE.
AT THE VERY IT AT ALL LEVELS OF
A SCHOOL OR SO.
EVEN TEACHER SHOULD NOT GIVE ANY
TEST A HOW CAN YOU WRITE THOSE
CHILDREN.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT THE
RANKS -- GPAS CAN BE USED ABOUT
THE LATER MORE LIBERAL SOUGHT
CAN BE YOU DON'T WANT THAT WE
ARE ALL CREATED EQUAL HOW CAN
YOU RANK ME AND I HAVE A
DIFFERENT TALENTS AS SUCH AND
SUCH A SO A I I THINK THIS IS SO
CREATING.
OUR SOMETHING ON NECESSARY -- IN
A CAN WARM AND THEN IT MAY
JEOPARDIZE.
OUR FUTURE -- INTELLECTUAL ôNG.
ã DICK -- COMPETITIVENESS OUT
OF A WILL FIND SCORES SO THAT
THE WE WE POST ABOUT THOSE
THROUGH YOU SEE -- CAST A SYSTEM.
I I WILL A JUST A PERHAPS A
REPEAT.
THAT THIS BILL I THINK IS ASKING
FOR UC AND CSU TO DO A STUDY OF
WE HAVE NOT.
BUT THEY HAVE NOT DONE THE STUDY
SO THERE.
YOU KNOW THE DETERMINATION OF
WHAT THEY FIND AND THE IN THIS
STUDY IS TO BE DETERMINED.
AND I THINK THAT IS THE THE
INTENT OF THIS RESOLUTION --
THIS MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YEAH I I THINK THERE ARE THIS
WHOLE COLLEGE SCANDAL RAISES A
QUESTION NOT JUST PEOPLE --
ILLEGALLY MESSING AROUND THE SAT
BUT PEOPLE WITH MEANS AND
RESOURCES CAN.
TAKE SAT PREP US ARE WITNESSES
SAID AND IS THAT TRULY -- FOCUS
ON YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUCCESS OF A OF A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AND INTEL.
THERE ARE MANY POINTS OF
RESEARCH THAT THAT POINT TO THE
NEGATIVE THERE.
AND SO THIS IS GOING ALLOW THAT
ALLOW US TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD LOOK AT
WHAT A THOUSAND SCHOOLS ARE
DOING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND LOOK AT ALTERNATE MEANS TO
EVALUATE STUDENTS OTHER THAN
STANDARDIZED TESTS AND I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS ACR THANK
YOU.
IT ENJOYS -- A POSITIVE --
RECOMMENDATION -- I I BELIEVE
THAT A U. S. C..
YOU SEE RATHER EXCUSE ME.
UC -- HAS ALREADY BEEN ASKED FOR
SUCH A STUDY -- SO THIS WILL
BUILD ON THAT -- JUST WANT
CLARIFICATION IS THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF DID RECOMMEND
SOME SOME CHANGES FOR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND I
THINK -- THOUGHT THOSE ARE -- SO
THAT'S THE NEXT.
ONE YEAH. FOR BOB YES OKAY AND
AND WILL HELP YOU GET YEAR AND
WILL TAKE BECAUSE IT COULD THREE
SINGLE FOR YEAH [inaudible]
SO ACTUALLY.
MISS MCCARTY YEAH YES I I I FEEL
TO ASK THE QUESTION DO YOU DO
ACCEPT THE A MEMBER YES AGE FOUR
YES THANK YOU.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK -- I NEED A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER BLOW.
A MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI IN NO.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'D. EIGHT ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW MOVING ON TO I DON'T.
KNOW IF ANY ONE OF US SORRY
ABOUT THAT. EIGHT ONE YEAH.
ALL RIGHT ITEM FIFTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
I GET THEIR WORK THE LAST BILL
TODAY TO DO THE LAST THE LAST
BILL OF THE YEAR.
LAST OKAY THIS IS A THIS IS ALSO
PART OF THAT COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
REFORM PACKAGE.
THIS RELATED TO THESE SPECIAL
ADMITS THAT WE HEARD ABOUT THIS
IS THE AUDACITY WORK AN
INDIVIDUAL WAS.
AWARDED TO ADMISSION INTO A
UNIVERSITY FOR BEING A SPECIAL
ATHLETE LET'S SAY TO THE WATER
POLO TEAM.
LATER TO FIND OUT THE PERSON DID
EVEN PLAY WATER POLO AND MAY NOT
EVEN BE ABLE TO SWIM.
SO THIS WOULD ENSURE WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE A SPECIAL ADMITS
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CSU SYSTEM
THAT WE FRANKLY DOUBLE AND
TRIPLE CHECK. TO MAKE SURE THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE CERTAINLY --
WORTHY OF SUCH SPECIAL --
EXCEPTIONS THAT WE WERE
CERTAINLY SHOCKED TO SEE THAT
TEN OF THE SEVENTEEN EXAMPLES IN
THE US ATTORNEY'S ACTION WERE
BASED IN CALIFORNIA -- TO AT OUR
VERY OWN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT BERKELEY AND UCLA
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS. TO TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CALLS ADMISSIONS PROCESS IS FAIR
WE DON'T SQUEEZE OUT -- STUDENTS
LIKE MIGHT WITNESS HERE --
MISTER ALEX LOOK THIS THANK YOU
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT --
THE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME IS
ALEX LOPEZ -- FROM UC BERKELEY --
SO I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AGAIN
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND HARD WORK IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE OF
INEQUALITY.
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION -- TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS ARE
GUARANTEED EQUAL ACCESS TO
COLLEGE.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE INTENDS
TO PROTECT STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF
FROM LOSING A SEAT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DUE TO
FRAUDULENT ACTIONS TAKEN BY
ADULTS WHO DISREGARDED THE
EXHAUSTING PATH TO COLLEGETHAT
MANY MINORITY STUDENTS LIKE I
HAD TO TAKE.
AS A LOW INCOME FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT I WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD TO GET TO SEE
BERKELEY.
AND IT'S UPSETTING TO KNOW THAT
THE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD IN
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS HAS BEEN
OBSCURED BY WEALTH INEQUALITY.
I SPENT ENDLESS HOURS STUDYING
TO GAIN OF FOUR POINT FIVE GPA
TO HIGH SCHOOL IN HIGH SCHOOL
EXTRA HOURS AFTER SCHOOL
PARTICIPATING IN YOUTH COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS.
THIS HARD WORK HAS BEEN
DESPONDENT BY THESE CORRUPT OF
ACTIONS.
WELL SHOULD NOT BE THE SOLE
DETERMINANT FOR SOMEONE'S ACCESS
TO COLLEGE ESPECIALLY IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF ALREADY
HOLD A SMALLER PRESENCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REPORTED THAT 40% OF STUDENTS
ENROLLED WERE LOW INCOME AND 25%
WERE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
GOING STUDENTS.
I AM PART OF THE STATISTICS
TODAY MY PEERS AND I WHO HAVE
NOT HAD AN EASY PATH INTO THE UC
SYSTEM SHOULD NOT HAVE OUR SEATS
TAKEN AWAY BY WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS WHO PAY THEIR WAY
INTO COLLEGE.
THIS IS AN ATTACK ON ALL HARD
WORKING STUDENTS WHO HAVE ABIDED
BY A FAIR PROCESS AND IT'S
ESPECIALLY DISGRACEFUL FOR ME
AND OTHER STUDENTS AT THE UC WHO
ARE UNDERPRIVILEGED STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
ASK THAT YOU TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT ALL HARD WORKING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND SECURE EQUAL ACCESS TO
COLLEGE FOR ALL REGARDLESS OF
INCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITH WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
VERY BRIEFLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SOMEONE MEMBER CARD
A NO YOU'VE TAKEN THE LEAD ON
RESPONDING TO THE INITIAL
SCANDAL -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT BUT EMISSIONS BY EXCEPTION
IS NOT JUST LIMITED TO STUDENT
ATHLETES THAT IT INCLUDES OTHERS
INCLUDING FOLKS WHO HAVE MAYBE
BEEN.
FOSTER STUDENTS CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS EXTREMELY DISADVANTAGED
HAVE COUNTED IN IN THE ARTS --
AND OTHER THINGS AND SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROCEEDING THOUGHTFULLY HERE SO
I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT I WOULD JUST REQUEST
THAT YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH.
FOLKS AT UC AND CSU TO TALK TO
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DOING THIS SO THAT WE'RE GETTING
AT THE HEART OF WHAT YOU.
WANT TO DO WHICH IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN'T -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET FOLKS SLIP
THROUGH SHOULD BE AT ADMITTED
BUT ALSO THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING --
UNDUE PRESSURE ON THE UNIVERSITY
AND AND MAYBE EXCLUDING SOME
FOLKS THAT WE REALLY WOULD WANT
TO BE PART OF OF OUR SKIN BODY.
YES THANK IS BRIEFLY RESPOND TO
THE CHAIR I I MET RECENTLY WITH
THE CHANCELLOR CRISTINA YOUR
ALMA MATER UC BERKELEY.
GO BEARS.
AND AND THEN SHE TALKED ABOUT
THE PROCESS OF THEIR OUTLINING
THERE AND WE'RE GONNA LOOK ABOUT
INCLUDING THAT IN THE ENTIRE --
UC AND CSU SYSTEM IN THE BILL
AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST
ATHLETES THE COULD BE --
MUSICIANS OR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THIS
WOULDN'T PROHIBIT THESE ADMITS
THAT COLUMN -- ADMISSIONS BY
EXCEPTION BUT IT WOULD REQUIRE
FRANKLY DOUBLE AND TRIPLE
CHECKING TO MAKE SURE THE
INFORMATION IS ACCURATE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU
HAVE A COACH OR AN INDIVIDUAL.
VOUCHING FOR THESE STUDENTS AND
AS WE HEARD THEY WERE PAID OFF
ON THE SIDE SO THIS JUST BRINGS
MORE A CHECKS AND BALANCES TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE.
GIVING SOMEBODY A SEAT WHO
DESERVES IT AND NOT SQUEEZING
OUT A QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA
STUDENT.
DO.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
IN A MOTION BY.
MR LOW SECOND BY DOCTORS QUIRK I
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR ALSO
FOR BRINGING FORWARD -- AND
THANK THE STUDENTS.
I I THINK WE'VE SEEN HERE THIS
AFTERNOON -- OUTSTANDING HARD
WORKING STUDENTS STUDENTS WHO
PLAYED BY THE RULES FOLLOW THE
RULES GOING THROUGH -- DID WHAT
WAS ASKED OF THEM.
EXEMPLARY STUDENTS AND A AND AND
I THINK AS AS WE YOU KNOW GO
THROUGH THIS.
IT'S GOOD TO REMEMBER THAT THERE
ARE.
MANY MORE STUDENTS LIKE THE
STUDENT SITTING RIGHT IN FRONT
OF ME.
WHO DID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS AND
ARE THERE BY THEIR OWN HARD WORK --
I KNOW THAT -- YOU SEE IS AGAIN
STILL IN THE PROCESS THAT
THEY'VE BEGUN I SAT NEXT TO I
HAD THE CHANCE TO SIT NEXT TO
THE DEAN OF ADMISSIONS --
RECENTLY -- IT UC RIVERSIDE.
AND THAT THEY ARE AT EACH CAMPUS
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS OF RE
EXAMINING.
THE WHOLE ADMISSIONS PROCESS --
AND WE HOPE THAT -- GOOD WILL
COME OF IT.
SO WE HAD A A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND A MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AT ANY
AMENDMENTS SELFIE.
THE ASSEMBLY THAT SUGGESTION
THANK.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
UBER ARMY. TEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT [inaudible]
AND CALENDAR.
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVED BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I
ELEVEN ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR ELEVEN ZERO IT IS OUT
.
OKAY SO GO AND FILE ORDER.
ITEM ONE AB FORTY EIGHT I NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT BOATING.
QUIRK HI WORK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
NUMBER ONE AB.
FORTY EIGHT SANTIAGO I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I OKAY.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE LISTED BEFORE.
SEVEN NINE ZERO AB FORTY EIGHT
IS OUT.
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE FACT THAT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
HEY ITEM.
TO AB FIVE FORTY I NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
NUMBER.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE FORTY AND THE
CHOI NO.
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I NINE TO THE BILL IS OUT.
AB FIVE FORTY LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM FOUR AB SIX TWO FOUR I NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE NO QUIRK HI QUIRK I BLOOM.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER AVE. NINE TWO AB SIX TWO
FOUR IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
BEFORE WE CALL THE THE NEXT VOTE --
IT IS.
ITEM FIVE AB.
SIX NINE SEVEN THERE SHOULD BE
HOPEFULLY -- AND FRONT OF EVERY
SEE -- A PRINT OUT.
PRIOR TO REQUESTING A. B. SIX
EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN BE SET. FOR
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT YOU
HAVE THAT.
BUT YOU SEE THAT.
YEAH RIGHT SO THAT THAT IS THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN -- MR TANG AND
THE COMMITTEE THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE VOTING ON QUESTION AND ENJOY
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION AS
WELL YEAH YES IT DOES.
ITEM FIVE AB SIX NINE SEVEN I
NEED A WE NEED TO MAILLET THE
MOTION AND A SECOND SO MOVED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE.
THIS NEEDS A LOT OF WORK HI.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I TEN ZERO AB SIX NINE
SEVEN IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SIX AB SEVEN OH THREE I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
NOW MOVES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO AB SEVEN
ZERO THREE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL NOT VOTING -- WHEN --
WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE NO LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'D. NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY IS OUT IN THE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM EIGHT AB NINE SIX THREE I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE A NO QUIRK.
I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I NINE ONE AB NINE SIX
THREE IS OUT WE WOULD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM TEN AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MOVE.
THE MOTION IS PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO A. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR SOME MEMBERS.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWELVE TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THE MOTION AND A
SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I QUIRK.
I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WEBER.
WEBER I'D. ELEVEN ZERO AB TWELVE
TWENTY NINE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO AB THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN IS OUT WE'LL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN I IN A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO MOVED.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WEBER.
WEBER I CAN ZERO AB THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE SOME OF NO IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED -- SOME OF THE
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS OUT.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
A. B. C. ITEM SIX SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SIXTY AYE THE MOTION
AND A SECOND SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI A NO.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
CHOI A NOTE TO NOT VOTING. NINE
ONE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY IS OUT
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX I NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
SO MOVE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE NO QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW NO PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I NINETY TWO AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I AM NINETEEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND NO MOVE. NINETY A SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO EIGHT THE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE IS OUT
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I AM TWENTY AB SIXTEEN TWENTY I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MOVED.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHU I KNOW QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL [inaudible]
LUCKILY [inaudible]
THE GATE.
GABRIEL NOT VOTING -- WHEN NO
LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL NOT VOTING TO I NINE TWO
EIGHT SIXTEEN TWENTY IS OUT
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND SOME OF THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
DANA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I QUIRK.
QUIRK I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE APRIL I IRWIN --
WHEN I KILEY KILEY AYE LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE A. B. C. R.
[inaudible]
SIXTY FOUR PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
I AM.
TWENTY FIVE ACR [inaudible]
SIXTY FOUR YES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I NINE ONE ACR SIXTY
FOUR IS OUT -- OKAY AND THE ROLE
WILL STAY OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES
FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible] FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MICHAEL [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH [inaudible]
UHHUH [inaudible]
YOU CAN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WHAT.
THE YEAH YEAH YEAH.
I DON'T.
WANT [inaudible]
MOBILE.
YEAH THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO GO
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
AND THANKS I'LL GET I'LL GET
BETTER [inaudible]
YEAH
.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT HE FINALLY.
OKAY WITH IT MORE TWENTY FIVE
LINES OF ONE YEAH [inaudible]
WHAT I?
AND WE TALK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
WE'RE ADJOURNED